Good evening. In compliance with chapter
551 open meetings of the Texas
Government Code, I call to order an
information session of the board of
trustees of the Austin Independent
School District for Thursday, September
18th, 2025 at 6:04 p.m. A quorum of the
board is physically present at Austin
ISD central office to conduct this
meeting. The meeting is being broadcast
on cable channel 22 through Spectum
Spectrum Astound Broadband and on
channel 99 through AT&T Universe. Closed
captioning in English is available on
these platforms for individuals who are
deaf or heart of hearing. Welcome and
thank you for joining us. Next is an
opportunity for the public to share
comments with the board. This time
allows speakers to comment publicly on
any topic of their choosing directly to
the school board. We have time for up to
60 speakers. And as a reminder, the
district also provides time during the
regular voting meetings of the board to
hear from the public about agenda items
for consideration and vote. This is an
opportunity for the board to take part
in listening to our community. While we
wish we could respond or provide
feedback, Texas law requires us to limit
our questions to requests for
clarification or followup directly to
the administration. members of the
public wishing to participate in the
public comment portion of our meeting
called a dedicated Austin ISD phone line
in advance of the meeting to sign up to
speak in person or to audio record their
remarks. Tonight we have 11 people who
signed up to speak in person and we have
49 who left a recorded message. We will
now move to in-person testimony in order
to provide as many opportunities for
input as possible within a limited time
period at this meeting. Each speaker
will be allotted one minute. No
substitutions or yielding of time to
others is permitted. Callers who signed
up to speak in person are welcome to
come to the microphone when their name
is called. As you come to the
microphone, please press the button to
turn it on. There is a device that will
light up as you move through your one
minute of aotted time. When the buzzer
sounds, please make a final thought in
one sentence. Again, we ask that whether
you come to give a complaint or praise
that you reference the staff member by
position or by abbreviated last name. We
ask that all audience members, whether
speaking or not, please show respect for
all others at all times. Our in-person
speakers tonight, the first three are
Lauren Smith, Steve Swanson, and Lindsay
Omates. And I'm sorry, Lindsay, if I
pronounced your last name wrong.
That button.
I got it. Okay.
Okay. Hi, my name is Lauren Smith and
I'm the proud AVID site coordinator at
Betachch Middle School, the district's
first AVID National Demonstration
School, which will be closed or
restarted with new staff next year. I
understand the board and the district
are facing tough choices, but it's
important for both entities to
acknowledge the circumstances that led
to those choices. This is a partial list
of things that happened leading into my
first year that my campus earned an F.
One assistant principal and one
counselor position were cut. Many
teaching positions were cut as we
received many new transfer students. The
position for our principal job was not
posted on time, delaying the hiring
process, which left two administrative
vacancies not fully filled until
October. The outcomes from these choices
led to high turnover and a need for
rebuilding in the 2324 school year. Our
culture and climate improved
dramatically that year. Going into last
year, we again made sweeping changes to
focus on domain 3, which ended with a
16% increase in student growth. Our
principal did that. Our staff did that.
Most importantly, our kids did that. But
it wasn't enough to clear our
accountability rating. And that
situation could have been avoided had
the district made different choices
going into 22 23. Please avoid these
choices moving forward. Our students
deserve better.
Can you hear me? Steve Swanson. Good
evening. Uh, we are here today because
we care about our students and the
future of AISD. But we may must face a
hard truth. The Texas Education Agency,
TEA, is failing in its duties to support
our schools.
Instead of empowering communities, it's
imposing top- down mandates that ignore
our rights, especially our students. Do
you know TEA TEA's A throughF
performance rating is F? We must stop
school turnaround planning and TA must
turn itself around. For decades, TA has
neglected its responsibilities to train
and support our communities in
meaningful student centered planning.
AISD lawyers honoring their professional
creed can help tea turn around.
Let's demand better. Let's demand and
help with the turnaround where it is
truly needed with TEA. I welcome your
questions.
Hi, can you start over with your mic,
please? Yeah, thank you so much. We want
to be sure we hear you.
>> Test. Test. Okay. Um, I urge you to
request an extension for win Montasauri
closure or consolidation. Under Texas
law, the commissioner has discretion to
approve turnaround plans where there is
credible progress and a strong plan. WIN
has both. WIN serves a historically
underserved community with the unique
model Montasur and dual language.
Closing the school now at such a
critical stage of our students academic
journey would be deeply disruptive if we
truly want to break the cycle of
underperformance. Our kids need
stability. The growth already underway
is clear grounds to stay the course. We
are not saying the school shouldn't be
held accountable, but the timeline is
rash and extreme. Principal far has led
remarkable progress, stronger student
growth, staff morale, and parent trust.
Win is also highly soughta with a 200
student weight list and over 40%
transfer requests. Families want this
school. In a district with shamefully
high concentrations of poverty and
racial segregation, WIN stands out as a
bright spot, a wonderfully diverse
school. WIN is moving in the right
direction. What we need now is stability
and investment, not disruption. Please
commit to a three-year runway for WIN.
>> Thank you. Our next three speakers are
Alejandro Maldonado, Helen Miller, and
Cheryl Bradley.
Buenes
Alejandra
Sophia
Baker
Unicochia.
Extraordinari
English. must have been independent.
>> Okay.
>> See,
>> sorry.
Victor Rodri is interpreter for AISD.
>> I can do it.
>> Oh, well, okay. No one told me that we
needed it, but I I'll do it.
>> It's a broken more broken English, but
>> that's fine. I can do it. Good evening.
My name is Alejandra. I'm the parent of
Sophia who attends a school Becker
Elementary. uh for immigrant families
and those that speak Spanish as such as
mine. Becker not is not only a school,
it's a refuge, a place for refugees,
refugees, I'm sorry, a second home for
those who u open the doors when we when
we more needed it. U the Baker community
is so united. It is being converted into
a family that u that I don't have here
in in in here in Austin. This is a a uh
network of support that many immigrants
have lost when we've lost when we've
left our country here. The bilingualism,
the culture of our children uh is not
only accepted, it's celebrated as a as a
valued treasure. Uh teachers and
parents, we're all one. Every day, each
day, our children learn to be be
empathize or empathy and respect and uh
share traditions and uh and cultures.
Beckard has demonstrates something
extraordinary. Oh, ac academic
excellence and inclusion. They're not
contradictory. U it is it is nurtured uh
once and again something very
extraordinary. It's so marvelous to see
children of families that are that are
non-Hispanic and start starting to start
speak Spanish. Uh the language is is in
what I was born with and I I lived with
and this is really incredible. Closing
Becker will not only close a building,
it will it will close and break a lot of
hearts of community. It would be um
taking from our children a place where
they feel um secure, valued and capable
of dreaming large or big. uh it would be
um it would losing a community an
environment a unique environment that
gives wings to prosper.
There therefore I ask you
>> I beg you
>> I beg you okay uh please protect Becker
protect this uh model of uh
multicultural uh success that is an
example for everyone for our children
and for the future our community. Thank
you.
Thank you.
Can Can you hear me? Good evening,
trustees, superintendent.
We are in a crisis. Our message tonight
is simple. We urge the board to declare
a moratorum
on all school consolidations and
closures to allow all of the district's
energy and resources to focus on
providing focus assistance and support
to all of our schools in academic
trouble.
The district must rightsize
its academic programming before it
rightsizes its facilities. TEA requires
investments in teachers, leadership,
curriculum, and families, not buildings.
Therefore, we urge a mo moratorum on the
consolidation and closes and ask the
board of trustees to devote all of their
attention to the academic improvement
needed to elevate our lowest performing
schools and hire a chief of academics
with a proven track record of elevating
high standards for all students. Thank
you.
Thank you. Next up is Miss Bradley.
First of all, shame trustee.
Oh my gosh. Okay, so that mean I I have
a couple of people I need to get a hold
to before I leave here.
Good evening, AISD. We are in crisis.
Our message tonight is simple. We urge
the board to call a moratorum on any
school consolidation and closures to
allow all of the district's energy and
resources to focus on providing focused
assistance and support to all of our
schools in academic trouble.
If the facility changes are not due to
go into effect until 2627
school year, there is time for a
postponement
to get the academic ship on firm ground.
This current board
has a majority of educators.
How would you feel if you were at any
one of the schools? Whether it's the 12
with the three Fs or the ones with the
two or the one. And all of you are
hearing is the distraction of school
closure and consolidation.
It's not fair to faculty. It's not fair
to principles. It's not fair to staff.
And it's definitely not fair to
students. So you have to take students
utmost first before we start doing
anything. And district AISD have a lot
of work and not a lot of time.
>> Thank you. Um next up we have Quitloa
Gamaro, Amy Moore, and Amber Welsh.
Hi, good evening. My name is Kitlawa.
I'm a parent of three Austin ISD
students. I was told by the chief of
communications that the reason there is
so little time between the October 3rd
date of the plan release and the time
that the board is expected to vote is
because of a board policy that says
parents must be informed by December of
any changes to their child's assignment
the next academic year. So, I'm asking
the board to suspend or change that
policy to give them more time to
evaluate this proposal. This proposal
will fail, however, if we do not write
the ship. There has been a failure of
academic and instructional leadership in
this district for the past 5 years, as
far as I can tell, and it will continue
to fail unless we center the most
important things, which is instruction,
academics, and learning. The buildings
and the facilities and the budget don't
teach the kids. And this administration
has failed to put forth an academic
vision, a baseline plan, and is going to
continue to move forward in a
consolidation and closure plan without
doing so. I urge the board to hold the
superintendent and his staff accountable
for making sure that we are given
something to fight for, something to
vote for. And that's an academic vision
that stops the inequities, stops stops
doing what we've always been doing,
which is providing a highquality
education for some and a poor education
for others. It's time to lead with
academics, not buildings. Please hold
the superintendent and his staff
accountable for establishing a vision
and a baseline. Thank you.
Uh, good evening trustees, AISD admin.
Thank you for your service to the
community. I'm Amy Moore, parent of
three Austin ISD grads and a longtime
Austin resident. So many things
converging into my head this month, so
bear with me as I try to get this all
out. I'm here to ask that the TAP
development process for our next 12
campuses be vastly improved over what we
saw at happen to burn at Dobby and Web
in the spring. What unfolded then was
harmful to communities and cannot happen
again. I'm also a resident of Barton
Hills. Our principal, teacher, and staff
at Barton Hills Elementary were heroes
last week. They kept kids safe in the
midst of confusion, fear, and broken
communication. I believe all AISD
campuses would have reacted the same way
because that heroism isn't unique to
Barton Hills. It's just being a boots on
the ground educator. Those school voices
need to be heard in all discussions that
affect campuses and the people inside
them. Whether it's a tap, safety
protocols, testing windows, or school
consolidations, please listen to your
boots on the ground. Thank you.
Hello. I'm a parent at a campus rated F
for the last 3 years and I'm asking that
you take me seriously and not write me
off as someone is like expected push
back to consolidation. We all know that
F does not tell the whole story of a
campus but the fact that we have so many
multiple year F campuses tell us we have
a serious issue in our system that
requires urgent attention. Campuses need
help. Our campus needs help. We need
district staff and board to prioritize
getting this TAP development process
right and ensure it is done in
partnership with teachers and parents
and community members and that
engagement is not a checkbox but truly a
partnership of actual collaboration
based on improving student outcomes.
Plus, we know academics should be
driving facilities and not the other way
around. And I ask you to act in that
way. Um, and I'm asking you to pause the
consolidation process for a short period
of time and prioritize thoughtful TAP
development process without redirect
without direct redirecting significant
resources that are currently tasked with
implementing campus improvement plans.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. We have two additional
inperson speakers at Laura Smith and
Annie Kllum.
Do I press the
Oh, I got it. Okay.
Okay. Thank you so much for visiting.
>> Okay. Thank you so much for visiting my
classroom on the first day of school. I
really hope you saw the truth about Web
Middle School. Please also give
consideration for acknowledging the
recent relocation of students from other
locations with because they have
different languages. Yes. And not just
Spanish. We need to make sure that they
can understand and can talk about the
things they need to say.
During the closed door session, the
consideration for having other public
options like libraries was a regionally
perfect option. I really would like to
hear more of
my students are life skills special ed.
I'm so glad you saw my classroom because
none of the we our oven, our kitchen
supplies, our bathroom, our machine
wash, our clothes washers, everything.
They don't work and we can't. We have no
option, no opportunity.
If we were in a regular campus and if we
had a higher amount of money, then they
could give us money to get these things
to teach these kids how to use them. But
we just don't have them.
>> Thank you very much.
I am a proud parent of three at when our
district's only public Montasauri
option. I urge the board to pause
consolidations and closures and focus on
support. We request an extended
turnaround timeline and an innovation
plan that keeps our principal and
teachers while providing the extra
district support TEA requires. Principal
FAR began three years ago with 11
teacher vacancies and no AISD support
after the first or second year UA
rating. By her leadership, this year we
are fully staffed with a 200 student
weight list and a 40% transferin ratio.
Principal Farre has increased student
growth, created a strong campus and
community culture, and integrated a
thriving Montasauri model with a two-way
dual language program in our
economically disadvantaged and
underserved community. Last year, under
previous rubrics, we would have received
a C. While overall state and district
scores have declined, students need
stability, not disruption. replacing
current staff would undo years of
progress and further fracture our
community. Thank you for your time.
>> Thank you to all of our in-person
speakers. Uh we will now play the
recorded messages for public testimony.
So please listen carefully.
I am Oura Houston, a 1961 graduate of
the original Elf Anderson High School.
It's imperative that the board has an
understanding of the historic ne nature
of Yellow Jacket Stadium and the people
who for years did their best to maintain
the field because of its important to
the black community. There was an
agreement with the Anderson Alumni
Association prior to 2019, which was
changed by the facilities master plan
group. There were no alumni or members
of East Austin included when their
decision was made. Running clubs from
across this city have taken over the
field, making it difficult for historic
neighbors to exercise. Yellow Jacket
Field is much smaller than House Park or
Nelson Field and should have never been
included with him. Our request is for
the board to understand the importance
of this issue and protect the resources
of a community which has historically
been marginalized at times by the
district. The field needs to be
maintained by the district but not
included with others. Thanks so much for
understanding and being res responsive
to our issues and concern. Have a good
night.
>> This is Roxanne Evans from District 1 to
talk about two broken promises. The
first goes back to the 1971 closure of
the original LC Anderson High School. If
the district does anything short of
meeting community expectations and
honoring voter approval of the 2022 bond
for the Yellow Jacket Stadium upgrades,
that broken promise will reopen old
wounds. Second, the promise and covenant
between parents and the district risks
being irreparably harmed by rush
decisions related to closures and
consolidations. I urged the board to
call a moratorum on consolidations and
closures to a to allow all of the
district's energy and resources to focus
on providing assistance and support to
all of our schools and academic trouble.
Thank you.
>> Hi, this is Barbara Spears Corbett
calling regarding the Yellow Jacket
Stadium. I'm a community member of
District 1 Austin ISD Board of Trustees.
The 2022 bond designated funding to
support the preservation and
enhancements of Yellow Jacket Stadium
with initiatives including turf
upgrades, improved lighting, additional
seating, press box, expansion of the
track, and official recognition as a
historically significant site. These
efforts aim to ensure the stadium
continues to serve a broad and diverse
community. However, compared to other
AIS district stadiums, Yellow Jacket
Stadium continues to experience
challenges related to insufficient bond
funding, disparities in amenities, and
unfulfilled commitments. The fulfillment
of the community aspirations for the
stadium would contribute substantially
to addressing past grievances from the
1971 closure and fostered renewed collab
renewed collaboration, trust, and
constructive engagement as the district
considers school consolidation and
closures.
>> Delicia Mlan, Becker parent. Dear
trustees, thank you for allowing our
voices to be heard. I am a parent of two
Becker children and we are considered a
heritage family. Just in case you're
unfamiliar, these are families that have
parents that speak Spanish but not
necessar necessarily their children or
these families lost their Spanish the
previous generations due to
discrimination and the pressure to
assimilate. Heritage families actually
make up over 62% of Becker's population.
I'm asking you to today to please keep
Becker open. Instead of dismantling
Becker, use it as a model school to
better mentor other dual language
campuses soon to be erected at schools
around Austin, serving a very deserving
emerging bilingual students. This will
help to ensure that these programs are
successful rather than failing due to
lack of guidance. Becker has
demonstrated strong academic outcomes,
has low operational cost, a very strong
community of staff and teachers, and
dedicated parental involvement. Please
cons keep these consider this option
when making your decision. My name is
Lindsay Heatherington and I'm sharing my
perspective regarding any potential
revisions to the AIST transfer policy as
part of the consolidation process. We
are the parents of a seventh grader at
Small Middle School. Our son Towns was
accepted into the Green Tech Academy,
Smalls Magnet program through the
priority transfer process. pounds is
thriving, earning straight A's in all
accelerated classes, taking high school
credit courses, and receiving support
from a certified dyslexia therapist,
which was not available at our zone
school, O'Henry, at the time of his
sixth grade enrollment. For our family,
it's critical that students be allowed
to complete the highest grade at their
current campus. Forcing a mid-program
transfer would disrupt academics,
relationships, and access to specialized
instruction. Looking forward, we also
hope Towns's younger sister will have
the same chance to pursue magnet or
specialized programs in Austin ISD.
Stability and opportunity are what help
our kids succeed, and we ask that you
keep these priorities at the center of
any policy changes regarding transfers.
Thanks for your time and commitments.
>> Hi, my name is Abby Milan. I'm a
Cherrywood parent. I'm calling to urge
you to save Maplewood Elementary in its
dual language program. We specifically
bought our home near Maplewood for our
2-year-old daughter's future education,
and the school's overenrollment clearly
shows its value to our community.
Instead of closing successful schools
like Maplewood, a I believe AISD should
invest in them. The dual language
program is especially important to our
city where nearly onethird of residents
are Spanish speakers. Our family is
already participating in school events
like Peace Day. Please support families
like ours by preserving this vital
neighborhood school and its bilingual
education. Thanks so much for
considering. Bye.
>> Hi, my name is Amy Morz. I'm calling as
a potential future
um
enrolled uh a future enrolled student at
Becker um and concerned about this other
causing and the dual language program
being removed. Uh we specifically moved
to Balden Creek to enroll our daughter
in the dual language program at Becker.
It's a huge asset. We have been learning
Spanish with her as she has been taking
an immersion prek program.
Um, and it's been a great benefit to the
whole family. There's a huge influx of
new young children in the Balden Creek
neighborhood. I think at least 80 plus
families with children under the age of
four. Um, and so I'm not sure where
these these kids would be going to
school if the program closed. and many
mentioned the dual language program as a
reason why they want to enroll in
Becker. Um if the school removes the
dual language program, I'm not sure that
we would enroll in any uh Boston public
school for our child.
>> Hi, my name
>> and we're going to pause this for a
minute. We realize that we have one
in-person speaker who signed up to speak
and we don't want to make you wait until
we go through all the other ones since
you're in person. It's Whitney
Hazelmeer. I apologize that you were
left off the list and appreciate the
chance to hear you. Thank you.
>> My name is Whitney. I have a child at
WIN and I'm here to ask that you give
Win Monasuri the time it needs to
succeed. This school deserves families
who have or this school serves families
who have historically been overlooked
and it does so with a model that is very
rare in our district, Monasuri and dual
language. That combination is working.
WIN has a 200 student weight list and
over 400 transfer requests. Families are
actively choosing this school. What our
children need most is stability. Closing
a school mid turnaround while progress
is finally visible doesn't just disrupt
learning. More importantly, it breaks
trust with families who have committed
to this community. Accountability
matters, but it should never come at the
expense of our kids who are already
showing that they can thrive when given
consistency. The choice before you is
not between accountability and progress.
It's between disruption and stability.
Please choose stability.
[Music]
>> Thank you. Um and now we will resume our
recorded comments. Thank you.
>> Is Judy Sanders and I represent my two
children who attend Win Montasauri
Elementary School. I'm calling in
support of the school to modify the
turnaround plan uh recommended by TEA
and to not consolidate the school. I say
this uh based on a Texas law that gives
the commissioner discretion to approve
taps when the district district can show
credible progress. WIN is an incredible
school and has made extreme pro progress
in the past three years. We have a
strong principal who supports the
student, the staff and the community
each year. The community and student
population grows and our lower levels up
through third grade are strong making uh
a lot of progress and the students are
very well uh connected to each other.
Um, the school needs more time in order
to develop its strong foundations of
monasuri and dual language. And I can
guarantee that if the school were to
close. This is Carol Fedick. I'm a
community member and friend of AISD. And
I'm here again asking for Good Friday to
be put on the 2026 calendar. Good
Friday's been rejected in favor of
Caesar Chavez Dolores today. The
documentation I've shared with you shows
that the task force principles and board
members were misled when they were told
the draft calendars mirrored the
previous year's calendar. They did not.
Every calendar since at least 2010 has
had Good Friday as a holiday. You were
also misled to believe that there had
been an open discussion on the calendar
when in fact Caesar Chavez day had
already been designated as a
non-negotiable holiday. to prioritize
Caesar Chavez Day over Good Friday under
the assumption that it better represents
Hispanics is racist and ignore ignores
the importance of faith to the Hispanic
community. I respectfully ask you to
respect all Christians in this district
and get Good Friday on the calendar.
Thank you.
>> Gregory Hayes, we are a young dual
language family of five living in the
Balden neighborhood attending Becker
Elementary School. We all know that in
these difficult times of change,
momentum matters, positivity matters,
and working examples to hold its
lighouses for the district matter.
Moving the wall-to-wall programs will
drive an increased use of the voucher
program, private schools, and families
choosing neighboring districts for
housing and quality schooling. I'm
encouraging the district to not throw
the proverbial baby out with the
bathwater, but rather keep the
attractive unique things that Austin ISD
has to offer. Wall-to-wall programs
should be exploited via school
collaborations, teacher exchanges to
bring new wall-to-wall programs online.
Inevitably, trying to move a wall-to-all
program will result in portions of the
program moving. Partial programs will
result in partial restarts, demolishing
a lot of the hard work these communities
have built over the years. After all,
the success of Becker as a wall-to-all
dual language program is not the success
of Austin ISD alone. It's a
collaboration success between Austin ISD
and the community serving the school.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Kelly Gracert. Um, I have
a daughter that's a student at Becker
Elementary. Um, I just wanted to share
um that Becker has really given my
daughter an environment in which she can
thrive learning from a wide demographic
of children, parents, and teachers. Um,
I'm a first-time parent and I was pretty
trepidacious about kindergarten. um
she's been at the same bilingual daycare
since she was 4 months old and I was
looking for um something similar uh
environment that is as nurturing, warm,
kind, thoughtful and and educationally
rigorous is what she was coming from. Um
she also struggles with change and I
want I wanted her to be really excited
about learning and her own personal
development. Um I visited seven
different campuses in AISD um since we
are not uh currently tied to a school
that has a bilingual program. Um, and
when I left Becker's, you know,
information night, I just knew this was
the place. Um, so while we're still very
new to the school, I can wholeheartedly
say it's been everything and more than
we expected. Um, from an elementary
experience and, um, this program and
this school just continues to open up so
many doors for her future. Um,
especially since, uh, she'll be fully B.
>> Hi, this is Stacy Woodburn Henry and I
am a Becker parent. I'm reaching out
because my understanding from
all of the conversations going around
Austin right now is that our dual
language program will be dismantled and
sold for parts uh distributed around the
district to hopefully bring up other
campuses. And I urge you to please
understand how illogical that is. We
have a incredibly successful program
with dedicated staff that could be used
as a training ground for other programs.
Breaking us up into pieces doesn't
lift anyone else up. It just hurts our
children. Please keep us intact. Let us
remain a successful program that other
teachers can come train in and take back
home to other campuses.
Hello, my name is Jodie Klopp and I'm a
grandparent with three children who
attend Becker Elementary and my the
purpose of my call is to urge you to
keep Becker open as a dual language
campus. I am a retired Spanish teacher
and have been very impressed with the
language proficiency of my
grandchildren.
Kirk who was in at is now at O'Henry
graduated last year and um he attended
Becker during kindergarten through fifth
grade. His family are not heritage
speakers. They speak English at home and
his Spanish proficiency in speaking,
listening, writing surpasses the
proficiency of my former high school
students after three years of Spanish.
I am convinced that Becker's bilingual
curriculum really works. I'm also
impressed by the multicultural
environment which leads to a more
successful and stable
>> My name is Peter Johnson. I live in the
Balden Creek neighborhood and I am the
father to a four-year-old girl. I'm
calling regarding the potential closure
of Becker Elementary or the changer to
the dual language program. We moved to
Building Creek specifically for the dual
language program at Becker Elementary
and have been preparing our daughter for
that with a dual language pre preschool.
Um we're hoping she can go to Becker. If
not, we'll need to enroll her into a
private school to um get that dual
language experience. Uh so calling to
ask you to please not close Becker or to
change the dual language program which
we are very excited about. Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Kathy Wilson, a Becker
elementary parent, and I just wanted to
call to express my concern regarding the
potential closure of Becker. It is one
of AISD's most cost-efficient and
academically successful dual language
campuses. In ASD's own rubric, Becker
scored a one in cost per student. TEA
rates Becker as a B school. Families and
caregivers such as myself are engaged
and staying in ASD because they believe
in the power of Becker's dual language
curriculum. Our teachers chose to work
at Becker over other schools commuting
from elsewhere in the city and region.
Becker is a welcoming and inclusive
campus that serves and uplifts
Spanish-sp speakaking and heritage
bilingual families. Our strong community
values are reflected every day in our
commitment to joyful, inclusive
bilingual education. Becker is a model
campus that should be replicated, not
closed. Becker's success can benefit the
entire district, not just one
neighborhood, by offering a successful
model for building dual language
programs over many years of efforts.
AISD's board of trustees should continue
to invest in what works and keep Becker
open as a dual language.
>> This is Tyler Vickers. My daughter is a
student at Becker Elementary in
kindergarten. Uh Becker has given my
daughter an environment in which she can
thrive learning from a wide demographic
of children, parents, and teachers. As a
first-time parent, I was a little
worried about kindergarten as she's been
in a bilingual program since she was
four months old. And I was looking for a
place that was as nurturing, warm, and
thoughtful about her education and
Spanish immersion and experience as um
you know, Becker is. She also really
struggles with change and I want her to
be excited about learning and and
personal development. So I visited seven
different campuses in AISD when and
chose Becker as my number one uh to
transfer into. She is a transfer by the
way. um I knew this was the place when I
when I saw it and ranked it with all the
other school among above all the other
schools. So while I while we are still
new to the school as a kindergartener, I
can say I wholeheartedly it's been
everything and more that we expected
from an elementary experience and
Spanish immersion experience. Um and I
hope that that we can continue to go in
there and open more of these doors for
her and toward her future of being fully
bilingual. So thanks for listening and
have a good
>> Hi, my name is Anna Juan. I am a mom in
the Balden neighborhood um zone for
Becker Elementary School and I'm calling
to leave a comment um in support of
keeping Becker open. Becker is a really
crucial part of our our school of our
neighborhood. Um we have a super vibrant
um community of young parents um many of
whom uh have kids at Becker but then
also actually probably an even larger
contingency of parents who are looking
forward to sending their kids to Becker.
Um it seems like there is quite a large
community of of kids who are just under
the threshold for elementary school but
who have moved here in very recent
years. Um a lot of people are very very
interested in the dual language
immersion um and have been keen to to
experience that um for ourselves um for
our kids really. Uh we really I really
want to strongly encourage you guys to
consider keeping the school open. Um
it's a huge asset to the community um
and just a wonderful experience for the
for the children to be able to
experience the wallto-wall um language
immersion.
>> Good morning. My name is William Ward.
last name is spelled W A R D. I'm an LT
Anderson High School alumni. I graduated
in 1968 and I was a member of the 1968
district 40 basketball championship team
coached by the late Lawrence Britain. My
call to respectively ask the AISD board
to reser preserve Yellow Jacket Stadium.
I'm also asking the board to designate
the facility as a central facility and
provide promise and needed upgrades.
Yellow Jacket Stadium is one of the
oldest African-American track and field
stadiums. I understand that there was a
2022 bond passed that would protect the
history and the future of the stadium,
but the funding wasn't allocated as
promised. My wish is that the AIC board
of trustees would reconsider its
commitment and allow allow funds to be
preserved to preserve the stadium with
turf, lighting, and additional seating
and bringing the track to eight lanes
just as the other districts benefited
from the funding. This would be a
commitment to the community uh for the
damage that was done in 1971.
My name is Leticia Anderson, former
trustee, calling in to express my deep
concern about the way this consolidation
process has been handled. What we are
witnessing is a clear lack of leadership
and accountability from this board. Your
silence throughout this process has been
striking. You have refused to engage
with families, educators, and students
who will be most directly impacted.
Instead of honest communication, you
have chosen secrecy. Instead of
transparency, you have chosen silence.
This is not how public servants should
lead. Our community deserves clear
answers. We deserve to see the data, to
understand the reasoning, and to have a
real seat at the table. By avoiding
meaningful engagement, you have allowed
confusion and mistrust to grow. Trust is
fragile and you are breaking it. If you
cannot lead with integrity,
transparency, and respect for this
community, then you are failing the very
people you were elected to serve. Thank
you.
>> I am a rich top parent. Research shows
that when schools are consolidated or
closed, displaced students do not
perform better academically after. In
fact, studies have found they can
experience up to a 10% drop in
achievement. This show true independent
of students socioeconomic status. The
harm goes beyond academics. A UT Austin
study found that students expressed
grief and loss when separated from their
school community. Systemic reviews
confirm that friendships and trust in
teachers are directly tied to well-being
and attendance. When those ties are
broken, students face higher loneliness,
more depression, and up to a 20 to 30%
increase in disengagement from school.
Attendance decreased for these students.
One national study found attendance
concerns for displaced students for
three years after this closure. Tonight,
I am asking the board to please help us
understand a little bit more about the
research that you all have done in order
to talk about the impact that this will
cause our children. In the past months,
we have heard about the financial
impact, but not about what is happening
and what will happen.
>> Hello trustees. This is Kristen Carney,
a proud Becker parent of two. Becker is
extraordinary because of its excellent
dual language education and community.
Every spring, Becker brings the largest
group of elementary students to the Cap
10K. Just down the street, the
neighborhood library welcomes students
after school with programs that spark
reading and curiosity. Our green garden
classroom is another treasure. Parents
like me volunteer every other week to
teach STEM activities, getting to know
the students and other parents. Because
of these reasons and the excellent dual
language education, families from all
over AISD choose Becker, driving extra
every day so our children can grow up
bilingual, biiterate, and bicultural.
Closing or moving Becker would dismantle
a thriving community that can be a model
for what a successful dual language
program can be, helping all students in
AISD. I want to recognize the hard
choices that you have to make here.
Thank you for your service and I
appreciate you listening.
Hi, my name is Natalie Betts. I'm a
parent at Richtop Elementary. I would
like the board to address three issues
related to school consolidation. First,
please reconsider the exclusion of
portables in the data rubric. Excluding
portables completely rather than giving
them a weighted score compared to seats
in a permanent building really distorts
the real picture of over under
enrollment in our schools and I fear
will lead to misinformed
decision-making. Please consider them as
part of the temporary solution they are
intended to be in order to achieve the
minimized impact that AISD is aiming
for. This is already going to be a
difficult transition. Please do not
remove or ignore one of the tools in
your toolbox. Second, I want to implore
you to keep our school community
together if changes are made to our or
other wall-to-all dual enrollment dual
language schools. I completely shared
AISD's goals to expand these programs to
more emergent bilingual students, but
you need to do that in real life with
the people who make those programs
possible rather than just on paper.
Finally, please give this process more
time. We need at least one more round of
feedback before the vote. Thank you,
>> Alexandra Chavez, parent of Becker
Elementary.
Much
gracias.
>> Much gracias.
>> This is a translation into English of
Alexandra Chavez and Santiago's message.
Alexandra Chavez, parent of Becker
Elementary. My name is Santiago. I am in
elementary since first. My family is
immigrant. We speak Spanish. I ask you
to save our schools. Please save our
dual language and baker. Thank you very
much. Thank you very much.
I am a rich talk parent. Research shows
that when schools are consolidated or
closed, displaced students do not
perform better academically after. In
fact, studies have found they can
experience up to a 10% drop in
achievement. This show true independent
of students socioeconomic status. The
harm goes beyond academics. A UT Austin
study found that students expressed
grief and loss when separated from their
school community. Systemic reviews
confirm that friendships and trust in
teachers are directly tied to well-being
and attendance. When those ties are
broken, students face higher loneliness,
more depression, and up to a 20 to 30%
increase in disengagement from school.
Attendance decreased for these students.
One national study found attendance
concerns for displaced students for
three years after this closure. Tonight,
I am asking the board to please help us
understand a little bit more about the
research that you all have done in order
to talk about the impact that this will
cause our children. In the past months,
we have heard about the financial
impact, but not about what is happening
and what will happen.
>> Hi, my name is Jonathan Levy. My wife
Christina and I have two daughters in
Sunset Valley Elementary, third grade
and preK4. We're a half Puerto Rican
bilingual family and transferred our
girls into Sunset Valley so that they
would not only be bilingual, but also
become part of a Spanish-sp speakaking
community outside the home and have
Spanish speaking role models in the
workplace. We love Sunset Valley's dual
language program and hope that the board
will be able to preserve it along with
all other current wall-to-all programs
and eventually be able to expand them.
These programs have been successful for
so many years. So rather than
dismantling them, the board should
consider creative solutions to build on
their success. Thank you.
>> Good evening. My name is Steven Chan. Uh
I'm a parent of a third grader at
Richtop. Um I'm just calling to voice my
concerns about the closure of the school
after this year. Um I really advise
against it. Um, my son loves the school,
loves teachers, loves the principal
there. We
want that to remain open. We don't want
him to be displaced into another school
and lose all his friendships and all his
connection with the community. Uh, I
love the school. Please do not close it.
Uh, I advise against it. And I hope we
can keep the school open and we could do
anything we can to help that. Please let
us know. Thank you.
Good morning. My name is Olivia Channon.
I'm a parent of a third grader at
Richtop. Research shows that when
schools are consolidated or closed,
displaced students do not perform better
academically. In fact, they can
experience up to 10% drop in achievement
regardless of socioeconomic status.
Identities also declines when national
study found displaced students miss more
school of the three years after closure.
The harm goes beyond academics. Research
shows that when friendships and trust in
teachers are broken, students experience
more loneliness, depression, and up to
30% rise in disengagement from school. A
UT Austin study also found that children
express grief and loss years after they
experienced a school closure. So I am
asking the board, what research have you
using to use these um guides to use
these decisions? What evidence do you
have to offset the academic, emotional
and social harm um closures causes
children? As a parent, I chose Austin
ISD because I believe the district used
research to inform its practices. But
this in this process, I've only heard
about financial efficiencies. our
communities their transparency not just
about dollar saves but about the
consequences for children's academic and
well-being. I do not support the closing
or consolidation of Rich Elementary.
Thank you.
This is Sharon Bain, parent of two AISD
graduates. This consolidations process
cannot just be about buildings. It has
to be about what we are doing
academically for the children in them. I
know there's work happening on a more
detailed academic vision. Please don't
come back here on October 9th and say
that you're working on it. We need to
hear something concrete now. Something
like, "By third grade, most of our
students will be reading to learn
instead of learning to read. Our
students begin to learn the rudiments of
essay writing in X-ray and write five
paragraph essays by Y-grade. Students
who struggle to reach these goals are
identified early and receive age and
pedagogically appropriate targeted
support in the classroom. things like
that. Synthesize and distill the TEICS,
the long-range plan, the equity and
special education audits into something
accessible so we know that we are making
these hard choices to focus all
available funds on providing this north
star at every single neighborhood
school. Thank you.
>> Uh yes, my name is Matthew George. I'm a
parent of a third grader at Rididge. um
calling to expect my um you know
disagreement with the potential decision
to consolidate and close um our school.
Um I think it
it's the the impact would be devastating
to my child, my family, um our
community. Um it would have impact for
years. Um it would uh you know destroy
my child's faith in the
awesome ID. Um you know that he trusts
in y'all to do what's best for him and
this is not what's best for him. Uh it's
not what's best for his classmates.
uh the community that we've built and
established at Ridgetop. So I I I beg
you to reconsider all options. Um and
please do not close our school. Thank
you.
>> Carla Perez, Win Montasuri parent, as
you consider consolidations, I urge you
to request an extension for Win Montes.
Texas law states the commissioner has
the discretion to approve turnaround
plans when there is credible progress
and a strong plan and when has both when
serves a historically underserved
community with a unique model
multi-story and dual language placing
our school now at such a critical stage
of our students academic journey would
be deeply disruptive. Our kids need
stability to truly break the cycle of
underperformance. The growth already
underway is clear and grounds to stay
the course. Principal FAR has
transformed our school community. The
student growth is strong. The staff
morale and parent trust is high too when
it's also a highly soughtafter 200
student weight list and with over 400
transfer requests. Families want this
school in a district with high
concentrations of poverty and racial
segregation in elementary schools. Win
stands out as a bright spot in an
integrated school model that proves what
is possible. Win is moving in the right
direction.
>> Hello and good afternoon. My name is
Ethan Gian and I'm one of the head leads
at the Becker Grain classroom at Becker
Elementary School. I'm calling to ask
that we keep Becker elementary school
open. The Becker Grain Classroom is a
staple in the community. It allows
agricultural knowledge to be spread
throughout Austin, not just for our
parents and for our students, but
individuals who want to grow veggies and
herbs to be able to serve community
restaurants. And we are teaching at the
level of biodnamic and permaculture at
which Kingsville&M is not currently
teaching at. We have microbiology
technology on site. We have compost and
so many other great tools to teach both
future generations and future
communities how to grow their own food
and serve their community with the best
interest. This includes our connection
with St. Edwards University who is
testing our compost on a microbiological
scale. I beg that you all keep this
open. Hi, this is David Inosuk calling
to express deep concern about the
proposal to close or relocate the
Spanish immersion program at Becker
Elementary. Becker is far more than just
a campus. It is a thriving community
that's a model of what education in
Austin should truly look like. What
makes Becker exemplary is not only the
academic program, but the culture and
the substance created by its families,
its educators, its students. And the
school is built on in inclusive a
inclusive community rooted in things
like diversity, language, and belonging.
This is not simply a program that can be
moved because it's a living ecosystem of
relationships, traditions, and shared
values has taken years to cultivate. And
Becker as a campus should be celebrated.
It's and not disintegrated. It's a
unique brand blend of all these things
that really is something that should
serve as a model for other schools
across the district. Closing Becker
would not only disrupt hundreds of
families, it would dismantle a community
that embodies what ASD should aspire to
achieve, which is strong, connected, and
inclusive schools. So, we ask AISD to
recognize Becker's values and preserve
its campus and lean on it as an example
rather than erasing what's been so
thoughtfully built.
>> Hello, my name is Dr. Danielle Dwarte
and I'm both a parent of two elementary
age children in East Austin schools and
an educator with more than 15 years of
experience. I urge you to call a
moratorum on school consolidations and
closures so that AISD can direct its
energy towards helping schools most in
academic trouble, especially those on
the east side that have been
historically underresourced. As you
know, there's 15 AISD schools that have
repeated F scores yet no real support
like staffing, interventions, or
coaching have been provided. Schools
should not be scrambling to write
turnaround plans months after scores
have been released. Second, Win Monasuri
is a model worth protecting. The
principal is amazing and has grown Win
from under 300 students to full
enrollment with over 200 students on the
wait list. Families like me are drawn to
the dual language monastery program
which will is one of the few integrated
models in Austin.
There is a smarter path forward. Texas
allows the uh the commissioner to
approve turnaround plans with credible
progress and win qualifies. Please
request an extension and provide at
least a three-year runway and invest in
stability, not disruption.
>> Uh, good morning. My name is Cheryl
Finny and I'm a parent of a third grader
at Ridgetops. Um, research shows that
schools close or consolidate. Students
don't improve academically. In fact,
they often see a 10% drop in achievement
and attendance declines for years after.
Uh, the impact isn't just academic.
Closing schools breaks friendships and
trust with teachers leading to more
loneliness, depression, and up to 30%
increase in disengagement. Uh UT study
found children still felt grief after a
loss um years after closures. Um so
tonight I asked the board, "What
research are you relying on to justify
these closures? What evidence shows the
benefits outweigh the harm to children?"
Um, I chose ISD because I believe
decisions here are were based on
research. So far, I have only heard
about saving money. Our community
deserves transparency, not just about
finances, but uh the real impact on
students are learning and well-being. I
do not support the store uh the school
closure or consolidation for Rididgetop.
We are zoned for that school. Hi, I'm
calling to express my disappointment at
the that you are considering to close
elementary. My grandson has been a
student there for the past three years
and it has been a wonderful experience
for him. I've attended school functions
to see him and fundraisers etc. And I
feel like it is such a wonderful
community and a bright spot in Austin.
and I'm disappointed that it is one of
the schools you are considering closing.
Thank you for listening to my thoughts.
My name is Jill George. Um,
thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Kristen Davis. My
daughter is a fourth grader at Joslin
Elementary School. I'd like to talk very
briefly about the consolidation closure
and attendance boundary plan and
proposed changes to the transfer policy
that are scheduled to be published on
October the 3. I would encourage the
board of trustees to use the entire
month of October and the first half of
November to fully and actively engage
both school communities and district
staff in conversations regarding the
draft plan and proposed changes to the
transfer policy. While I appreciate the
hard work and people hours that both
district staff and trustees have already
put into developing the draft plan and
revisions to the transfer policy. I am
concerned that there has not been
sufficient public comment on the actual
draft plan and the actual proposed
changes to the transfer policy. Thank
you.
Jane Mana, parent of AISD student.
My husband and I are parents of an
emergent bilingual student at Becker
Elementary. Becker is one of AISD's
flagship dual language campuses with a
proven cost-effective program that
serves Spanish speaking students,
heritage speakers, and families like
ours with joyful and inclusive bilingual
education. Our story is deeply tied to
language and culture. I grew up on the
Texas border and my husband is from
Puerto Rico where we mainly speak
Spanish at home. For us, raising our
daughter, where Spanish is celebrated,
is essential. and Becker has been
everything we had hoped for, a place
where she can thrive academically,
connect to her heritage, and feel
embraced by a caring community. We are
also transfer family commuting from
Southwest Austin to downtown. And
Becker's location makes it possible for
us to stay at AISD. Importantly, Becker
is both academically successful and one
of AISD's most costefficient schools.
It's a model that should be replicated,
not closed. Please keep Becker open as a
dual language campus. Our family and
many others depend on it. Thank you.
>> My name is Aaron Mixik and I'm a parent
in the ISD
starting in kindergarten. My daughter
has been in a Spanish-speaking daycare
since she was an infant. When we go to
Mexico, she speaks fluent Spanish. I
work in community care where all of my
patients are Spanish. And if if I don't
continue to send her to a Spanish-sp
speakaking school, she's going to lose
this amazing gift. Dual language
programs are some of the most
well-enrolled and costeffective
models in the ISD. Families stay in the
ISD because of these models.
and
kids that speak English in the dual
language models help the native spanners
Spanish learners learn better English.
And I just feel like the ISP needs to
understand how valuable these programs
are and
continue to invest in these small
schools that are offering such and this
is Allison Hansen, parent of a of two
students at Win Monasuri and AISD. This
call is to request an extension for Win
Monasur's turnaround plan under the
provision that there is credible
progress and a strong plan in place. Win
is the only school in the district that
is monasteri and being such a unique
school creates an exception. This
exception should apply to the timeline
of its turnaround plan as well. A
critical look at the scores will reveal
progress at the classroom level and this
year will break the cycle of
underperformance. Closing the school
would not serve the student body or the
community on the east side as a whole.
Win is a unicorn of a school and under
the brief tenure of its current
principal enrollment has improved year
overyear. It has a 40% transfer in rate
and an extensive wait list showing its
desiraability and the progress required
for passing is already underway. Closing
the school would halt the progress made
and will not meet any goals the
turnaround plan claims to serve. Win is
a beautiful, diverse, successful school
and deserves the district's support in
maintaining the current forward
momentum. Thank you.
>> Marie, speaking as a parent, I'm a
little tired of this district and its
problems. So, I'll just say it plainly.
Everything in this bed order update is
going to be a lie. Special education
needs conservator to protect students.
There's no point in debating middle
school scorecards when we start
warehousing children at age three. We
should be building strong foundations.
We need an academic plan and new
leadership. Stop closures and
consolidations. Cut and close
headquarters first. Even Matias admitted
the only savings is in an admin salary.
We could close 50 schools and still not
match what's wasted by an ever growing
headquarters. Cut it and close it. LSG
guardrails and scripted communications
insult voters and elected trustees. The
board isn't the problem. Teachers aren't
the problem. Leadership is. Throw out
the handbook. You are elected to lead.
Finally, on GF, false documentation and
dishonesty persist in Austin ISD. These
amendments would shield abuse and
neglect. Think and Richards abuse of
three and four year olds, etc. Even of
our youngest students, it would just
shield it from board oversight. Do not
approve these amendments. Thank you.
>> This is Trisha Kim. I'm an AISD grad and
public school advocate. I'm calling to
read a letter that was published in the
Statesman this week. Texas education law
does not let set limits on the number of
simultaneous TEA imposed campus
turnaround plans for a single public
school district. AISD is unlikely to be
successful implementing 15 turnaround
plans at once while also conducting a
normal school year, continuing to
overhaul its special education system,
and planning for school consolidations
and closures due to budget deficits and
declines in student enrollment. After
having four superintendent in five
years, Austin ISD's current leadership
has the skills, experience, motivation,
and common vision to move us forward. A
TEA takeover of our district's
leadership will not be more effective
should the burden on the district be too
great. State law needs to allow
flexibility and an attainable timeline
to work with campuses and families,
support teachers, learn from progress,
and apply knowledge gained to remaining
underperforming schools. State law
should support districts demonstrating
recent successes, not punish or
dismantle.
>> This is Nadia Khan. Advanced support for
dual language programs in 50 plus
schools is inadequate yet crucial to
address underperformance and convey
lifelong benefits. Ensure schools
receive staff and supports needed to
implement this program effectively. DL
programs best entered before first grade
lead directly to advanced academic
pathways by literacy skills lifelong
social health and economic benefits. DL
students outperform peers in every
category by secondary. DL must be
flexible to travel where emergent
bilingual students live, expand and
contract as populations change, and be
free of application barriers if it's to
serve those who can benefit from it
most. Additionally, students in
integrated DL classrooms outperform
students in linguistically segregated
ones. Integrated DL is the best model at
closing the gaps for emergent bilingual,
echois, African-American students
receiving sped services. Open doors to
integrated learning for emergent
bilingual at more schools while
welcoming historically excluded students
to this advanced pathway. Support and
expand Yel in a way that does not again
leave out students we are most trying to
lift up. Thank you.
>> My name is Marilyn Faulner. I have three
students in AISD. Two currently attend
Becker Elementary and one is an alum of
Becker. This school, Becker Elementary,
has raised my children to be global
citizens with empathetic worldview and
wall-to-wall bilingual education. The
education they have received in the
community do not exist independently.
They are one and the same. And
therefore, Becker is a model campus that
should be replicated, not closed. Our
success at Becker can benefit the entire
district as a training model, not just
affecting one neighborhood, but by
offering a successful model for building
dual language programs that we have
developed over many years of effort and
dedication. We would like for you to
continue to invest in what works,
keeping us open in our current location
as a dual language school. We believe
that dismantling or transplanting
successful valued AISD programs will not
lead to improved enrollment or education
outcomes. Thank you.
>> Hello superintendent trustees. My name
is Robert Kibby. I've been involved in
ASD for many years.
I have been trying to as well as the
community members have been trying to
get into Mendes to help our kids out
there and we have been turned away since
charter school took effect. I met with
the principal and the director on August
15th and told them our concerns about
the lack of communication, the lack of
participation that we have. They
promised me that they would get back to
me. Uh I emailed them last week because
I haven't heard from them in a month. he
finally emailed back and asking what
kind of community input
or communication would they would we'd
like to see. Um, yes, they got a beat.
I'm appreciative of that, but that just
goes to show if AISD puts the effort
behind Mendes like the charter school
does, we our kids can pass. We just need
to have faith. We need to get AIS Mendes
back to AISD. We do not need charter
schools in our school district. Thank
you and have a great day.
>> Hi, I am a parent of a first and third
grader um at Brierwoods Elementary. Um I
wanted to make a statement about the co
school consolidation process overall. Um
as parents, we feel that there is no
clear data that proves that closing
schools like Brea Woods will in fact
save the district money. Um the second
note I would like to make is really
around the fact that we have a several
failing schools in Austin AISD and the
conversation is focused on school
consolidations and saving money not on
how we're going to improve the outcomes
of the children across the board in AISD
and how we are going to avoid a takeover
by the state. um our school and uh
parent community is advocating for
delaying this process to really
understand the data around what we will
or will not save by closing schools and
secondarily focusing the the board and
uh AISD's energy on improving the
outcomes for students across the board
in Austin AISD. Thanks for your time.
>> My name is Jeremy Berseron. I'm a parent
at Breerwoods. We have four children in
Bikerwoods Elementary, two in
kindergarten, two in second grade. I'm
calling to ask the board to delay the
consolidation process. Right now, this
process feels rushed and it doesn't
really allow for true community
engagement. Closing schools without
fully exploring alternatives will not
solve AISD's long-term financial or
enrollment challenges. It will
destabilize neighborhoods like ours and
harm families. Trustees have a
responsibility to make sustainable,
well-informed decisions that require
transparency and collaboration with the
communities most effective. Please slow
this process down and work directly with
us so that we can help identify
solutions that actually strengthen the
district instead of quick fixes that
create more problems. Thank you.
>> Dear ASB board members, thank you for um
taking the time to listen to me. My name
is Lawrence Ray. I am a parent of an
elementary school um child in the AIST
school system. Um I'm calling to make a
plea to you to pause the consolidation
process that you're undertaking right
now. Um for three main reasons. Um first
um uh there's no data that has been
released to parents or the community
about how closing any of these schools
in the ASD school district would save us
any money. Um second, there still hasn't
been any data from the last round of
school uh closings in 2019 to indicate
that such savings would be likely. And
third, and potentially most important,
um there is a lot of evidence that the
Texas Education Agency is uh very much
ready and um uh raring to to take over
AISD. And I would really urge you to
focus on that bigger threat um to um our
intellectual community here in Austin.
Um so please if um uh if you would um
concentrate on that threat and pause the
consolidation process that you're
undertaking right now. Thank you for
your time. Um and thank you for all the
hard work that you do for public schools
here in Austin.
>> Good evening ladies and gentlemen. My
name is Bill Woods and I live in
Brighter Woods.
Brier Woods Elementary School is more
than just a school for us. is the
cornerstone of our neighborhood, having
been created the same year that Bria
Woods was platted in 1939.
And while it has served admirably as an
excellent elementary school, it has also
served as the central meeting place and
focus of thousands of neighbors over the
years, including being the central
meeting place for scouts, our
neighborhood association,
church, and civic meetings.
I urge you please to focus on the
immediate threat and stop getting
distracted with questions about the age
of buildings. We need for you to halt
the consolidation process and focus on
what matters that is saving our schools
from tea takeover and allowing them to
remain the anchor for our neighborhoods.
I know this is not a decision you take
lightly and I wish you wisdom in making
your decisions. Thank you very much.
Bye-bye.
>> My name is Jasmine Wind and I'm a parent
at Win Monastery. I urge you to request
an extension for Wind Monator's
turnaround plan. The truth is closing
win right now is premature and it
ignores the real credible progress
happening every day. State law gives the
commissioner the flexibility to approve
turnaround plans when progress is clear.
And we know WIN has met that bar. WIN is
not just another elementary school. It's
a one-of-a-kind dual language monitory
programs serving a community that needs
stability. The east side deserves a
program like when and pulling the rug
out from under these students now would
be devastating. If we truly want to see
our kids succeed, they need continuity,
not disruption. The community is begging
for this school to stay. Seen incredible
gains in student growth, staff morale,
and parent trust. We have a 200 student
wait list. My family included sat on the
wait list hoping and praying to be
admitted. Families want this option for
their children. Win is a huge bright
spot for AISD. Please don't shut down
success. Give Win the time and stability
it has earned. Thank you.
>> Thank you. This concludes public
testimony. Thank you very much to all of
our speakers and all of our callers uh
for sharing your input with us. Uh
trustees, do we have any questions or
clarifications? Trusty Hunter,
>> my apologies for being late. Uh there
were several callers about the Yellow
Jack stadium. Do we have um a resolution
or a plan for the stadium?
So, uh, Trusty Hunter, um, so to be be
clear, um, from the original agreement
that I was a part of many, many years
ago, even prior to the 2017 bond
program, we've been committed to working
with the alumni to not only, um,
identify space within East College High
School, but also invested in Yellow
Jacket Stadium. Uh, because of how the
bond in 2022 was was communicated, the
funds for it were tied to East Side
Early College High School. uh we don't
have a resolution regarding the track
because a track expansion is really I
think what the is kind of the root issue
that we're trying to address uh to make
it a UIL competitive um site and truly
make it able to support a regional um
UIL competition. It would need that
additional lane uh which is not
something that was part of the original
budget. So what I can tell you right now
is we do not have it resolved. I am
aware of what the issue is. Um I don't
necessarily um I can't provide an exact
timeline. I can tell you that we are
working through it. I'm also aware of
the overuse of the site um and kind of
the lack of controls uh given how it's
been used by folks um that maybe don't
have the proper approval. U we've
noticed that um Jeremy Stiffler, our
real estate director, um has is
involved. Um athletics is involved. uh
we've begun to add signage and control
that a lot better. Uh so we are aware I
can't tell you that we have a a res
resolution um to that specific issue but
I can tell you that we are working on
it.
>> Thank you. I have an additional
question.
>> Um
for the process there has been a call
for data or the data that you're using
not available
on the site. I thought we set up a site
and that all the data going through the
consolidation would be available for
families.
>> So for the consolidation process um I
believe the data that most folks were
referring to are just kind of the
progression of the process. So the
rubric which has been released that was
a starting point uh at that time um and
we've committed to do this is to de d
take a deep dive and really evaluate all
the things that were discussed in the
last multiple work sessions with the
trustees. You know how can we look at
boundary changes across the entire
district to ensure alignment and reduce
the number of splits between elementary,
middle, middle and high. How can we look
at um identifying uh areas of surplus
seats? So that is really kind of
intentional work. There's lots of
iterations. That kind of work isn't
posted because it it is all draft. It's
back and forth with our demographer. Um
but as we have uh presentations uh we
post those as we have um milestones that
we'll meet. We'll submit those and and
post them. But there isn't uh like the
the iterative work in between when we're
evaluating uh and working with the
demographer that isn't uploaded and we
don't have a way to distribute that. We
wouldn't be able to
Okay. Um,
okay. The the final uh sort of request I
have is
there's a lot of source of data with TEA
like individuals are speaking with TEA,
individual groups or whatever. I would
request that
we request from the commissioner or his
people or whatever what actually can
happen in a turnaround and print that
and post it because people people I know
what you're telling me. I know what
people are telling me. I know what I can
read on the internet.
That information if the commissioner is
going to approve several different plans
then let's have him say yes I'm willing
to do that. If he's like no I've told
you what I want you to do and this is
what you need to do it. I would like
people to be able to know that.
>> Um, so trust enter what I can commit
what I can communicate uh to our
trustees and to our community and and
staff is that we do have regular
conversations with the agency. Uh, the
commissioner isn't I mean it's a large
agency. We're not directly communicating
with him. It's his staff that oversee
much of this work. Uh and so um as we uh
explore different strategies to be um to
be used in each of the turnaround plans
whether it's a three or two uh UA uh we
are getting feedback.
What I can commit to doing is providing
an update. Um I would say probably in
the next week uh we do have a couple
milestones set where we kind of uh are
able to talk to the agency. It's part of
the process. any school district in the
state of Texas that's going through this
process has a meeting with the agency
where they share with us um their
understanding. We share with them where
we are and the work that we're doing and
from that uh we could probably produce a
document. I don't know that I would get
be able to have the agency sign off on
it, but it would at least be our
understanding uh and takeaway. Um but as
far as the strategies that can be
approved by the agency, we're happy to
upload that and share that with our
community.
>> Thank you.
Thank you. Additional questions.
Um I just have one which uh we had some
callers ask for
um a better understanding of the
expected savings and I know that's
something we've talked about. Um, is
that possible? Certainly at the next
time we talk about the consolidations
plan, but maybe also posted on the
consolidations website really showing
that work and helping people understand
get a realistic understanding of how
much and where those savings come from.
>> Uh, yes. So, we've we've shared
presentations in the past and we can
probably um you know create another
piece of collateral that is easier to
distribute that shows kind of uh the
types of savings that occur uh when a
consolidation does take place. One of
the things that Katrina McGomery, our
CFO, and I are working on is the um
parallel model, financial model, so that
as we explore scenarios um and
ultimately, you know, come to a plan
that is released, we'll be able to show
kind of what that actually looks like
from both um um other direct cost um
reduction as well as a staffing
reduction. Uh our plan is always going
to be to um transition staff, make sure
because of our size, we're lucky and
that we can absorb and really support
staff in different ways that smaller
school districts can't. Um and so yeah,
we're happy to provide that. I will tell
you that Katrina and I are working on it
now, but we can go back and share and
maybe promote what we've already shared,
which is kind of where the costs come
from. Uh the other thing I I I want to
respond to just because it's kind of
it's tied is the the conversation around
um the focus on accountability versus
budget and the thoughts around slowing
down. What I want to be really clear
with our community is that the the risk
regarding our budget is is very very
similar to the risk regarding
accountability. Um, not being
financially able to make payroll, not
being able to meet our obligation is
something uh that I am not willing to
do, but a the agency has stepped in in
many many instances across the state of
Texas because of financial um distress.
And so it it is not um as known. It's
not something that we have uh been
notified of by the agency because we've
been proactive. We've been make doing
this work. We've been doing this hard
work. Um but I can tell you that there
are many examples. Uh and um it is very
very possible for a school district to
get in trouble with the agency because
they are not managing their financials
appropriately. And for us, we've been
very intentional about doing the hard
work. This is a part of that work. We've
made a commitment to the board to not go
below 15% unassigned fund balance. We
have strategies to get out and we've
communicated for the better part of a
year that this is one of those
strategies we have to go through. Um but
I that risk is very real. Uh and um it's
it's just one that I I don't want to be
maybe said separately than
accountability because they are very
much aligned. Additionally, not having
the resources to deploy to our campuses
is going to keep us from being able to
actually invest where we need to to
ensure that our students get what they
need to be successful. So, there are
they are very very much aligned for both
those reasons.
>> Thank you. Um, any addition? Yeah,
>> I have one question. Several of the
callers were talking about schools being
on closure lists and my understanding
from a timeline was that a plan would be
prepared and then publicly released
prior to our next board meeting. Um, so
did I miss a list or are people
accessing a list that doesn't exist? I
mean, where are these ideas coming from
that we're closing particular schools?
>> So, we have not released a list. Um, our
timeline has always been at the board
information session in October. Uh, when
we upload those documents, that'll be
the first time we have not only the the
um boundary change, program move, uh,
it'll have consolidations, everything.
Uh, one thing I'll tell you is I'm
anticipating uh because of the
expectation of getting up aligned feeder
pan patterns to where over 90% of the
boundaries in AIST will be impacted in
one way or another. Uh so um we have had
conversations with um the wall-to-wall
uh um communities. We value dual
language. It's something we're committed
to doing. be value to wall to all
programs, but we wanted to be um honest
about kind of where we are in the
process and communicate that the
emergent bilingual student population.
uh we know where they where they reside
in our attendance boundaries and we also
know that the transfer in rates to these
programs is is growing and growing and
growing and so to have stable programs
uh for years to come which is an
expectation I understood from the board
we have to have these conversations but
there is no list um we will be producing
it and uploading it but we have been
having these conversations so that our
community understands where we are in
the process
>> right and just note I did see on our
public documents on the consol
validation's website, it does include a
reference to potentially moving the wall
to wall dual language programs, but
there are a couple other schools brought
up that I don't understand why that
community feels that their name is on a
list, but I it's okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Uh any additional questions
or clar clarifications?
>> All right. Um thank you again to all of
our speakers and thank you trustees. Um,
as a reminder to our community, you may
share any general comments or questions
with the board by email at
trusteesaustinisd.org
and with individual trustees at um
emails on our website. Next up is the
president's report. Uh, as part of the
agreed order with the Texas Education
Agency, the agreement requires that the
board shall at the first board
authorized meeting each month publicly
report by reading into the record the
percentage of time invested in student
outcomes during the prior three-month
time period as described by Lonear
Governance and our agreed order and the
total time spent in closed session
during the prior month. The June, July,
and August three-month average board
meeting time spent on Lonear governance
defined student outcomes and special
education monitoring was 66%
which means we've exceeded our target of
50%. For the last month, August 2025, we
were at 79% and the board spent 283
minutes in executive session in August.
Um, I also really want to thank uh all
of my colleagues. I know people have
been at many, many community meetings,
um, meeting with people about
consolidations, going to meetings at
campuses around the turnaround plans,
really investing time beyond the board
meetings, meeting with community, and I
I know, you know, people sometimes don't
know this is an elected volunteer
position, unpaid, and I know we are
spending lots and lots of hours out
making sure we're hearing people,
listening to people, and understanding
the situation. and I want to thank you
all for um what you're doing.
Um our next item is part of our
commitment to discuss student
achievement and we have a presentation
on scorecard goal 4 algebra GPM 4.1
sixth grade advanced math. Um the report
will look a little bit different uh
going forward based on feedback that we
have gotten from our Lonear governance
coach. Uh before we hear our
presentation, we need to confirm that
our monitoring report is complete. And
uh we have some specific questions to
help us determine if the monitoring
report is complete or not. Um the first
question is does the report clearly show
which specific goal and interim goal is
being monitored? Does the report show
data for the three previous reporting
periods preferably on a line graph? Does
the monitoring report clearly show the
current reporting period? Does the
monitoring report clearly show the
target reporting periods, including
annual targets and a deadline target at
the end of the period? Does the
monitoring report clearly show the
superintendent's current view uh via a
defined set of indicators of the system
performance relative to the goal? Um
we've been talking about that as on
track, offtrack or um developing I
believe. Uh, does the monitoring report
clearly show supporting documentation
as evidence of the superintendent's
understanding of the performance and uh
the status of that goal? And if we're
not on target or the superintendent's
understanding of uh what's happening
indicates things are not on track, does
the report clearly describe the systemic
root causes um the responses of the
administration including why those
responses have been chosen and any
needed next steps. Um so just as we're
looking at a revised report really just
want to go through those things because
we have to affirm that they are there.
Um,
so given all of that, does anyone have
evidence that the elements are not
present?
All right. Thank you. Um, so now we will
turn the floor over to Superintendent
Sigura for the presentation. Thank you.
>> Thank you, President Boswell. Uh,
joining me tonight we have Dr. Maryanne
Maxwell, assistant superintendent of
academics, as well as Danielle Perico,
director of STEM. So, as you mentioned
in your opening remarks, uh we do have a
new uh monitoring report uh for our
community and and staff uh following
along. Uh our previous reports uh were a
little lengthier. Uh and um after an
evaluation of the first year of
reporting, uh and based on some feedback
we've gotten from our coach, uh we made
some some changes. A couple that I'd
like to call out is that it's a little
uh shorter in length, about five pages.
we did add several um graphs um to to
show logit intuitively um just how we're
performing over uh previous years and as
we move forward and so uh you'll see
that change um but I also will call out
one specific change um as I walk through
the first section of this report. So
this is um uh go progress measure 4.1 uh
which is supporting goal four. Goal four
states the percent of a of annual eighth
grade class members identified as
economically disadvantaged who
successfully completed the algebra 1
course by earning course credit and
achieving meets grade level or above on
the algebra 1 EOC will increase from 8%
in June of 2024 to 14% by June of 2021.
The goal progress measure uh that was
adopted uh uh the sixth grade
accelerated mathematics GPM 4.1 states
the percent of sixth grade students
identified as economically disadvantaged
who enroll in accelerated mathematics
and persist to course completion will
increase from 21% in June of 2024 to 39%
by June of 2029. Uh as always we have
initiatives uh within the organization
that uh inform much of our work uh and
it's important that we communicate you
know how this goal monitoring report is
supported by that and this one is most
um aligned to the middle years forward
initiative including engagement staffing
funding scheduling and support. So the
next section is a little bit different
uh so I want to um call our our families
and and staff's eyes uh to it. Uh it's a
a section called evaluation of progress.
Uh here is a section where the
superintendent uh takes all the
available information presented um in
the report as well as any additional
information that helps um determine I
guess helps me make a determination
whether we are on track. Uh so I'm
pulling not only the actual data but
also looking at historical trends
perhaps looking at different systems
that are in place uh and coming up with
a determination uh whether we're on
track both in short term for the annual
goal but also for the five-year horizon.
And if there's a differentiation, we
want to make sure that's clear because
you can be on track in one year one but
honestly be off track in year five. Uh,
and the inverse could also be true where
you're um off track in year one, but
it's because you you're kind of
calibrating. You're going to expect a
decline, but you expect to re recover in
year five.
Uh, so um acknowledgement of that
change. Uh the the statement here is
that the goal progress monitoring um
provides evidence the district is on
track to meet the middle school algebra
1 goal. uh 24% of sixth grade students
identified as the Columbia Advantage
completed the introductory accelerated
course 2425 an increase from 21% in 2032
24 data meets the current year targets
and suggests implementation is in line
with structures for both SP 2124 and
pathways to algebra 1 by 8th grade next
steps include better building uh
building better tracking tools to
progress monitoring students at the
campus and district levels providing
additional district programming for
students and targeting professional
development for staff
A couple other things that that um I'd
want to call out that kind of fed into
this this um statement. Uh are just some
some uh other operational changes. Uh
one is that sixth grade at many of our
elementary schools are uh in last year
in 2425 have now moved to the middle
school. And so when you think about the
different options uh for course
selection, uh an elementary school is
not going to have the same opportunities
that a middle school would have. So we
we know that more students are going to
have the ability um to have to
participate in these accelerated um uh
class uh courses. Another one of these
is that the way that we calculate this,
it's every student that enrolls uh over
the course of the year. So the
denominator is a very large number and
and doesn't necessarily change and we
don't change it based on students that
may move out of the system uh may drop
the course before we actually get to
snapshot. Uh so um if you can imagine
that the denominator that we're
capturing over the course of the year is
actually smaller than what we are
reporting then it gives me just more
confidence that we're um meeting the
target even if we already are as a
percent as a percent of the other thing
is uh what's really great about the goal
progress measures and just the way that
we've built out these scorecards is that
it's allowing us to really understand
how our system is working and making
adjustments appropriately. One of those
is is that there are other accelerated
math courses that aren't coded. is just
seventh grade math, right? When you're a
sixth grader, um another example of that
that we were talking about last week was
um IB at Manson. Um there's a math
course there would that would qualify
and but we're not counting it. And so
there as we kind of go through the
process and and bu build out the tool
and continue to improve um uh it's given
me um I guess uh a clear understanding
that that we are on track for this
specific goal progress measure. So not
only from a percent perspective but all
those other things also kind of
reinforce um that I guess position that
I'm sharing with the trustees. It's a
new section so if I'm fumbling to my
words that's why. Um but with that I'll
hand it over to Dr. Dr. Maxwell and the
team to take us through the rest of the
report.
>> Thank you, Superintendent Sigerta. Good
evening. Uh Boswell and board of
trustees. We're pleased to bring you
this report uh this evening that does
identify progress for students in the
goal progress measure towards algebra.
uh as uh Superintendent Sigura was uh
describing sixth grade students that are
in the accelerated math class which is
uh a blend of all of the sixth grade
standards and about half of the seventh
grade standards and that that is a
pretty good indicator uh and connection
we why we've chosen this as a goal
project because most of our students are
in this course. While we have other
courses and other ways for accelerated
math, this is a pretty good chunk of
students. It's the uh uh most
traditional pathway to taking algebra in
eighth grade. Uh and so we're pleased to
also report that we did meet the yearly
target. Um as discussed when when we're
talking about uh being on track, uh this
is providing us some early evidence of
some positive trends. um some of the
work that we've done around um numeracy
really at the elementary and middle
school level and uh Senate Bill 2124
which uh grabbed a larger group of
students based on their fifth grade star
results uh to to be identified to have
the capacity to be successful in
accelerated courses. So that is a big
part of why the enrollment is increasing
now and we expect to see continued
increased enrollment as um star scores
continue to improve in new mercy in
elementary schools. Um and as we
continue to uh uh identify courses that
really support students in accelerated
math and and put in some other supports
in place. Uh so some of the things too
we'll talk about this evening are what
we'll do uh looking ahead including some
MTSS structures in courses because this
evening's uh discussion really is a look
at the end of year. It's a full
completion of how students not only did
uh how how they how much they enrolled
but also how they did in the courses and
completed with passing grades. Um, so
which is the ultimate goal. We want them
to enroll, but we really want them to be
able to persist to completion and be
successful in this accelerated course so
that they're successful in the
accelerated math pathway after this. And
part of that is making sure that uh we
are providing some MTSS structures in
these classrooms if students are
struggling in the class. And so we want
to make sure we're not missing those
students just because they're an
advanced course. They may need supports
and scaffolds. and uh also discussed
tonight some targeted professional
development for teachers that would
support them in providing those
scaffolds. And then as Superintendent
Sigura mentioned uh looking forward
creating some some additional tool to
tools that really help us better track
our progress um and uh and do the do the
same work moving forward.
So overall this goal as discussed is
really middle school algebra. The board
goal is on algebra. We know that we want
them in that accelerated pathway that um
the traditional path where most students
will enroll is the eighth grade algebra
accelerated pathway. We know we want
students in accelerated math. We know
that has a a large impact, gives them
more opportunities for continued math
courses and accelerated courses in high
school. And it also makes it much more
likely if they start on this accelerated
math pathway and take advanced math to
um enroll and persist in post-secary
education and and obtain post-secary
degrees. So, it's a big difference
maker. For this particular GPM, we've
narrowed the focus on economically
disadvantaged students because we want
to make sure that we are providing this
opportunity to the historically
underserved students and we're
increasing that um enrollment and
persistence to completion and not just
an overall number of students with SB24.
So you can see as we look at the goal
progress measure, I'll speak a little
bit to this chart and our uh line graph
incorporated into the chart. Uh the
light blue on the left hand side
speaking of course completion is really
how historically we've done with
students who have enrolled and persisted
to completion of the course. And then on
the right side you can see the yearly
targets. So uh that is where we wanted
it to be 2425 and then continuing on for
the next 5 years for this goal progress
measure. You can see above the school
year for 2425
the um actual number that we met at the
end of the year matches the number that
we wanted for the target. So the target
was 24% and we did meet that target.
What you see in the middle are some the
numbers for progress monitoring that
came earlier this year. So twice last
year we reported these numbers in
progress moni mon monitoring. We wanted
to point out some of the differences
that are we saw in progress monitoring
with the final number. So the uh we
discussed some of the ways that we're
pulling this data and tracking it. And
what we found was as we looked during
the year so once in November and then
again in April we took a snapshot of the
students that were currently enrolled in
the course. So active enrollment in the
course and at that time it was 25% in
November 30% in April that were
economically disadvantaged and then you
see that number drop when it comes to
the final enrolled in the course and
persisted to completion. It may look uh
at at first glance that that means that
many students did not persist to
completion. That's not what that number
is telling us. What we're what
Superintendent Sugura was describing
earlier is that when we take a snapshot
for active enrollment, it's all of the
students that are in currently currently
enrolled. And when we take the picture
at the end of the year, it's any student
who was ever enrolled in that classroom,
whether they are currently enrolled or
not. So if you ever came into the
classroom, even if you left now, you are
included in that snapshot, that picture
at the end of the year. So the
denominator got bigger. So to use just
simple numbers on this, if it were 100
students that were enrolled actively in
November and 25 of them were
economically disadvantaged, that gave us
the 25%. In April, if it was still 100
students, 30% were identified as
economically disadvantaged. The way that
we pulled the data at the end of the
year, that number increased because of
the number of students that came in and
out. It included mobility rates. And so
if that number that number increased to
one say let's say 125 for easy numbers
even if the number on top was still 30
students it decreased to 24%.
So that's why it it explains some of
that difference in those numbers and
also learning through the process. It
would help us actually monitor a little
bit better if we're going to change the
way that we're looking at that data and
pulling that data through the year. So
it's a little more uh correlated to what
we would expect to see at the end of
year. Um so and there were uh a small
number of those students who also failed
the course. And so both of those numbers
together really contribute to why that
24% is lower than the 25 and the 30%
during progress monitoring. And Miss
Perico will talk a little bit more about
that as we talk about how the the data
was pulled. I just wanted to give that
introduction and say we have a line
graph. We have a couple of bar graphs in
the middle of the line graph to to show
that sort of mixed set of data. MCO
just did that. Sorry. Thank you. So
before we dive into the data, I do want
to give just a little overview of our
accelerated courses. So as a reminder,
sixth grade accelerated covers all of
the sixth grade standards and then half
of the seventh grade standards. As our
students progress into seventh grade
accelerated, then they receive
instruction in all of the eighth grade
standards and the remaining seventh
grade standards that were not covered in
sixth grade accelerated. This is
important to know because it's really
important that to understand that that
curriculum, sixth, seventh, and eighth
grade math is compacted into two years
so that students have the foundational
skills that they need to be successful
in algebra 1 and eighth grade and
beyond. Um because it's not just algebra
1, they need those foundational skills
for geometry, algebra 2, and other
advanced level classes. So, I just
wanted to kind of level set on that
before we now look at the data. And the
table that we have here um represents
our sixth grade students who are
identified as economically disadvantaged
that persisted to completion and
completed sixth grade accelerated math.
Um I want to draw your attention and we
talked a little bit about this already
but to that yellow column um that really
highlights the the final data for our
2425 school year. Um, and again, it
represents the sixth grade students
identified as economically disadvantaged
um, who completed that sixth grade
accelerated math course. So,
districtwide, as Dr. Maxwell said, 24%
of all sixth grade students identified
as economically disadvantaged did
successfully complete that sixth grade
accelerated math course. This was an
increase of three percentage points from
23 24 to our 2425 school year. Um, you
will notice though that again, as Dr.
Maxwell was pointing out in our previous
graph, we do have some discrepancies
between that data that was pulled in
November and April and that really had
to do with how progress was measured. So
that progress data was measured by
enrollment or active enrollment um where
the completion data at the end of the
year was not just actively enrolled, it
was any student enrolled, but also it
did include um or accounted for students
who did not pass the course. So, we did
have some students that didn't pass. Um,
and that course failure rate did impact
some of that progress monitoring. Um,
while only a small number, we did have
an overall 98% passing rate for the
course. Um, the it is disproportionate
the number of students who failed the
course um that were economically
disadvantaged. So, we'll talk a little
bit more about what we'll be doing for
that. Um so while we are proud of our
over overall progress and we've met that
that target um we do need to address
some of the disparities that we are
seeing. So we did not meet our target
for two of the student groups. So we met
our overall target but for two of our
student groups um we did not meet it.
However, we did have an increase from
prior years in all of our student groups
with the exception of our emergent
bilingual and economically student
economically disadvantaged student
group. um we did not meet our target for
Hispanic, Latinx, and economically
disadvantaged student group. However, if
you're looking at that table, you do see
an arrow pointing up. Um the reason for
that is we did make improvement. Um we
did go from 20% to 21%. However, our
target for that student group was 23%.
So, we know we still have some more work
to do. Um we did have one percentage
point decline for our emergent bilingual
and economically disadvantaged group. So
in looking at our root cause analysis,
we did determine the following that
access to accelerated math course was
one of the barriers. Prior to Senate
Bill 2124,
um typically historically our students
that were enrolled in accelerated math
courses were students that performed in
the mastery level on fifth grade star.
With the implementation of Senate Bill
2124, we now have opened access to
students. Um, the Senate bill requires
any student that scored in the 60th
percentile or higher on the fifth grade
star is now automatically enrolled with
the option to opt out. This does remove
some of that access barrier. Um, but now
that we know that we've removed that
access barrier, we need to take it one
step forward and look at success in the
course. what are we doing to ensure that
our students are being successful in
sixth grade accelerated continuing that
success in seventh grade accelerated
which then will continue the success in
algebra 1. Um so we really need to
couple that access that we're looking at
and couple it with success in the
course. Um so we did also recognize that
leads us into that we do have some
support gaps in our system. um students
really need consistent support before
the course, during the course, and even
after the course as they're preparing
for their next math course. Um so while
again we did have an overall passing
rate of 98%,
um students that were identified as
economically disadvantaged did fall to
passing rate of 94%. Um so to support
students, we will implement tools around
data tracking and monitor student groups
throughout the year so that we can
identify those needs in a timely manner.
We want to really make sure that what we
do in our grade level courses, we're
doing those for our accelerated courses,
too. Our students should have access to
tier 2 interventions, uh, scaffolds,
retach, all of the things that we know
are best practices in our grade level
math courses. We want to make sure that
we are doing that with our accelerated
math courses, too, to keep our kids on
track so that they can continue to be
successful in that pathway.
Our
data for Hispanic, Latinx, and
economically disadvantaged student
groups and emergent bilingual and
economically disadvantaged groups um
tells us we do need to dig deeper. We
need to look at what's happening. So
those were our st two student groups
where we need to continue to do some
work so we meet those targets the
following year. Um, one of the things
that we are doing, we're collaborating
with our multilingual education team to
really focus on contentbased language
instruction with specific supports
around u mathematical discourse. And
we're doing that through sentence
starters and structured conversations in
the math classroom. We know that
mathematical discourse is really
important in the math classroom because
it supports critical thinking,
conceptual understanding, problem
solving, and then ultimately using that
academic language in the classroom,
which is really important. Another root
cause we recognized was data tracking
inconsistencies. Dr. Maxwell talked a
little bit about this earlier um around
the different course codes that were
being used. We did recognize that some
campuses were using a slight variation
in a course code. So, we didn't actually
pull that into the data. So, we have um
put together structures to really help
campuses ensure that they're using
course codes that align with our
accelerated math course codes in order
to help us be more accurate with
tracking that data. Um, we did also find
that the way we were monitoring progress
didn't tell us the whole story. It told
us about enrollment, which again, that's
that first piece, making sure that we're
opening access for students, but it
didn't correlate with success in the
class. So, we're working really closely
to find different ways that we can track
success along the way to make sure we're
not just meeting enrollment, but we're
meeting success or providing success in
the classroom. Um, so we're working on
that and we'll continue to work on those
structures to really help our campuses
monitor that progress along the way.
Finally, I do want to highlight we have
some campuses that we want to talk
about. Musen, Geriski, and Anne Richards
um are three campuses that have shown
some success with their monitoring. Um
Mkasen and Anne Richards had more than
half of their economically disadvantaged
students enrolled and completed
successfully the sixth grade accelerated
math course. Geriski had approximately a
third of their economically
disadvantaged students enrolled and
completed the math course. And some of
the they have strong systems in place um
to really support student success. Some
of those systems are they provided tier
2 interventions in their accelerated
math classrooms. They had tutoring. They
provided scaffolds for the students. Um
AVID strategies. They did writing across
the content area. So lots of writing and
connecting that again with that
mathematical discourse piece. Um and
also they had student data tracking. So
we've talked a lot about how we want to
really have data tracking and have
campuses focus on that throughout the
year with our accelerated students. But
when you couple that with students
tracking their own data, it provides
them ownership of their learning and
putting those together are really the
two puzzle pieces that will really show
our success in accelerated math
classrooms.
>> So, uh steps to continue this work uh
and and continue to improve our outcomes
and our enrollment for economically
disadvantaged students. uh as Miss
Perico mentioned working in some areas
with campus level monitoring to really
ensure student success. And so with that
we mean working with teachers. This goes
handinhand with professional development
teachers um and using current classroom
data, their informal assessments,
formative assessments that they're
giving along the way. And the math team
has also written curriculum based
assessments for the accelerated courses.
in addition to all of our onle uh sixth,
seventh, and eighth grade courses. So,
we wanted to make sure and include this
accelerated group in those curriculum
based assessments. And those are
assessments that are uh a little bit
shorter in nature, but they only test
exactly what has been taught up until
that time. So, it gives teachers pretty
real-time information in um whether or
not students have mastered the content
that they've just taught. and we're
allowed to immediate uh from that we can
we're uh we have the capability of
immediately putting students in
monitoring groups to make sure that
they're continuing to be successful in
the classroom. That combined with those
MTSS structures for the supports
scaffolds any interventions those
students might need is really what will
help us monitor closely uh help teachers
monitor closely through the year um and
provide that information to campuses so
that they can do that that close
monitoring of how students are doing and
give real-time interventions.
uh we definitely uh are providing
targeted professional learning for staff
regarding that and also that's not just
teachers that's administrators. So we've
been focusing a lot uh already this year
in um all of our campuses and our middle
school campuses in observation and
feedback of classrooms and making sure
instruction is really strong. students
are doing uh grade level uh activities.
And in this case, that would be a
combination of sixth and seventh grade
standards and and that students are
successful in all of that and
administrators have what they need at
their fingertips to really give give
good quality observation and feedback to
teachers. That professional development
is part of this work. Uh making sure
that we're offering to that that
districtwide programming for students.
So, Miss Perico talked a little bit
about the supports that we're providing
before, during, and after. So during of
course once students are enrolled in
that course and we're giving um
real-time feedback and working with
students as they're progressing in the
course before uh references the bridge
program that we did for the first time
last year. Uh 215 students were invited
55 enrolled and attended that bridge
program. And so we're tracking their
progress throughout this year to see how
they're doing in that course and and
whether or not that was a successful uh
uh kickoff for them because uh their
their math scores may have identified
from fifth grade that they definitely
had the capacity for accelerated math.
We wanted to make sure that they felt
comfortable beginning in the course that
they felt uh uh positive and ready to go
in accelerated math by the time they
enrolled in sixth grade. So that's what
some of those before uh supports are
after. And then towards the end of the
year as we're seeing the success of the
students, making sure we even have some
uh some other uh in between bridge
programs for success for students
starting in in different levels of the
path, but making sure at the end of the
year as we're doing right now, looking
at any students that were successful,
that may have struggled um that didn't
pass those courses, having conversations
about if they could still be continuing
in this accelerated course. And so we
have that had that information for
teachers right from the beginning. um
did a pretty extensive job of looking at
that data on on our team and providing
that to campuses. So, they had that
information ready to go to
um and then finally, of course, we've
mentioned this, but making sure we're
modifying our uh district tools to
really help look at this and support
campuses with this information and make
sure that it's accurate information so
that they have what they need to to
support their students.
And that will end our presentation for
the evening and we will open it up for
questions. Thank you.
>> Um, thank you very much for all of this.
And now we'll open the floor to for our
monitoring conversation. Uh, our
questions during the meeting will be of
strategic nature, meaning we will ask
questions to help us understand how the
reality of our students is aligning with
our vision. And um, you may have noticed
that many of you I know saw the email
that Ashley Paw um, sent to us about um,
monitoring before this meeting.
um as a form of coaching. So, uh ready
for first question. Trusty Hunter,
>> thank you for the presentation. Um
you mentioned data inconsistencies and
you mentioned using the data to actually
track students. Uh my question is how is
the district strengthening data systems
to address inconsistencies between
enrollment and completion reporting and
accelerated math and how is that
information going to be used to identify
at risk students early and deploy timely
supports to ensure persistence and
success towards algebra 1 readiness.
So I think the beginning that we're
looking at is really uh and for purposes
of this report we want to make sure that
we're pulling data systems consistently
so that we're reporting overall and
we're making sure from the um kind of
highlevel perspective that we either are
on track or we're off track. So that's
one. So we would need to align the way
that we're pulling progress monitoring
data instead of using active enrollment
taking the same this may be what the way
we do it using all students at any time
that have been enrolled in the course so
that we have consistency. Um also uh
we've provided in the second document
that was attached this evening which is
the campus level report a little more
information about other students who are
enrolled in accelerated courses. Uh, and
so some of the things I think that we've
talked about that we might consider in
the district data level monitoring would
be including that information so that we
can see overall any student that might
be participating in an accelerated math
would be included in this and we can
look big picture at whether or not all
of our accelerated courses are having
the the effect that we think that they
are. Um, as far as persisting to
completion, that's a data point that you
don't get the completion part until the
very end of the year. And so what we
have done is one of it is actually have
a very uh have an improved data system
at the that that really has data at our
fingertips. It's called Edgehoria aware
that allows us to create monitoring
groups with all of the formative data
that's that teachers have inputed and
any uh additional assessments such as
curriculum based assessments that they
have taken. Once you create a monitoring
group for students, you can keep that
same monitoring group and continue to
run any sort of data through that group
and look at it through the year. So
that's more that real- time data system
that we have in place that's at campus's
fingertips and a teacher's fingertips to
help make decisions for their students
and know when they need interventions.
Okay, thank you for that. Um I
appreciate the explanation. Uh my
basic question is have we fixed the
problem so that moving forward because I
I heard you say we will do it. So have
we done it so that the next data that we
get will be true or more true I should
say.
I could say that if we continue in on
reporting this and continuing to report
to report on this goal and the goal
progress measure, we would definitely
come up by the time we report again h
have it pulled so that it is consistent.
>> Okay. Thank you. It helps. But
>> thank you.
>> Yeah. And I think Trusty Hunter thing I
would add is EduRia and kind of the
expansion of it was a recent um change
that we made within our own school
district to address this part of this
issue. Um it was just implemented this
past summer. this is the first year that
we're actually rolling it out. So that's
really an acknowledgement of kind of a
change in what we saw in previous years.
Um and so that that's one change that we
can kind of point back to just, you
know, several months ago. And then the
the way that we pull the data, that's
just a reflection of us of going through
one year of the reporting cycle. So I do
expect the way that we're we pull a
better reflection. Um and so I think
both those things will will help improve
how we show the data.
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
Additional questions.
Secretary Gonzalez.
>> Hi. Thank you. Um so you mentioned
supports before in your main port your
main report in the root cause analysis
you mentioned that supports before
during and after are insufficient. Can
you talk about some of the systemic
redesign that is going to guarantee
particularly students that are at
campuses that have received a D or an F
um how they're going to receive
non-negotiable supports rather than
relying on campus bycampus capacity or
implementation.
So I think one of the things that we did
um was really implementing that math amp
up bridge program that was for rising
sixth graders and it was a pilot year.
So we did invite students from our
highest need campuses at the middle
school like rising sixth graders. um we
did only have 55 attend but I as a pilot
we were we were trying it out seeing how
it worked and we're looking forward to
really monitoring those students this
year to see if they were successful and
then hoping to expand that. So, while
right now it's not mandatory that they
attend, that is one really important
piece before because sixth grade
accelerated math is really fast-paced
and we really want there's so many
things happening when kids start sixth
grade. So, really encouraging and having
more outreach, I think, will really help
have our attendance higher and see how
that will really impact students and set
them up for success starting that sixth
grade year in accelerated math. Um I
think you know I'm looking forward to
seeing what the data shows this year and
then hope that we can get more students
attend and expand it um for next year.
>> Yeah. Good evening. In addition to that,
we um have principal training for all
principles. Danielle was just involved
in that training yesterday at our first
level principles meeting this school
year where all middle school principles
met at Gritsky Middle School. We looked
deeply at the data, did data dives, and
then we talked specifically about not
just um Trusty Hunter persisting to
completion, but going beyond completion,
like were they actually successful in
the course, excuse me. So, we noticed
that um it's not just having a high
enrollment of students that represent
certain student groups in the course,
but what were their actual like scores,
student achievement level, that data,
and then at what point did we know that
students were not successful? So, we've
been having deep coaching with executive
directors, looking at data, specifically
at our DNF campuses, but at all of our
campuses at the middle school level, and
having those hard conversations with
principles and admin teams. So, we
noticed that about 30% of students that
were enrolled in algebra were not
successful at the middle school level at
this campus. At what point did we know
there was a problem? And then what
supports were provided to persist along
the way? So it's not enough to have
students enrolled but we want them to be
successful and to achieve in those
courses. Um one of those things is data
protocols that we're putting across all
campuses um that are required. Now there
are campuses that already have their own
protocol some campuses but we are
identifying like key essential factors
and elements that must be included in
whatever protocol we use. So just a
baseline factor. We've heard the
community, you know, ask loud and clear
for some academic baseline points. And
these are baseline points we are putting
into place when it comes to progress
monitoring data protocols, looking at
students that are in um courses and
ensuring that we have pathways of
completion and success for them,
ensuring that parents and families are
informed about that progress that
students know how to data track and
monitor that individual progress as
well. And then lastly, learning labs. So
learning lab is new for our secondary
schools. We have about seven schools
outside of our office of school
improvement schools that are included in
these learning labs. And these may be
schools in the past that may not have
received that type of deep level
support. We're talking about Keeling um
a part of our learning lab. Lively
Middle School as well as Betachch um
Dolby Barnett Martin Prett Covington a
wide array of schools that are in in
immersed in this deep learning. We met
um at Marshall Middle School, which is
our lighthouse school, for our first
meeting last week, and principles were
able to dive deep into that and do
instructional rounds with coaches around
what it looks like for effective
instruction, and then how to coach
administrators, principles, and teachers
up to that level to ensure that we're
all using high quality instruction
materials, that we're progress
monitoring, that we are committed to
data protocols that are standardized
across campuses, and that we are
constantly talking about supports,
progress monitoring, and being able to
scaffold students pun intended level of
mastery
>> teacher training next week.
>> Yes, we have a huge teacher training
next week, next Monday and Tuesday at
Austin High School. We have about 100
teachers, about 200 total maybe, but in
math and reading um that are coming for
all of our learning lab campuses, every
math and reading teacher is required to
attend as well as our instructional
coaches, assistant principles,
principles, and our executive leadership
team and academics team. So, we'll be
engaged in that learning on Monday and
Tuesday so that we can move as a system
across the bandwidth.
Great. Thank you.
>> Oh, I have another one.
>> Oh, yeah. Go for it. You want me to
stop?
>> I do not want you to stop. Um,
>> I I love our summer bridge programs. and
when done well, they they they're just
great sort of positive accelerants. So,
um I hadn't picked up on yet and so with
my apologies, I didn't get that we were
kind of piloted. I was wondering about
attendance versus capacity and I was
wondering about um participation rates
of say African-American
students. So, so first like how are we
going to where are we with that? and it
seems like we're underenrolled with some
of our groups that we know were
underserving. So, how are we going to
kind of take a look at that and get up
to a better participation rate among
targeted groups?
>> Yeah, thank you for that question. I
think it's really about one
communication. So, communicating earlier
with our campuses, making sure we have
all the support and make sure we have
all uh parents have information. We did
a parent meeting last year, but again,
it was we brought this pilot together
really quickly because we saw the
importance of it, but it was timing may
not have been on our side. Um, but
continuing to really look into that
data, making sure now that we have
Edaphoria is really going to help us
really look at that data, target
students. Um our goal is for it to be
open to all students, but really
targeting where is the biggest need
right now and making sure that we are
getting getting out there inviting
sending you know counselors everyone is
supporting to make sure that parents
have the information. We did send um
printed handmade invitations to go home
to the families because we know
sometimes that you know different ways
we had multiple ways of getting around.
We had um campuses reach out to the
families as well as providing that. But
I think really looking at that data,
targeting, making sure we just continue
to make phone calls and really try to
encourage those kids. Uh we had a lot of
great feedback from those that did
attend. So even getting some student
feedback and sharing that to really hype
up the the program. Um but ultimately
our goal would be having it at every
campus. um might not be next year, but
that would be our goal is every campus
to host their own to bring in their own
students to their school to already
start building those relationships and
then building on the the necessary
skills to be successful.
>> Awesome. And and thank you for that. And
um and so I'm hearing about sort of
communication and I'm hearing about
targeted communication and I'm hearing
about direct outreach, which I all all
great. Um and then I guess staying on
this before I I yield back. Um,
one of the advantages of something being
smaller the first time around is that
there's a greater pointed opportunity,
you know, for learnings and also now we
have a little bit of an on-ramp or we
have a ramp because we're looking at
next um summer. So, do we have a sense
of how to make sense of u the
effectiveness side like you know are we
I guess what are our plans to say well
here are the kids that participated from
different demographic groups here's what
happened the next year and then using
that to refine and improve um the roll
out for next summer. So what are we
doing along those lines?
>> Yeah, thank you for that. So with our uh
curriculum based assessment data this
year, that's going to really help us
because now we can pull that naphoria,
we can look at the students that
attended and look at the things. So we
focused a lot on proportional reasoning
and and fluency um in that camp. So we
can look at how did students do on those
skills on their curriculum based
assessments throughout the year. So we
don't have to wait till star data. Last
year we just looked at STAR data to see
who we could identify to invite to the
camp. And now we can we'll have data
from um elementaryaries are doing
curriculum based assessments to so we
can look at fifth grade data and really
target and look at where the biggest
need is and look at trends. Maybe it
wasn't proportional reasoning. That's
what we chose to do for this summer. But
now we can look at all of that data and
really decide what is the biggest need
for that summer camp and make sure that
we're we're targeting that.
>> Nice. So not only the data from this um
from this year's attend camp attendees
we'll say is informing um next year but
what's actually happening in our
elementary schools and what we're
learning about where they are in their
needs is going to inform the the the
lesson plans and the curriculum for the
summer camp that's really cool okay
thank you and thank you trusted Gonzalez
>> okay um so in looking at the appendix
that you mentioned um on the table that
details the campus completion. Um
there's quite a range for economically
disadvantaged students on some campuses.
It's uh excluding the ones that no
longer have sixth grade this year. Uh
there are some that are lower than 10%
while others are above 60.
um how are you going to ensure that the
lowest performing campuses are going to
catch up rapidly um rather than allowing
this gap between campuses to persist.
So part of that is that active
monitoring of data as it's coming in in
real time this year to identify those uh
gaps earlier. And I think monitoring
this and looking at it having one year
completion data is super helpful with
that to see where we ended that uh the
year and looking specifically at
economically disadvantaged. Uh part of
it though is really using information
from our outliers. So one of the things
that uh really uh Dr. Wilson and Dr.
Emerson are are so intent on is having
principles very intentionally share with
each other the strategies that they are
using that are successful, very open
with data, very uh ready to talk about
these things that that are working well
and and pulling principles for those to
have principles talk about those
processes that are happening on those
campuses and then giving them some time
to really internalize that work and
figure out on their campuses how they
might be might be able to replicate some
of those processes. So it's really I
think it's just a little bit of both
watching knowing where we are now from
last year's uh data and then looking at
current but for sure giving principles
the opportunity to share those
strategies that they know are working
because when we see like the kind of
outer outlier data that we talked about
where if you have you know 33% of
students identified but 67%
uh students overall are the makeup of
the enrollment then you've done uh all
of those strategies to to really
identify students and make sure that
they're successful and that they
completed the course.
>> All right. Thank you. Uh, additional
questions.
>> I mean, all my questions have been
answered by the report. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> My questions have already been asked and
answered.
>> Okay. Thank you. My questions have been
answered. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Um, I have a few questions.
Um
uh one is looking at you know we're
seeing improvement in all groups you
pointed out in the report except our
emergent bilingual um students with
economic disadvantage and um I know
we're seeing large differences kind of
large growth in some and small growth in
others in addition to that one group
that didn't grow. Do we have an
understanding of why we're seeing the
big differences among different groups?
Yes, we uh definitely talked about that
in the report and always want to make
sure that um we're noticing where those
where those gaps exist in student
populations. Um it's a little with the
increased enrollment this year with with
SB 2124 and um some of the new things
that we've put in place. Uh I think it
would be prudent of our team, we've
talked about this, to really kind of
watch what kinds of interventions have
been successful this year um to to help
that kind of root cause analysis a
little a little more long term on what
beh what might be happening with those
populations. Again, we mentioned this to
some of the complications of when you're
looking at a a smaller number uh within
uh Hispanic population. We've definitely
seen some shifts in in that population
and just our overall enrollment and uh
saw that saw those shifts happen in
during the year last year and so that
may be affecting this and so we might
need just a little bit more long-term
data to to make those determinations.
>> Thank you. And yeah, I appreciate
clarifying kind of what that shifting
trend was that it was just losing
students during the year. So, thank you
for that. That's very helpful. Um,
and I think, um, when we look at that
enrollment versus completion data, uh,
and and I appreciate the explanation of
kind of what we're seeing and and how
that might come into better focus as we
get a better understanding of this. So,
um, I'll be interested to see that and
thank you for the bars that on the line
that I think it it explains what we're
looking at. So, thank you for that. Um
what do we need to more fully understand
um within this data um kind of looking
ahead uh kind of who dropped the course
who failed the course versus who left
the campus kind of what what needs what
do we need to understand that better
>> uh I'll u start this with just an intro
and and hand it over to Miss Perico too
because I know she's been working very
closely with one of our coordinators on
this specific data uh we looked looked
very closely at the students that did
not pass the course so that we could
understand um not only what they uh how
they had been identified, how they and
why they had enrolled in the course, um
any factors that such as how they had
previously performed on uh STAR, any
assessment data that we found and and
various factors like that. Miss Perico
could probably name a few more to really
dig into that. That's some of that
initial year data that we wanted to look
at and and be sure to share with
teachers for the kids moving on.
Yeah, I'll just add um we we dug really
deep actually into that data and we
looked at uh star scores from a couple
years ago to look for trends and
patterns. Um and we noticed like some of
our students they they mastered and then
we saw a decline like maybe they went
down to meets and then approaches or and
then we had some kids that came in and
meets and then they got masters. So
looking really closely what are some
trends that are happening and then what
what are we doing on campuses to support
we did also look at students that
actually were in the course that were in
it due to autoenrollment from Senate
bill and some of the kids that did not
pass the course were not autoenrolled.
So, these some of these kids actually
did not meet um on fifth grade star, but
because we do have open enrollment, uh
parents can decide, I still want I want
to challenge my my student. I want to
try to have them in there. And that's
really where that progress monitoring is
so important because we need to be
monitoring them along the way, providing
supports and then having real
conversations. Are these supports
working? If not, what is the best choice
for that student academically? But it
was really interesting to see what
students were autoenrolled, what were
not. So we want to continue to look at
that data, but we've been really digging
into looking at historical data and now
super excited that we're going to have
the curriculum based assessments so that
we can really look throughout the year.
What are those trends that we're seeing
which will also impact our curriculum
too and it'll impact any changes that we
need to make to support and in our
professional learning for teachers.
>> Thank you for that. Um, any further
questions?
All right. Thank you so much for this.
Really appreciate the information and
look forward to learning more. Um,
so trustees, thank you for the
conversation. And now we vote on whether
or not we accept this monitoring report.
And as a po point of clarity, we're
voting to accept this report as a formal
acknowledgement that we had a
satisfactory conversation with the
superintendent and have a deeper
understanding about how the current
reality for students lines up with our
vision for them. And I will entertain a
motion to accept the report.
>> I move to accept the report.
>> Thank you, Secretary Gonzalez. Is there
a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you, trustees. Any discussion?
Having a motion by secretary Gonzalez
and a second by trustee Kintana to
accept the monitoring report. All in
favor, please raise your right hand
and the motion passes by all on the dis.
Thank you. Um and thank you all for um
taking part in this uh process.
Uh next up is our scorecard goal um
three C uh college career military
readiness. our goal project measure
three which is industrybased
certification aligned courses. We have a
new team coming up. Um and this is also
related to our commitment to student
achievement. Uh so before we hear our
presentation we need to confirm all the
things we read uh during our last
presentation that our report is complete
and this report also all of our reports
going forward will look different. Um so
considering the questions we um that
have been shared, does anyone have any
evidence that the elements of an
effective report are not present?
All right. Thank you. So um now we will
turn the floor over to you
superintendent again.
>> Uh thank you President Boswell. Tonight
I have joining me Dr. Maryanne Maxwell,
assistant superintendent of academics,
Ashley Baker, executive director of
secondary outcomes, and uh Dr. Wilson,
uh, assistant superintendent of
secondary school leadership. So, um, as
we kind of move into this report, I I
want to state, uh, the goal, uh, goal
three, CCMR, and again, just reminding
everybody, this is a new reporting
structure. Uh goal three uh states the
percent of annual graduates who
demonstrate college career and military
readiness CCMR by meeting Texas Success
Initiative TSI criteria and at least uh
and at least of one of the following
items. Earning an associates degree
concurrent with graduation enrolling at
a post-secary institution following
graduation, earning an industry based
certification or earning a level one or
level two certificate will increase from
43.7% for the class of 2022 to 54.6% 6%
in the class of 20 27. The goal progress
measure identified in our scorecard GPM
3.3 IBC aligned courses states that the
percent of 11th and 12th grade students
who enroll in courses aligned with an
industry based certification or an IBC
and persist to successfully course to
successful course completion will
increase from 46.8% in June 2024 to 55%
by June of 2029. Uh the initiative that
this most closely aligns to is the one
um that we've identified and named
post-secondary success. Uh elements
within it include college readiness, uh
enrollment, CTE, and graduation.
Uh the new section uh as stated uh just
you know about an hour ago uh is the
superintendent's evaluation of progress.
Uh and again there are many different
things that influence um the the
determination uh not just the data that
is um pulled by the team not just the
conversations but also analyzing systems
we have in place uh looking at
historical trends uh and our overall
trajectory. So the statement um or the
the goal progress measure monitoring
provides evidence uh that the district
is on track to meet CCMR goal targets
59.8% % of all 11th and 12th grade
students successfully completing
completed one or more course courses
aligned with an IBC 20 IBC 2024 25 data
exceeds the current year 47.2%
and also 5-year targets of 55%. Uh data
suggests concurrent implementation of
CTE programs of studies of study are
successful. uh next steps include
connecting the IBC uh alignment to
individual graduation planning, IBC
completion, data digs and building out
with industry partners. So yes, uh this
is one of the uh goal progress measure
that um exceeds uh not only the
short-term goal um but already the
five-year target. uh some of the things
that um I wanted to kind of share that
kind of helped me determine that we were
on track which is just not the numbers
but also some of the work that we've
done over the last uh two years. Um one
of the ones that might uh that our
trustees might recall is all the work
around the universal choice sheet. Uh we
spent a lot of time um you know making
sure that we had introduced that. But
one of the things that was different
this time around uh was um the fact that
uh CTE um team actually kind of place
the the courses on the universal uh
course selection sheet opposed to the
campuses identifying themselves. Uh so
that ensured that the um that our
students that uh were potentially
selecting a course knew that it existed.
uh which is which was um something that
we had not done previously but again you
had to have the universal core sheet
first then you had to have the team in
place then you had to have the authority
to do so uh a lot of alignment in
counseling and training uh you know the
work that we've done over the last year
and a half and restructuring uh
additionally
uh we have um really uh been focusing on
making sure there's an awareness before
a drop occurs uh our students um you
know are making lots of different
decisions in their academic journey And
it's always important for us to to
ensure that they're making the decision
with all the information available. And
so last year when we came to you, we
talked about the fact that we have some
controls in place now. Uh it is not it
it just dropping a course is not
something that is able to be done
without the counselor signing off uh
notification to family. Uh and and that
has allowed us to have that critical
conversation before a drop is fully
executed. uh what we found in the past
is sometimes that was occurring uh and a
pathway um that a student was on is all
of a sudden eliminated and and that's
certainly not something we want to do as
an organization. Uh the last thing I'll
say is about a year and a half ago, we
also made a commitment um to invest in a
Salesforce product that assisted with
not only CCMAR but also CTE TSI. Uh and
a lot of that work has has been done. Um
phase two, which is really focused on
the CTE work, is underway. Um so with
all of that um and the fact that we've
exceeded our goals um both short-term
and long term kind of give me the
confidence that we are truly on track.
Uh so wanted to kind of make that
statement before I hand over to the team
to take us through the rest of the
presentation. Off to you Ashley or Dr.
Maxwell.
>> Thank you uh Superintendent Sigura.
pleased uh again to bring you a report
tonight that uh we uh are uh noticing
definitely some great trends in this
area uh of our 11th and 12th graders.
They've made great progress and some
things that the team has put into place
have been very effective and some of
them seem like very simple things but
once you get everyone working towards
the same simple things and are aligned
you've got some some pathways for
students and some courses that really
work out for them that result in them
being able to if they choose this path
have industry based certifications. Uh
so some of the things we'll talk about
tonight are those those things that have
been done and also some some next steps
to continue that work to make sure that
we're continuing with IBC alignment in
everything that we're offering in
graduation plans and really talk a
little bit more about how we're using
the data to help campus campus
administrators and groups of people
working on campuses that we make visits
to of using our CCMR dashboard with that
data as a springboard and then really
monitoring ing CCMR plans for students.
So, this is based on the overall goal
that is college, career, and military
readiness. Multiple ways that students
can achieve this this goal in this work
to be college, career, or military
ready. This one that we're talking
tonight about tonight, of course, is
industry based certifications. Uh there
are some other ways uh that we would
continue to measure this throughout the
year for students. And of course,
students can hit CCMR readiness in
multiple ways. is another way would be
uh showing that they're college ready
through um the Texas Su success
initiative with the TSI 2.0 test in math
or language arts. Um another way of
course is is military readiness. Some
other things that we talk about in the
year um in in progress as a progress
measure toward this goal. Specifically
here this goal progress measure does
look at our 11th grade and 12th grade
students completing in an IBC aligned
course. The key component for this
implementation is that the state defined
programs of study a few years ago. They
established that in 2019 with expected
implementation starting in 2021. So
Austin ISD's response to that was to
align our course sequences with TEA
series of learning so that we knew
students when they started those core
sequences they would be set up for
success and in the right path. and we'll
describe some of that work not only with
students and families but with
counselors at our schools to do that.
You can see from our I got to scroll.
Remind me to scroll uh from our from our
line graph on this that on the left side
we have past years of course completion
all the way up to this current year of
2425 at 59.8%.
Next to that in the darker blue you have
our yearly target. So you can see our
yearly target this year underneath that
was 47.2. So we definitely have met that
target and in fact we've met the targets
for the next five years for this GPM. So
the incredible work been been done by
the team. So it's it's exciting news and
it's definitely exciting news for our
students and and being able to reach
this kind of readiness should they
choose to get uh to be find this
readiness through industry based
certifications.
Miss Baker.
>> Well, Superintendent Sagura and Dr.
Maxwell took all the fun things that I
was going to tell you. Um, so yeah,
programs of study when TEA instituted
programs of study, essentially a program
of study is a series of four courses,
typically four courses. A student could
do it in three, but they're going to
finish those courses. It's going to be
three or more courses for four or more
credits. Now, you know that this aligns
also with our accountability measures.
So now moving forward, we need those
students to be completers, which they
would have four credits um and then also
finish that IBC. So when TEA instituted
that years ago, we've, you know, we've
seen the writing on the wall. We've
known that it's coming. So in response
to that, Austin ISD needed to make a
more strategic and systemic approach to
where, how, when we offer CTE courses
for students. Um, not only that, but we
break those courses down into four
levels. So uh, TA breaks it down in
levels one to four. Of course, level
three and four are those higher levels.
you're going to see those the content
dig more into the the career aspects of
it. The rigor is going to be higher for
those courses. So, when we're going to
walk through this data, I want you to
think about um not only are those
students, we're talking about those
level three and four courses, but we're
talking about the juniors and seniors
from last school year, so school year
2425.
And not only did they enroll in those
courses, but they were successful in
completing those courses.
So, I am proud to announce that our
Austin ISD students have not only
surpassed this year's target, but our
five-year target um quite well, in fact.
So, our target this year was um 47.2%
and we surpassed that with 59.8%.
Um but also, not only did we do that as
a whole of Austin ISD, our all of our
students student groups not only showed
growth, but they met our target for this
year, which is really outstanding. So,
our uh for example, our Asian student
group has surpassed that with 13.9
percentage points. And our
African-American and our uh Hispanic
student groups surpassed with 10.9
percentage points and 10.3 percentage
points. While that is outstanding, we do
recognize too that some of our student
groups, while they surpassed this year's
targets, they haven't met that five-year
target like some have. So, uh an example
of that is our African-American students
and our students receiving special
education. So they're meeting our
current targets, but we want to see the
same growth that we see for others as
well. So we're going to do more focused
work with that student group across the
district. I think it's important to know
too that our IBC data shows that our
students are making strong connections
between not only the courses but
committing to that IBC. So, of the 11th
and 12th grade students who were
enrolled in an IBC aligned course last
year, those level three and four
courses, 38% of them earned the IBC that
corresponds with those courses, which
means that our 11th and 12th graders
last year, over a fifth of them at 23%
earned an IBC, which is outstanding.
It's shown a lot of growth through the
last five years in in CTE alone.
So, how did we get to this level of
growth?
um tea instituting those programs of
study required us to um make that
systemic approach and um we've had to
cultivate a culture of not only
excitement around IBC's and CTE but also
an expectation of these students are
going to take the IBC's and that's not
just for the students that's for the
administrators and the teachers because
it has been a culture shift and an
expectation shift over the last few
years not just in Austin ISD that's
across the state um
uh superintendent Sagu mentioned the
universal core sheets and I want to say
that there's a clear impact in the data
when universal course sheets went into
effect starting the 232 24 school year
and that was a direct ask from the
trustees. We have seen a major shift in
success in that factor.
So, by creating this standardized
document that is districtwide, we've
given parents and their families and
students the ability to see a
clear guidance on what that course
sequence should look like. And also, it
helps us to avoid inadvertently limiting
the access for any students to go into
those courses.
Like you also said, Mr. Sagura that we
uh CTE established a drop form so that
anytime a student considers dropping out
of a program of study because if they're
going to drop that course it likely
means that they would also program. We
want to make sure that the counselor has
the opportunity to have that
conversation with the student. Um it may
not only be the counselor maybe the
teacher gets notified too to say hey
like what what's going on? And so it's a
more well-rounded approach to working
with that student. I think all in all um
you know we talk a lot about messaging
and communication and how important it
is and I think that that's where univers
universal court sheets really came from
the heart of it that we want to
communicate with our families and that
is the good work that has come from that
and so now our families are consistently
getting that messaging across the
district with the work of the CTE team
who's worked really hard with campus
administration and CTE at the campuses
to align those programs to fit the
campus and fit the student needs. Of
course, I I know that we've seen student
success across the district, but it
really could not be done without the
hard work that's happening at our
campuses as well. So, our campuses uh
are doing outstanding work, not only in
administrative monitoring, but working
with CTE.
Our CTE programs and some of our PEK
programs are really strong because of
that work. And I'd like to highlight a
few outliers that we see across the
district. The first of those is Akens
High School. So Akens Early College High
School. Uh that one, you know, they just
have such a strong AC uh academy model
that they can support the extensive CTE
course catalog that they have on that
campus. They have a lot of programs, but
they've got well wraparound service or
great wraparound services for those
students because of the the academy
model that they support students with.
Also, Buoie High School. Buouie High
School has a strong foundation of course
sequencing. They're doing intentional
work with four-year planning. So those
families and those students, they're
making those decisions as they go
through and the counselors are working
hard to focus on the four-year planning.
also Crockett Early College High School.
These students have a fost or fostering
a culture of career readiness through
cross-curricular
work m sorry mostly supported by their
avid strategies. Those students are
making real world connections between
their academic learning to the career
opportunities ahead of them. and LBJ
Early College High School. LBJ is making
significant gains by strategically
integrating the early college high
school programs with CTE programs. And
they've had results uh that with
impressive gains particularly for their
African-American students and their
Hispanic students.
And Dr. Maxwell will walk us through
some next steps.
>> Thank you.
So we really just want to make sure that
we're continuing that consistency uh
that uh of the work with the programming
with the core sequ sequencing making
sure things are really clear for
campuses and that our department
continues to have a strong uh colle uh
collaboration and connection with
counseling and that they are part of all
of this work because they know they have
regular touches with students not only
in enrollment but in uh in the courses
and and and working on that graduation
plan but also need to be part of that
conversation if a student wants to drop
a course and understanding how that
really will affect the the outcome and
and the choices. Uh so definitely want
to keep that uh strengthening that
four-year planning and focusing on data
to really help us make these decisions
and know where our students are. So our
our data is really focused on the larger
picture of CCMR and when the team goes
out, we've already started these
secondary outcomes meetings, the CCMR
meetings at campuses. So we go out to
campuses. We're specific with sitting
with that staff and using the with
talking through just you know everything
that is CCMR current updates so that
they make sure everyone's well informed
but then also take some very explicit
time with the staff with administrators
to taking the data from the CCMR
dashboard and then downloading that in
an individual student data to an
individual student data level
particularly to the students at that
campus. We worked on that structure uh
with Dr. Wilson to make sure that we
were providing principles, assistant
principles, counselors, the staff at the
campus the time that they needed to
really go through that data and see
where the students are with CCMR
readiness. So mo our students can find
us of course and many do in in multiple
can sort of check the CCMR box in
multiple ways, but sometimes we look at
that data and we see there may already
be a sophomore or a junior that hasn't
indicated CCMR readiness. And so that's
an immediate plan. Of course, we may
notice that a sophomore isn't on a
pathway to do so. And so we that's that
opportunity for them to really make
individual decisions for students at
their campus. Can't finish everything in
that one meeting for hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and thousands of
students. But it does give them that
process to be able to continue that. And
then we continue our meetings with
campus. So we go back out, we check on
that progress, we pull the data again
and see where the students are again and
see what uh paths have what
interventions have taken place, what
conversations with students have taken
place to make sure that they're on the
path that they need to be.
And that is the end of this report and
we welcome questions. Thank you.
>> Perfect. Thank you for this. Um it's
nice to have two meetings of really
exciting data in a row. So just want to
call that out. I I want to call it on
page three. Um you wrote what we are
doing is working and now we can see it
and and it's really now we see it. So
thank you. It's really exciting um to
have such strong results um and such
great big growth all at once. So thank
you. Um so trustees questions.
Trusty Hunter.
>> Thank you.
Um,
it's not a long question, but I'll make
sure that it's
that you can get all the parts of it.
So, how is the district monitoring and
supporting student performance and IBC
aligned courses to ensure that gains in
enrollment translate into successful
course completion and industrybased
certifications for all student groups?
>> That is a good question. Um, so to
expound on what Superintendent Sagura
said earlier about the CCMR dashboard.
So I was on a meeting just this morning.
Um, we are opening up the second phase
of that which we're calling CC pathways.
So now for the first time ever, our
counselors, um, our administrators,
we're actually going to be able to see
where students are in that four-year
plan uh, for CTE. So it's going to track
the course sequencing for us. So instead
of having to go through student by
student and see hey did they meet these
four courses it will show us that data.
So that alone just the manh hours
included in that will be so much more
effective and efficient. Um but also
working with our teachers to not only do
professional learning with them but h
there's more and more
resources available to help students
learn prior to taking the IBC. So we
want to make sure that we're providing
them the practice test. Some
certifications come with practice exams.
They come with uh a series of courses
that the students go through. Every
certification is different. Uh but we
make sure that those teachers also have
the avail the availability to do the
professional learning to help the
students pass those exams too.
>> Okay. Um and then I just have a a
clarification question. Did you say that
African-American students did not meet
the five-year goal?
>> So no, they've met the current goal, but
they have not surpassed the five-year
goal. Perhaps I'm reading this
incorrectly. What is the five-year goal?
>> Oh, did they?
>> Oh, they sure did.
>> Okay. I'm like I'm not a math person.
I'm a history person.
>> I can tell 50 is bigger than 40.
>> Okay.
>> I should go back to the middle school
algebra one.
>> Okay. Thank you. I just wanted to make
sure that I wasn't looking at something
incorrect.
>> Correct.
>> Perfect. Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Thank you. Additional questions.
asked and answered.
>> My questions have been answered. Thank
you.
>> I have a question.
>> Thank you.
I guess in in hearing um this wonderful
report, I hate to be the a Debbie
Downer, but I guess I'm just wondering
if you anticipate any changes happening
in the future that could affect the
success that we are seeing or will see.
I think one so uh yeah um trusty
canthana one of the things that the team
and I talked about um this comes around
well you know should we reset our goals
or our targets because we've been
successful and I I'm of the opinion that
we need to at least keep them for one
more year and what could affect this is
any changes from tea right so we've
talked about that um you know the
requirements for IBC's what IBC's count
versus don't count just a couple years
ago there were some that dropped off and
so district's numbers were shifted quite
significantly. So um that to me would be
something that uh would impact this but
I think with the tools that we have in
place the awareness the systems we'd be
able to manage that. So you might see
like a shift but I don't think you would
see us move in the wrong direction if
that makes any sense. Uh but that to me
would be one thing that's outside of our
control um that could be an impact.
I don't know team is that I mean we
talked about that. I don't know if
there's anything else
>> feel good about it.
>> Okay
question. So thank you because that that
helped me crystallize what what I was
thinking there. So I think along those
lines and I appreciate the the comment
about extending you know at least for
one more year. Um, you know, my question
was about, you know, given what we're
seeing with the successes of the of the
universal choice sheet and the
initiatives that you've already done is,
you know, the expectation that the gains
are going to carry over or that, you
know, whether how do we know whether
we've plateaued? You know, you've talked
about other efforts to have further
gains. And so I guess you know if you
could speak a little bit more to do you
think the efforts that we've done still
have room to bear more fruit um or you
know have we plateaued or you know how
we're looking between that if that makes
sense with the efforts that we've had
new efforts that we're going to have you
know what is the further grow growth
that we're anticipating or that we're
targeting.
>> I think what we're focusing on with our
principles and campus leaders is just
drilling down to the student specific
level data which is what Dr. Maxwell and
Miss Bker talked about. So those
individual campus level conversations
where Miss Baker's team meets with our
principal like their admin team, the
special education chair is included as
well as the counselor and um advanced
academics and a lot of other um
departments and teams come together to
drill down to student level specific
data. So this is great overall, but you
know success is never final and that's
something we tell our principles all of
the time. And so just looking at the
different student groups for that
particular campus and individual
students to see where that growth is
needed. Also CCMR is um an incred
incredibly large umbrella. So IBC is
just one portion of it. Um and although
we do want to see gains either sustain
the momentum or increase that, we do
know there are other areas of
opportunity under that umbrella which
you'll hear about in other board
monitoring reports. So Miss Baker and
her team, we met at Akens Early College
High School yesterday for a high school
principal level meeting. we were able to
um have the inter principal Miss Deon
share out about all of the incredible
things going on with themies and the way
that they are monitoring the work but
then we also drill down to TSI and we
talked about academic readiness and
identifying students to make sure that
they are college ready when it comes to
math and reading with data. So there are
other areas and points where we want to
ensure success and growth across the
board but we are proud to stop and
celebrate for a millisecond um the work
that's happened here.
I also want to add this school can only
grow to so much, right? So, not all
students are CTE students. We have
students who are in athletics and don't
have room for CTE in their schedule. We
have students who are in fine arts and
don't have room. So, we can only grow to
a certain point. So I think that to to
answer your question, we need to see we
need to maybe match our enrollment total
in CTE with the way that they're
persisting through as well because
>> okay,
>> if we only have 75% of our students
enrolled in CTE courses, we could not
possibly grow beyond that.
>> Okay. And then maybe I appreciate that.
Thank you. That that does answer the
question. And and then just to um drill
down I guess on the drill down point um
am I correct in understanding then I
guess the way I'm interpreting that is
some of the work that we've done is
putting the systems in place that allow
for that granular detail to to be going
to the students. So so that's kind of
the next step is being able to use those
systems to that degree. So yes. Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional questions.
>> My questions have been asked and
answered. Thank you. Thank you. I have
just two. Um one is in the high schools
you highlighted um as the the outliers
and the highlights. Um the it's it was
really notable that the students the
percentages for students with economic
disadvantage and students without were
very close to each other. Um do you have
an understanding much closer than we
usually see. Do you have an
understanding of why those gaps are so
small in this area?
I don't to be honest with you. I think
that um what I love so much about CTE is
that it's for all students. Um I think
so often that we separate college and
career and in fact CTE is both. Um I use
health science as an example. You cannot
graduate high school and be a doctor. Um
thankfully you have to go to a lot of
college before you get to do that. And
so I think that's the beautiful thing
about CTE is it's for all students of
all backgrounds, demographics, um,
whatever their economically
disadvantaged or advantaged uh,
situation is. And so I think that that's
probably a big part of that.
>> Yeah. There's also a shared
understanding and awareness on these
campuses. So when you walk onto the
campus for Akens, Buoie, Crockett, LBJ,
um, those programs pop out.
Superintendent Sagura and team, we
visited Crockett Early College High
School. I think it was the second day of
school and we were able to visit with
students and there were some students
that were in the cosmetology class we
visited that were from Mak's early
college high school. So they were
they're actually utilizing the student
share program in order to come for first
period on a day to this course for
cosmetology. We talked to the student
that was manicuring superintendent good
as nails and she mentioned this is her
third year in the program and she really
loves her teacher. We know that kids
pick people, not necessarily courses.
And so, she's made that commitment to
stay in this program and persist to
completion just because of that
relationship with her teacher, with the
other students that are present and just
the strong awareness. I asked her, "How
did you get here?" My friend, you know,
is a student at Crockett and told me
about how wonderful this instructor was
in the program. So, just the strong
awareness and the culture that's built
around the CTE courses really helps to
make it sustainable on campuses.
>> Good. Thank you. I love that. Um, I have
one more question and then um, Trusty
Kaufman, do you want to do you have a
question or have yours been answered?
>> No, I was watching from the back and I
mine has been asked and answered.
>> Okay, thank you. So, I just have one
additional question which is um, do we
have any understanding of how or whether
our students use these certifications
after they graduate or is that something
we don't track?
>> Good question.
>> A really good question. Um, no. I, you
know, I read an article today about how
some of them are than others and as I
think TEA is being responsive to that
very thing. They review the list of
industry based certifications regularly
and really make sure that those are
answering labor market needs not only
within the state but specific
communities as well.
What we see coming down in the next
accountability handbook is probably that
they're going to tier those IBC's by
level. And so something like a
cosmetology license, which is a license
with the state, would be over something
for an example of Microsoft Office,
right? So you could be hired at a
liveable wage with the cosmetology
license. However, with a Microsoft
Office
>> certification, you could be really great
at APA whenever you go into college. So,
um, it just everyone depends. But they
are stackable credentials and we know
that they're good for kids regardless of
the level that that it is. And so we're
going to keep working and and getting
those students those credentials.
>> And I think part of that is making sure
that we as a system are always looking
at what those high wage high demand
areas are so that we are making sure we
got good enrollment in those that we're
promoting those programs that we have
what those programs need which does
increase the likelihood that they will
be using that they'll find employment um
in those industries and that they'll go
on to be successful with them. One more
thing, uh, that's really where the work
with our industry partners comes into
play. So, we've got industry partners
partners throughout the city, throughout
the area that play a big part in looking
at those industry needs, looking at the
market needs, and knowing, you know,
this certification is great, but really
in the industry, they're looking at this
one. Okay. Well, if that's one of the
IBCs, let's shift that way. And so,
working with the community is is a big
part of what we do.
>> Thank you all for this. Uh, any further
questions?
All right, thank you all so much. Really
appreciate it. Um,
and thank you to all my colleagues for
this productive conversation. Again, we
vote to accept uh on whether we will
accept this monitoring report. And
again, as a point of clarity, we're
voting to accept it as a former a formal
acknowledgement that we had a
satisfactory conversation with the
superintendent and have a deeper
understanding about how the current
reality for students lines up with our
vision. And at this point, I will
entertain a motion to accept this
monitoring report.
>> I move to accept the report.
>> Thank you. Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Uh, thank you. Any discussion?
Having a motion by Secretary Gonzalez
and a second by Trustee Kintana to
accept the monitoring report. All those
in favor, please raise your right hand.
And the motion passes by all those on
the dis. Thank you so much. Um, next up
is uh our information reports and
updates and Mr. Sora, will you please
introduce the next item?
>> Yes, President um Boswell. I have
joining me um Joshua Jun, executive
director of governance, accountability,
and board services and Dr. Cherry Lee,
interimm assistant superintendent of
special education programs to share the
TA special education agreed order
update.
All right. Good evening, President
Boswell, Superintendent Sukra, uh board
of trustees. As part of the TEA agreed
order, we committed to provide uh
regular updates to the board um and to
the community.
And this update includes um an update on
the required actions under the order. Uh
the order outlined 99 deliverables in
the following categories. uh Lonear
governance. Uh priority one, satisfy
open corrective action plans. Priority
two, identify and implement effective
practices. Priority three, improve data
systems. And priority four, establish,
um a parent outreach campaign.
Currently, um out of the 99 deliverables
under the order, uh we have completed 96
of them. Under uh Lonear Governance, we
do have one uh remaining. That's the uh
LSG quarterly uh board self-evaluation
in October. Uh we also have one that is
ongoing uh which is to read into the
record at the first board meeting each
month the percentage of time invested uh
in student outcomes during the prior
three months and the total time spent in
close session during the prior month.
Um, under party three, improved data
systems, we also have one ongoing
deliverable and that is to submit
reports monthly to the agency and a
summary uh report to the board that
meets the requirement outlined in this
section.
Uh, pursuant to the agreed order, the
board engaged in quarterly
self-evaluations using the LSG
implementation integrity instrument. Um
and the board had to achieve a meets
focus score within two uh years of the
board completing the LSG workshop. And
after reaching that meets focus, the
board was to work with the LSG coach to
maintain a meets focus score that's 60
or better uh on the LSG implementation
integrity instrument for three
consecutive quarters. And as you can see
on the table here, the board has reached
meets focus for five consecutive
quarters as of August 2025.
Okay, good evening. As part of our
ongoing commitment to meeting the
requirements of the TEA agreed order, we
remain focused on priority one, which is
ensuring compliance with federal and
state timelines for evaluations,
re-evaluations, and initial and annual
AR meetings. And we recognize this work
requires sustained collaboration across
all levels within our school district.
our case managers at the campus level,
our speech therapists or related service
providers, our diagnosticians, our
school psychologists, our campus
principles, and our executive directors
who supervise principles as well as our
district level special education staff.
So, as presented in August, the district
has adopted the frontline special
programs management system, which
includes a dashboards and reporting
feature to help staff monitor compliance
with the required timelines. We continue
to partner with our vendor to make
system improvements based on feedback
from staff who are actively using the
platform.
We want to acknowledge the tremendous
lift that Austin ISD staff members have
engaged in as they learn and adopt and
adapt to this new program. Systems
change is not easy. Transitioning to a
digital platform requires time, effort,
and persistence. And ongoing training is
critical to building confidence in all
of the new workflows. And we want to
extend gratitude to all staff for the
additional efforts needed to transition
systems. It's been a heavy lift and
despite past challenges, we've made
progress in holding and documenting
annual AR meetings on time and we're
closely tracking all reevaluations to
ensure they're prioritized. The district
remains committed to responding to
current TEA complaints and will continue
to prioritize compliance with annual ART
and re-evaluation requirements as
outlined by Superintendent Sigura at our
leadership institute for all principles
in July and in ongoing communication
with campus leaders. As we review our
progress tonight with the agreed order,
we acknowledge our focus must move
beyond compliance. The art committee has
a critical responsibility to develop
IEPs that are individualized and aligned
with each students unique strengths and
needs. This includes updating families
on their child's progress and
reconvening the art committee when
updates are necessary and annually is
required. Our shared goal is not just
compliance, but meaningful outcomes for
students. Our focus remains on fostering
engagement at our committees where
families feel heard and are included in
the development of their child's IEP.
Priority two requires Austin ISD to
identify and implement effective
instructional practices included
targeted professional learning for
staff. A central component within this
priority required extensive training for
all campus leaders and instructional
staff on the MTSS process. high quality
instructional materials,
speciallydesigned instruction, the
special education legal framework, and a
continuum of services for students with
disabilities. It also requires the
district to ensure ongoing professional
learning development opportunities.
Austin ISD's completed all 47 action
items identified within the pri priority
to ensure our district builds upon the
foundational training
components within the order. Our Austin
ISD teaching, learning, and leading
teams are working to ensure
instructional delivery and
implementation of highquality services
for all students across the district
through the provision of strong tier one
curriculum and instruction. Our TLLL
team conducts routine instructional
walks across campuses to support
alignment, providing real time feedback
to campus leaders, which you heard
earlier as well.
I'd like to also share a few specific
updates on our special education team's
comprehensive calendar of PL
opportunities which builds upon the
foundational training district staff
completed as required by the order over
the past two years. Our new monthly
learning lab series offers realtime
training for special education case
managers. Attendance at our monthly
learning labs is a new requirement for
all special education teachers across
the district. Tuesday, we held our first
learning lab where almost 700 special
education teachers attended one of three
virtual sessions. Sessions are recorded
for those staff members who are unable
to attend. Additional professional
learning sessions include sessions on
frontline special programs management as
described earlier, high-quality IEP
development, autism supports, behavior
intervention, and transition planning
for students with disabilities along
with focus sessions on functional
behavior assessments, crisis
deescalation, and dyslexia intervention.
We also offer monthly cohort meetings
for teachers providing early childhood
special education and life skill
services. Our campus support
coordinators will now be leading a
monthly PLC on each campus to provide
additional focused training specific to
the needs of that campus.
This layered ongoing PD approach
reflects our commitment to building
staff capacity and sustaining
improvements aligned with the TEA agreed
order.
>> All right. Under priority three, Austin
ISD committed to improving our data uh
and reporting systems and to submit
monthly reports to TEA and the board
outlined in this section. Um in the fall
of 2024, um as you may recall, we
discovered uh the special education data
management system that we had could not
sufficiently produce the accurate and
timely reports that we needed to support
students and to ensure compliance. Um
and we we uh tried many avenues uh but
we reached an impass uh in the fall with
the system we had. And so in September
uh we had to make an extremely difficult
decision to transition to a new data
management system. Um and after holding
multiple listening sessions and
reviewing uh survey data, we put out a
request for quotes um in October 2024 um
and procured a new software frontline uh
special uh programs management system uh
by the end of the year. This was a huge
undertaking. We went from project
kickoff mid January uh to go live in
July. Um that aggressive timeline was a
challenge like Dr. ly mentioned uh but
the dedication um and tireless work of
our team made it happen
and as we have presented previously we
made uh training a top priority um
because uh it's the key to success. Our
comprehensive training program was
thoughtfully designed and delivered in
multiple settings this summer and
continue to be a focus um as we started
the new school year. Uh we are thankful
to the agency for the time granted us
until September 1st to transition to
this new data management system. We're
thankful for the opportunity u over the
summer to collaborate with the monitors
and Dr. O'Neal ahead of that September
1st submission. Uh last week u on
September 12th, we submitted updated
reports as requested and are waiting
feedback. Um our next steps include
providing ongoing technical assistance
to campus staff um as well as conducting
follow-up training. We will continue to
moni uh monitor compliance at the
district and campus level. And finally,
we will continue to submit monthly
reports to TEA and the board uh that
meet the requirements of the order.
>> So, moving on to priority four, we have
met the 15 actions under priority 4. And
one of those actions required our
district to establish a parent advisory
group to gather and incorporate family
feedback on the district's special
education services. Our first special
education family advisory committee
meeting was held in January of 2024. And
in the upcoming 2526 school year, CEPAC
will convene six times to accomplish key
objectives as outlined on the slide that
include aligning the committee's work
with the district's strategic plan for
special education, developing new
strategies for parent outreach,
enhancing resources and training for
families, and providing guidance on
inclusive practices.
Based on recent input from committee
members, we have added a parent and a
teacher co-chair for the 2526 school
year. Volunteers serving in these
positions will not only develop the
meeting agendas, but will define the
scope of focus for key discussions,
further empowering parent and community
voices on the committee. Our first
meeting of the school year is on
Tuesday, September the 30th at HQ from
6:00 to 7:30. And at the beginning of
each meeting, time will be provided for
both member and community feedback and
comments. More information on signing up
to provide the public comment can be
accessed through the Austin ISD CFAC
website. And we currently have one
opening for a parent member. And we do
encourage Austin ISD parents interested
in participating to apply through the
standard application form for service on
our district advisory bodies on the
Austin ISD website.
While Austin ISD has completed all of
the requirements identified within
priority 4, our Childfind efforts
continue. Childfind is a federal
requirement that makes sure that public
schools, including Austin ISD, identify
and evaluate children who may have
disabilities and need specially designed
instruction. When families of students
attending Austin ISD have concerns about
their child's learning, speech, or
behavior, they can request an evaluation
by contacting their child's campus
principal or teacher.
Families of students who are
homeschooled or attending private
schools in the Austin ISD attendance
boundary can also request an evaluation
for their child by visiting our
childfind page on our external website
as shown here on the slide and
completing a digital form. Our district
childfind contact is Miss Amanda Reyes
who is our director of evaluations and
she can also answer additional questions
regarding the special education
evaluation process. Now, early
intervention services are available for
children from birth to age three who
qualify.
And our Austin ISD um ECI specialist is
Miss Michelle McGee. And she meets
regularly with our local ECI agencies
that include Easter Seals and Any Baby
Can to support families with the
transition process from ECI services to
school-based special education services.
If families have more information on
ECI, they should contact the Department
of Health and Human Services and that
information is also linked on our
ChildFind page.
Our first Childfind session was held on
September 3rd here. It was virtual and
it provided families a chance to really
learn and ask questions about the
referral and evaluation process and we
had over 30 families in attendance. In
short, our child find efforts are
required as required by priority uh four
have been met, but outre outreach
efforts continue.
So, the last component within priority 4
required Austin ISD to establish
effective parent engagement and I'll
highlight a few of the following updates
regarding family engagement efforts that
are also featured on the slide. We've
increased our reach to families through
social media, the district newsletter,
and the family connections newsletter.
The first newsletter reached 15,000
families. The next quarter quarterly
newsletter will be sent out in
midocctober.
Our family empower hour learning
sessions are offered every Wednesday at
noon and 6 p.m. through Zoom. And our
sessions are designed with time for
parents to explore materials and
resources and ask questions to members
of our special education team.
October events include sessions on the
dyslexia handbook and strategies to
support students with dyslexia in honor
of dyslexia awareness month. We're also
going to include a session on a parents
guide to our map growth platform,
accessibility supports for Chromebooks,
which will be led by our assisted
technology team and a student employment
panel.
Our team also has a family learning
opportunities page on our external
website which provides information on
upcoming family events and archived
newsletters. And we post events through
Austin ISD social media as well. I'd
also like to share that Brie Roth, who
is a longtime Austin ISD staff member,
is now serving as our team's family
learning and engagement specialist. She
has more than 20 years of experience as
a teacher and an advocate and she's
partnering with our families, our parent
support specialists, our schools and
community organizations and families and
staff are encouraged to reach out to Bri
to facilitate parent training on their
campus and find additional support and
resources. So, as we close tonight's
presentation, we would like to invite
our community to our second annual
in-person transition fair on September
27th at Buouie High School from 10 to
12. We do thank Buoie High School for
hosting this event for the second year
in a row. Last year we had over a 100
families that attended and this is an
opportunity for families and students to
explore post-secondary options and
really make valuable community and
agency connections. We're going to have
over 50 agencies and vendors who are
going to be participating offering
information on vocational training,
higher education options, employment and
independent living opportunities. Austin
Community College will be there as well.
Registration is encouraged, but it's not
required and it is open to all.
So, this does conclude our presentation
tonight and we thank you.
>> Thank you very much. Uh, trustees, any
questions about this report? Trusty
confident.
>> Um, thank you for the continued work to
fulfill all the expectations of the
agree order. Uh, I just wanted to check
um I know that there was there were a
lot of things that had been due May 31st
and additional ones due August 1st and
um you I think those were included in
the chart but we didn't really hear
about those items that were submitted.
Um, if people are interested in the
actual artifacts and the documents that
were submitted, are those available for
for the public or for the board, things
like the continuum of services map or
the um protocols and processes for
allocating resources, like are those
submissions available so people can see
what was what AIC is doing?
>> Yes, we can make those available. We
have not linked all of those resources
to our external website, but those
resources would be available for for you
know for review including you know
training documents that we have provided
and all of those have been reviewed by
the monitors and we provided those to
the state as well.
>> Okay, awesome. Thank I'll submit a
tracker request then to get the ones I'm
interested in. Thank you.
>> Absolutely.
>> Thank you. Any additional questions?
All right. Um, thank you so much for
this report, for the work. Uh, you know,
I know it's been a whole lot of people
and a whole lot of, uh, heavy lifts.
>> So, it's really, um, exciting to see so
many things delivered and taken care of,
um, and improved for our students. So,
thank you so much. Really appreciate it.
Uh, any further comments,
superintendent?
Um I think just uh kind of reinforcing
that you know uh this order does not end
you know whenever we complete the work.
>> Yeah.
>> You know we we've continued to say this
and and we are committed to it. Um you
know what's required by the state what's
required by federal law compliance
that's like the foundation. That's like
the minimum. I mean we are striving to
be much more than that. Uh so you know
our strategic plan uh is really kind of
the the heart of the work once we get
hopefully past the TA greed order. Um
there's no timelines yet set for when
that'll be, but um we're hopeful that as
we get to the end of it, we just
continue to reinforce that this is not
stop. It continues on. Um but certainly
want to thank the team for all the hard
work. Uh it was a gargantuan lift. Um
and just really proud of us being able
to get to this point. not through it
yet, but very proud of the work this
far.
>> Yeah, moving in the right direction. So,
thank you very much. Really appreciate
the update and the work. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Uh, okay. So, this sends uh ends our
section on the information reports from
the administration. At this time, we
will now move into the preview of agenda
items that will be considered for a vote
at the next regular board meeting next
week on September 25th. Austin ISD staff
is available to answer any questions for
tonight's preview. And we will begin
tonight with item seven, which is the
agenda preview for upcoming academics
and curriculum items. Any questions on
these items?
All right. Next is section Oh, yes.
Sorry. Yes. Trusty Hunter. Um 7.1 Cap
City Fund for Education.
Excuse me. I was running. I um I want to
say that I did notice that last time we
had a presentation, it was very sort of
in the same structure, but it did not
have as much rich information on it. And
I noticed that this time they did
include uh who they're serving. I I I
liked it. I appreciated it. I would uh
also just love a breakdown of that 96%
which groups but uh this is a much more
in-depth report than we received last
time and it helps to uh make those good
decisions based on the service that
they're providing. Thank you.
>> So um Trusty Hunter we can would a board
update be sufficient and to provide that
okay we'll work with the vendor
All right, thank you. Additional
questions about section seven.
All right, next up is section 8, board
administration.
And um these are a lot of uh kind of um
kind of tweaks and cleanups and
adjustments and um punch list and you
know kind of tying up loose ends. a lot
of work um that we've done with our
coach to bring us into kind of polishing
of a lot of the work we've done um
through our Lone Star governance work to
really kind of um to to address a lot of
issues um that have been raised. So,
it's a long list um and another two-way
communication meeting um plan. So,
Ashley Paw is going to be here with us.
our coach, I think, is joining um
virtually to to be here with us for any
questions that we have. And um I think u
my understanding when Ashley's here is I
believe this all counts now under the
new Lonear governance guidelines as um
high impact adult focus time I believe
is what the new term is. And uh hi
Ashley, did I get that right? focus,
>> high leverage, adult focus time. Uh, and
we have quite a few things that are
coming up. So, um, I'll just kind of go
through one by one so we can ask any
questions. Um, 8.1 is the Lonear
Government's two-way communication
meeting plan and schedule. And the
document you have there is a draft. Um,
this is a two-way communication plan
really focused on uh our schools with
two Fs going and talking about we worked
Andrew and I had a conversation with
Ashley on Monday and we've talked with
her in the past about about engagement
in our community that talks about not
just district level goals but local
campus performance and the idea of doing
that. We're hearing from families um at
some of our target uh turnaround plan
meetings of you know what can I do to
help? And so really taking that local
data that is closest to our families of
what the data look like not just at the
district level but the campus level and
then partnering with campus
administration to follow that
presentation with a conversation led by
administrators and by staff about how
families can best support their students
success. So, we're going to be working
um the the script that there that is
there is just a draft. We're going to be
working before the next meeting to get a
a new script in that Ashley has um had a
lot of thoughts and we had a good
conversation about how to make it feel
really useful, relevant, um actionable
to our families. So, you'll have a new
draft there. Do we have any questions
for Ashley about that?
Okay. Um, next is appointment to the
board of directors of of the Austin ISD
PFC. Um, that's our public facility
corporation. That's not an Ashley item.
Does anyone have questions about that?
The PFC board has recommended adding two
new members to that
um to our public facility corporation.
All right. Um 8.3 is an Ashley item. Uh
that's approval of update to the
district scorecard and targets. And
before we talk about those adjustments
themselves,
um, we need to talk about what we
consider ontrack performance. And I
think we got a good preview,
um, when we talked about our first
scorecard item where Superintendent
Sigura had the section where really it's
it's not only stating whether we are on
track or not, but really what that back
backing it up and explaining to us how
that decision was made. Um, and Ashley,
I know, um, you wanted us to have a
shared agreement of what cons what we
consider ontrack, offtrack. Can you, uh,
take a minute and explain to us what the
expectation is with that?
>> Uh, yeah. And so, um, so thank you. And
um so when uh the board is um monitoring
its goals uh what you are trying to
understand through your monitoring
conversation is where you are today. Um
so where uh students are today. So what
is the current reality for students
relative to the goal? And so when the
board uh the board monitors the goals,
you do so by looking at goal progress
measures. Um and the the um I think Dr.
Foster has has said this very eloquently
in the past. He talks about how the um
the GPMS and the goals um all work
together to create kind of an ecosystem
of how you are um creating that systemic
change. And so um the when the board
thinks about on track um you're not just
thinking about whether or not the goal
progress measure is on track. What you
are actually wanting to understand is
whether or not the goal is on track. Um
the goal progress measures are good
information um to know uh what kind of
progress you're making. But the the main
thing is the goal because that is the
student outcome that you're trying to
accomplish. Um and that's what has been
identified in collaboration with the
community. All that work that you you
did um last year to to really drill down
uh what the community's vision is and
then you codified it through your um
student outcome goals. So that's um
that's kind of the perspective um that
the board should be looking at as you
are uh doing your monitoring. But you
also need to um it's not as
Uh we also need to be clear that um it's
not just um you know board members or um
you know someone in the community or
really anyone who is reading the
monitoring report. Um it shouldn't be up
to them or they shouldn't have to um
have to read through the entire report
to try to understand whether or not um
the current vision or the current
reality matches the vision. um the
superintendent is the one who uh really
is um expected to provide that
interpretation and I provided um I
provided some additional documentation
this morning to the board. Um it's a
document called the policy governance
consistency framework and it talks about
um any reasonable interpretation. And so
where the board sets the goals, the
superintendent uh sets the goal progress
measures and those are the
superintendent's interpretation of the
goals. Um
where where you are relative to the
goals through the goal progress
measures. It's the superintendent's
responsibility to really um explain to
the board what that is and provide that
evidence of why that is the
interpretation.
>> I know that was kind of a long-winded
answer, but it it is a little a little
bit more um complex than um you know
just kind of a surface level
understanding.
>> Thank you for that. Any questions about
that?
Okay, thank you. Um, okay. Do we have
any questions about the updated
scorecard? We have the updated
scorecard, the current scorecard. We
have a side by side that details all the
changes and then we have a revised
updated scorecard and a revised side by
side. So, a lot of documentation here
that explains the changes that were
made. Um,
a lot of these came from the
administration filling in um, you know,
some TBD, some metrics that didn't exist
yet.
um some things. We made some changes to
language to to align um with some
requirements and and some other tweaks
to it to um really just kind of polish
it and and we've been test driving it
for a year and to get it uh right uh
with Ashley's guidance uh to both the
administration and uh us as trustees. Do
we have any questions about this?
Any discussion?
Yes, trusty coffin. I didn't see in here
the explanation of the revised targets
and current data for the um GPM on
students on track 5.2 I think for
students on track for um achieving the
dual language seal of by literacy.
What can you just help me understand the
the basis of those goals? Like what I
mean in particular, what is the
denominator on those? Like when we're
looking at numbers that say that we have
the our baseline is that 50.8% of 9th to
12th graders are on track in program
coursework to earn an Austin seal of bi
literacy. What is the denominator there?
is what are we what what does that
number mean?
>> Um I believe it's the students that have
started that. So not all Austin IC
students uh but students who started on
that track.
>> Okay. And and that the goal five the
denominator there is all graduates.
Right.
Uh that is correct.
>> Okay. And so those numbers will fit
together in terms of monitoring the
progress towards the goal.
>> Well,
fit together. I think we would um see a
correlation. If the go if the goal
progress measure is progressing then we
would see a correlation that the goal
would progress. Um and so uh yes. Okay.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any additional questions
about the scorecard?
>> Uh anything you want us to know?
Um I I think uh for our trustees, you
know, this scorecard um you know, since
I've been in Austin ISD for I guess
seven, eight years now has evolved. I
remember at one point there was like 70
metrics and then 16. I've seen it kind
of fluctuate over the years. Uh and I
very much appreciate the scorecard the
trustees approved in the summer of 2024.
Uh I think it's a it was a lot of great
work went to went into it and as we've
used um the scorecard for one year
there's refinements as you just said uh
whether it's how we collect the data or
changes in staffing right that has
impacted our ability maybe collect
information that we previously were able
to collect easily and so the one thing I
maybe want to communicate to trustees is
that uh you know there are lots of
things outside this report that we track
that we pro we um spend time and energy
on. Uh these reports um do become
uh sometimes um kind of uh resource
consuming to produce.
You know, when when we think about when
we actually pull the data, I want our
trustees to understand, we pull the data
at the time that it's available. if it's
tied to a certain milestone, you know,
if it's an assessment or some point in
the year, we pull it, uh, you know, we
assess it. We then, um, the team begins
to to write and develop the the
analysis. We then pull it into a
presentation, then review the
presentation. We then refine it. We have
to really understand because I think our
board as as expected would want us to
understand, do we really kind of
recognize what the root cause is? have
have we really addressed all the
different things that could come out of
this data. Uh and and that work is done
by very few people. Uh this is not
something that is is is outsourced. It
really has to be those who are leading
the work to be able to connect to
connect all the dots. So I would just
want our trustees to know that every
time we present something uh it may come
across as you know maybe not a a
significant lift but I can tell you that
it is a very significant lift um
work-wise and the the challenge we have
is sometimes you know we can say that
well maybe don't spend as much time on
it but the reality of it all is anything
that goes public facing has to be a high
quality deliverable like it's a large
organization the expectations are high
the responsibility is I we have to check
everything and it has to be a high
quality deliverable and it has to be
accurate. And so if there was an
opportunity for refinement in any way to
to reduce the number of reports um that
would be something the administration
would love for the trustees to consider.
the work is getting done and we're happy
to report out on it in different ways
whether it's board update or posting
online but the actual effort associated
with report producing these is quite um
time consuming and and given what we're
tackling with accountability with all
the work and tea's agreed order with
special education the work that we're
doing with consolidations I just it's
it's a lot of the same people and and we
have fewer people so I just wanted to to
say that um but it is kind of the way
that it is because of you know we didn't
also want to make changes or recommend
changes and and maybe communicate that
these weren't important to us. They are
all very important but I at least wanted
that to be said for the record.
>> So that's it.
>> Thank you. Any comments? Uh vice
president.
>> Yes. Um,
Miss Paws, can I ask you um what
is the minimum and maximum number of
constraints that must be on the
scorecard or can be?
>> Uh, yeah, that's actually a really great
question. Um, the board needs to adopt
at least one constraint. So, a minimum
of one and no more than five.
And um a key a key thing to understand
is that for every and this is for your
goals as well. Uh for goals you need to
have three to five but for every
additional um goal that you adopt for
every additional constraint that you
adopt there is um there is a pool for
resources. And so you're attent
essentially taking um you know you're
the number of resources that you have
and you are spreading them out across um
right now across 10. Um if you were to
um reduce the number of constraints then
that would free up um free up additional
resources for to be spread out across
others. But that really is an important
thing for the board to discuss. um you
know as long as you are with um as long
as you are within that um with within
those boundaries then um I really don't
have a whole lot of um of opinions you
this is how you represent the
community's uh values and so um the
constraints are important but um how you
uh focus and prioritize that's really um
up to the board for how to do that.
>> Okay. Thank you so much. That's that's
helpful. Um so with that I um you know I
really appreciate you talking about you
know the resources of many kinds at
these um I would say like like the
monitoring um because a lot of this is
like teacher walkthroughs, teacher
monitoring, classroom monitoring or
maybe extra assessment or time for our
students as well as you know financial
costs. Um, so I would say I am
supportive of having the minimum number
of constraints on here. Um,
and I would say there even can be like
unintended consequences when um,
something is measured in a certain way.
Um,
that might not
that could take resources from what
we're actually trying to do. Um, because
like you said, everything does take
resources and time and people. Um, so if
we're kind of finding the perfect way to
measure if people are being engaged, if
families are being engaged with limited
resources, like my concern and
something, you know, I felt like I saw
as a a teacher is that took away from
like actual time to engage people. Um,
so I'm supportive of of the minimum
number of constraints.
And do you have a suggestion about which
one we would keep? Um,
>> or do you want to discuss?
>> I think my my colleagues probably have
really good ideas about that.
>> Trusty Deast,
>> I I just wanted to make one note on the
on the old constraint 5.3,
the sped restorative practices.
Um I'm seeing that it's saying that it's
moved to CPM 1.3
and on the updated one I just see a
reference to economically dis
disadvantaged students but I don't see
the sped reference in there
and so I wanted to just double check if
that was an oversight or if that's
supposed to be included in that one.
>> It will continue to be disagregated and
presented with that constraint progress
measure.
>> Okay. I just want to make sure as we
kind of streamline some of these that we
don't move that we don't lose some of
the sped specific ones.
>> Yeah.
>> Just because I do think there's there's
value in having that be discreet.
>> Yeah. So, one of the things that we did
was um I think in alignment with just
how who we are like we segregate all
data and the way some of the constraints
were written, we were having the actual
student group be at the constraint
level,
>> right? And so in an effort to create
some tightening and also in an effort to
add a fifth constraint which is the one
that tracks um schools that have a
series of unacceptable ratings. We
collap we didn't collapse we rolled it
into the constraint above it or to
constraint one. So now when you go
through all the data will be there in
the same way. It's just now a a CPM
versus an a constraint. I mean sorry the
natural constraint a CPM 1.3 versus just
constraint four or constraint five.
So there there was kind of a lot of
little tweaking to try to create space
for the added of the the adding of the
fifth.
>> I just just calling out make sure that
we're not moving losing some of those
populations. I did appreciate how in on
the old scorecard um you know the old
constraint three for historically
marginalized groups it just described it
as specific student populations so that
it was a little open-ended um but still
had us focus on specific student
populations as opposed to just one or
the other.
I just every every time I look at these,
I go back to IEP goals and writing a
goal that gives you enough, you know,
wiggle room to to be able to apply it
all the places. Um, so when we use this
specific language, I just want to make
sure we're choosing the right one.
>> Yeah. No, I appreciate that. And so
we're welcome any input or ideas you
have, Josh and I will certainly work
through. The only thing that we are
managing um trustees is the board
calendar. So there's a requirement for
how many times we report out on the
goals and the constraints. And so we
have to kind of line it all up. And
what's the number of requirement
required reports on each constraint?
>> Uh once is a minimum.
>> Once is a minimum.
>> Each CPM is is once and then on a goal
it's
>> four.
>> Four. And so if you have the same goal
progress measure, then you're putting
that same goal progress measure multiple
times unless you have more goal progress
measures. And so when you think about
the data that we're collecting and when
we collect it, I think it can create a
sometimes a a frustrating experience for
trustees because we either don't have
the data yet and we're sharing something
or we've had it for a while, but because
of the number of requirements that we
have to meet, it ends up kind of
creating this funky schedule. So
anything that we do, we always have to
align in that way and not get too far
ahead or behind from when the data is
actually available. So just that's
another kind of level of
uh creativity that has to be applied to
get this all to align.
>> Yeah. And I I really appreciate that.
I'm definitely um you know defer to you
on on how you want to unpack those. I'm
just again just reiterating I I see
those disagated.
>> Yeah.
So okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional comments.
>> Yeah, maybe a question. Um, do we like
want to look at do we still feel like we
should have five goals? Should we have
four? Should we have three? Does that
happen? Thoughts about that
>> constraints? Um, so I guess going back
to goals since we have to have
>> we must have three to five.
>> I was
>> three, four or five goals.
>> We have to have three, but you can have
up to five
>> and we have
>> more less ability to focus on each one
and more resources. So, um,
>> yes.
>> So, I just wanted to to bring that
question forward. Um because yeah I'm
I'd be interested in talking about only
three but if want to see if anyone else
is interested in that.
>> And I think it's important as we talk
too that if we only have three the three
we have to have no matter what our third
grade literacy um which is measured by
the star reading assessment with the two
GPMs
um
or with um I'm sorry one GPM second
grade literacy. Now the third grade
numeracy measured by the third grade
star and we have um GPM about second
grade numeracy and then the third one we
have to have as a college career
military readiness indicator and that's
that has to be the goal. Um and we had
some some play in how we measured that
and that's part of what we talked about
tonight and we have um three different
GPMs under that. Uh, and so I think I I
think it's also an interesting question
to and I know you have the puzzle of
monitoring it enough times during the
year, but whether we also need all the
GPMs that we have, I think is a
reasonable question to ask as well. Um,
like we know you're going to work on the
TSI, do we really need to talk about
that?
>> Uh, you know, kind of having those
questions as well. And does that work
with the calendar?
I'm not opposed to having the three
because it's the same thing that we tell
our um families and teachers when we go
out to have these particular LSG
meetings and they're like whoa you only
have five and what we tell them is these
are the five that we have chosen to put
down to focus on to monitor we are
always working on things that are not
here always because that's what
districts do that's what teachers do
that's what um schools do so just having
the three I think really clearly just
talking to our community and saying just
like we told you before with the five
these three are the ones we're going to
monitor in this space the administration
is continually working on all the things
>> trusty coffin
>> I support trusty's idea of reducing the
number of constraints I think that the
way constraints work in this system
they're not very helpful um because you
convert like an important idea idea
>> into a very unimportant piece of data,
>> right? And so because the constraints
require us to have constraint progress
measures instead of just saying, "Hey,
when you're this plan that you have for
improving reading scores, does it
include practices that exclude,
disproportionately impact, or fail
underserved students?" No. Okay, good.
That's a good plan. rather than having
to turn that into a constraint, which
then narrows it down to a couple things
instead of the big picture. So, I would
rather just have some confidence that
the superintendent we've selected and
that the plans that they're presenting
are addressing those important values of
the district because I don't think that
these measures that were created for
them indicate whether those values are
being followed to the district for most
of them. And so, I think um I think
they're not very helpful to have these
constraints. And I would support
narrowing them because I do think the
lift from the administration of having
to create those reports and for us to
spend time at board meetings discussing
them is not a good use of the
administration's time. I'd rather have
them focused on the student achievement.
>> Additional comments or thoughts?
>> Is there a particular constraint given
what you just said, Trusty Kaufman, that
you feel would be the most useful to
retain? And before we do that, I want to
flag that one of the changes we made,
which we had discussed um as a board,
but I really want to highlight it
because it's a new one, is we changed
constraint five to one about
accountability. And um the language that
I worked on with Ashley and and that I
want to be sure everyone sees and um can
weigh in on whether we keep it or don't
keep it and whether if we keep it we
keep it as in this form is the
superintendent will not allow students
to be in a school with consecutive
unacceptable ratings count of three or
more based on the current rules of TEA's
A throughF accountability system. and
it's tracking the number of campuses
with an F rating under the state
academic accountability. It it says it
will decrease from 29 to zero in 2029.
And it goes back and looks at the past
data. 2019 there were eight. 2023 under
the new A3 system there were 30. At 2024
29 this year 2023
um and then a trajectory to get us to
zero. Um
>> and what was the rationale behind
creating that as a constraint when it's
already the fundamental nature of the
accountability system?
>> Um the rationale was to make sure that
we had opportunities to discuss it under
our agreed order which um restricts what
we can talk about and and so it's not
time that costs us that puts um that we
have to find a way to not talk about
other things. um that really so we can
talk about it within our our 50% of a
loted time in a way that gives it the
space it needs um without putting our
ourselves at at risk of not talking
about other things.
>> Yes, in that case I would support
keeping constraint five
and
and potentially deleting the other form.
>> Do we have thoughts?
Can can I just clarify? I want to make
sure
I understood this part. Um that part of
the advantage of reducing those progress
monitoring reports is that we would get
more frequent progress monitoring on the
goals and the other pieces. No,
>> there would be less time invested by the
administration
in creating reports that come to the
board rather than getting sleep and
doing their work.
>> Okay.
I would like to express agreement with
retaining constraint number five. I've
been to four turnaround plan meetings in
the past two days and that has been
a very loud and frequent question is why
wasn't this discussed immediately after
the system allowed a campus to receive
its first F rating. So personally that's
how I feel.
Okay. Other thoughts
interest in other constraints is the
thought that we go down to one.
Um
I I would suggest that constraint one
would be one that I would keep.
Trusty Coffman.
>> So my challenge with constraint one is
that again it covers a very important
principle about not excluding or
disproportionately impacting or failing
our underserved student groups. But then
it turns into a backdoor
to additional goals, three additional
goals because now we're saying and we
also want to improve attendance. We also
want to ensure evaluations of students
and we want to improve our discipline to
be less, you know, disproportionate.
None of which helps us when we're
looking at a reading plan to see does
this plan actually equitably address all
of our campuses and particularly those
campuses who deserve the more support
out of you know neglect in the past. So
I just I agree. Um and then I look at
where are the other checks and balances
for this. Well, chronic absenteeism
affects all the other al academic goals.
So that really I would expect our
administration would target absenteeism
as part of the improvement plans for all
the other goals. So there's already an
incentive and there's already a a desire
I think to address those um with the
special education evaluations. That's
again a fundamental component of
ensuring that our students are getting
the services they need is that and it's
part of our agree upon order our agree
order. So that's also being addressed
through another system. So while I think
all three of those pieces under there
are extremely important.
I I also see that those are creating
literally three more goals that we're
putting in addition to the five because
now we're saying these are the eight
things that are most important. And I
think in the spirit of reducing the
number of not the not reducing the
number of things that AIST is working
hard to improve but in reducing the
number of things that the board is
investing our time and demanding time
from the administration to do additional
work. Um I think I'm comfortable with
those being removed for that reason. I
support the idea that those are
important. I I don't think that the
process of
constraints is the way to to make them
important.
>> Yeah. I I think just to rear in mind
very specifically with the special
education community I know that you know
the families that I've engaged with you
know the concerns around discipline and
pulling students out of the learning
environment and the you know long
history with the sped backlog that you
know for me these are two constraints
that that data is reinforcing to the
families that have been asking so much
to you know know that things are getting
better in sped and they're looking for
specific data on it. And it's so hard to
give specific data points to those
people. Um, and even with these
constraints in place, you know, these
are still both concerns. Like I still
have families asking me about their
evalu
concerns. Um, so, you know, I I I agree
with the the, you know, idea that these
are goals that we're going to be working
towards anyway. Um you know for me the
point is more in the the reinforcement
to the community that they have
something concrete to look at. Can
>> you say one more word on that?
>> Yeah please. Um, in that case, I would
recommend that we revisit that
constraint as being specific to those
things that we will not the
superintendent will not allow for
special education committee to be dis
affected disproportionately by
discipline or um to fail to have timely
evaluations and make it specific to
somehow whatever way we can word it
properly to make it specific to those
things. And that would take the
absenteeism off. And I think it would um
address Fernando's concern, reduce some
of the load, and um also keep us focused
as we, you know, kind of address a lot
of the things um in the agreed order.
Make sure that we maintain a focus so we
don't um let that backslide. I think
there's an argument to be made on that
too. I know you're not supposed to keep
going when you are getting a yes, but I
I
>> keep going.
>> Uh, no, I agree. I mean, I think as we,
you know, potentially are going beyond
the agreed upon order, this would also
be a way to maintain the spirit of of
the work that we were doing there. So,
um, I appreciate the conversation around
it
>> and it is a large percentage of our
students as well. It's a population
that's a significant number. Um, Ashley,
uh, if that is there consensus on this,
how do we feel about this?
Yeah.
>> Yeah, I feel good.
>> Okay. So, um Ashley, can you help us
with language? Do you want to help us
with language right here, right now? Um
or should we work on that offline and
bring it?
>> Yeah, please committee that and then
>> Okay, we will committee that. Um you
good with that, Ashley?
>> I'm good. I'm good with that. And
>> committee that means I will talk to you.
But I may ask about timeline because if
this is on would that then move it away
from the next voting meeting because
there would not be time to post it.
>> Three business days.
>> Well, I think we will revise we will
probably make an amendment to what's
been posted, right? Would that be
lawyers the proper way to do that to
make an amendment to the scorecard?
If we put a draft up
>> because we'll be posting next Thursday's
meeting tomorrow, right?
>> Tomorrow. So, we would have to post it
as is. put a a revised draft up
>> early next week, probably after Ashley
and I have a chance to talk.
>> Certainly not an open meetings issue.
It's just more of like yourformational
expectations, but it's it's on the
information session agenda, I would
think, for the purpose of having these
conversations and taking the feedback
and making the changes as you. So, I
don't think that's inconsistent.
>> Okay. So, does that work for everybody?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So Ashley, you and I will work on
language about that. We will plan to
drop the chronic absenteeism.
Um Josh,
>> and I wanna I want to add just one thing
for the board. Um just to kind of I
think uh solidify this this
conversation. Um I don't have the
feedback from uh your most recent
community engagement in front of me. Um,
but I pretty much have the feedback
memorized from the first time that you
all did it, when you adopted the
scorecard in the first in the first
place. And those were the two um most
com uh most compelling uh values that
came from your community.
>> Um was around um
historically marginalized students and
special education. And so, um, if you
were going to keep, uh, if you were
going to keep an area, those are
probably the the two that, um, makes the
most sense for for you and for your
community. So, um,
I love this conversation.
>> Uh, thank you for that. All right. So, I
am making some notes here and um Ashley,
you and I will get together and work on
some draft language that we can post um
and a new headline for that constraint.
Uh and we will not create anything that
requires new calculations or new um
constraint progress measures from the
administration. We won't require you to
come up with a new way of measuring
things. We're going to keep what's
already there. Um the second one and the
third one, correct? and get rid of the
absenteeism.
>> Okay, I think so. Yeah.
>> Okay, good on that one. Um, let's just
go through these one by one then. I
think it'll be the most um effective way
to do it.
>> And I will just say I do support keeping
all five goals. However, I feel like we
already have measures and momentum on
those and I think that they are I would
I would like to keep all five goals.
>> Okay. Thank you. And I support keeping
all five goals really because I think
one of the other strong things we heard
from our community when we did
engagement is they want our schools to
be more than star scores. They want our
students to have a deeper set of of
skills. And I know we worked really hard
to um think carefully and creatively
about how to capture some of what our
community told us about critical
thinking um you know kind of deeper
skills uh than can be measured on a
standardized test. And I I think that's
how we got to some of those. So, um I
support that as well. Other people, any
thoughts?
>> I do want to ask just the the some of
the issues that were identified and
again, not in terms of the content of
the goal and a value statement on that,
but
how the reporting structure affects the
utility of the goal and the discussion
that we're having with the two that are
beyond HB3.
Are there
issues with the timeline, with the
structure of the reporting, with those
two goals that might
warrant rethinking how at least they're
structured or whether we should retain
them at all?
>> I think that's a question. I mean, you
know, the calendar and and when data is
available in a way, we don't. Do you
have thoughts about that? So, um I think
generally speaking, you know, all all
the goals are are are
the administration's no concern no
concerns with how they're written. I
would say that goal four, if there was
one to be considered for modification or
dropping to me, would be the middle
school algebra,
primarily because of um kind of where as
a system we are and how the laws come
into place to make it to where we're
going to be successful. We're already
being successful.
the group that supports middle school
algebra is also the same group that's
doing all the work around middle school
academics, school leadership. And so I I
have no problem reporting on this as
frequently as the trustees would like.
It really comes down to um reporting it
in this way because you only have one
goal progress measure. So I have to
report one goal progress measure
multiple times a year. it just ends up
becoming
um you know it I I would think it would
be frustrating for the trustees to hear
like really a report that doesn't get
updated because you only have one goal
progress measure. If you had multiple
goal progress measures over the course
of the year then I would come back you
know and update the board on the goal
with a different goal progress measure.
In this case I have one. Um so it just
it's one of those ones where
um we're we're already trending. There's
all the support behind it. We're very
focused on it. It's a lot of the same
people who are leading a lot of the
important work. It is time consuming. Um
happy to post provided as board updates.
Um but given that it's only one goal
progress measure against the goal and
just kind of how it's structured just
doesn't feel it's just hard. That's all
I'm going to say. Like it's just hard.
Um but that would be the only one I
would maybe ask the trustes consider.
everything else you know I feel good
about
>> if I if I can add we you have to present
on that four times one time is
summitative but then three times as
interim and so we're talking about that
sixth grade math so you saw the line
graph but then in the middle of it we
had to put bar graphs so that we can
somehow try to come up with ways to
explain where we are u so it does make
it tough to do it three times uh in the
interim
>> so I have a question about what might
work. Um, if we can lose the goal,
reduce the work and maybe still capture
the information. I think one of the
reasons there was interest in in 8th
grade algebra is that we know there is
data out there really tying it to
college attainment to success in higher
education. What if we got rid of the TSI
as a GPM and put that goal as a GPM
under college career military readiness
and eliminated goal four and had middle
school algebra as our third college
career readiness goal. Do we think
that's predictive? Do we think that
would count? I know that's the
administration's kind of job to come up
with GPMs.
Um, but do you think that would let us
continue to monitor
that in a way that was effective and
reduce the work? Um, and we could get
rid of the TSI and replace it with that.
>> Well, the CCMR goal I mean I
Yeah, I'd have to think about how that
would actually Yeah, I don't I'm trying
to think about the goal itself and how
it's written.
Um
yeah, so I mean all the work that E3
Alliance does, I mean we certainly know
there's a strong correlation between um
eighth grade algebra and post-secondary
success. So there there's no doubt that
that is is important. um how it fits in
CCMR as one of the goal progress
measures. I think I'd have to kind of
think through with the team here just to
make sure it I don't know if it would
require like a refinement of the actual
goal. Uh which which can't change. Um,
>> so that's
>> my guess is that algebra is important
like helpful with TSI that I might just
ask that question and maybe you can
>> think about that this week and bring
that to us and we can figure out what to
do with this in between or do we do we
feel like we just drop algebra and leave
and the other one like it is
>> yeah I would say I'm
>> I don't know if Dr. Maxwell, that's
where Ryan's coming up. If she's coming
up, there's usually something important
to say.
>> Well,
uh, we were just talking about that idea
back there. So, one of the things we do
report on is the, uh, college credit and
finding multiple ways to do that. So,
part of that reporting could be when we
see that uh, kids are starting to earn
advanced credit in um, high school. You
can act, as we're reporting, we can
backtrack that pathway into who had
enrolled in advanced math uh early in
accelerated pathways in middle school
and look at the effect that has on how
they're earning the the credits, the
advanced credits in high school. It just
could be a way that we report it rather
than having like being a separate.
>> So, what would that mean as far as your
um maybe recommendation on how to
structure that? I think I'd have to
think about that a little bit, but
>> Okay. We Well, okay. But it sounds like
that's potentially one way we could do
it.
>> I think we I think we could do it. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, why don't we wait for
recommendation on that?
>> Um, are we good with that?
>> Okay.
>> So, just to clarify, if that does work,
then we would be eliminating the eighth
grade algebra goal and it would instead
become a goal progress measure on the
CCMR goal.
>> Yes. And we would drop the TS we would
replace the TSI goal with a a goal
related to
>> I don't know that we would want to do
that.
>> I think we Yeah,
>> we would keep the TSI goal.
>> Yeah.
>> And we have four GPMs.
>> So
>> Ashley, we can only have three.
>> Oh, okay. That's right.
>> Okay. Well, I will do we want to ask for
a recommendation from the administration
about this whole situation?
>> Okay.
I think we heard a recommendation.
>> Yeah. Well, I think
>> Yeah,
>> I think we'd want to
>> is the recommendation to keep our CCMR
goals like they are and get rid of
eighth grade algebra. Is that
>> that's the recommendation?
>> The recommendation
>> that that would
>> What's that?
>> I'm sorry.
>> No.
>> Hi.
>> Hi. I'm not sure if you can see me.
>> Oh, hi. That's I couldn't It sounded
like a voice that wasn't Ashley's. Yes,
I see you. You're very tiny.
Sorry you all. Um, is it is it
appropriate now for me to kind of share
some a couple of thoughts on this?
>> Yes, it is.
>> Okay, cool. Thank you. Um, so I, as I'm
listening to this conversation,
one thought that comes to mind is, um,
I, you know, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I definitely
would hope that we keep algebra, you
know, tracking that eighth grade algebra
in here somehow, whether it's as, you
know, a goal progress measure or as its
own separate goal. Um what and this is
going to sound
um odd perhaps coming for me but when I
think about the the dual language and
the bilingual education work that we do
as a district I am um less concerned
about I I I'm less concerned about the
seal of biiteracy as I am about ensuring
that our
dual language is implemented well, which
is already a constraint progress
measure. So for for my purposes
um
I if I had to choose between algebra 1
by 8th grade or the seal of biiteracy
um and as long as we continued and we
kept the um the tracking of the
implementation of the dual language
program per our policy because that is
the thing that actually helps our
emergent bilingual students um the most
and where um I believe the biggest um
challenges. are right now. I would
probably
choose to to keep, you know, to
prioritize the algebra one by 8th grade.
Um,
so I just wanted to put my two cents in.
Hopefully, we won't have to make that
choice between the two and we can keep
it keep both of them somehow. But I just
wanted to say like especially when when
you look at the the goal progress
measures for our seal of biiteracy, we
are actually the numbers are are
interesting because we actually have
higher goals for students who are not
native Spanish speakers um than we do
for emergent bilingual students. And so
to me that doesn't feel as much like
centering emergent bilingual students as
much as as I would want it. And so for
that reason that's why I kind of
hopefully that gives a little bit of
background as to why um you know I feel
like looking at the implementation of
the dual language program which is I I
think um constrain progress measure 3
something I can't remember exactly um
that that that work gets really
reported on very closely and and the
focus is there. I'm not saying don't do
the the seal seal by literacy. I would
say carry on with that. But my bigger
concern is making sure that we're
getting is is monitoring the
implementation of dual language
particularly for emerging bilingual
students. So hopefully that makes sense.
Um but just wanted to put that out there
to make the discussion more um complex.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. Um
thoughts, trusty Kaufman.
>> Yeah. So I don't know if you weren't
here for this part of the meeting, Jesse
Singh, but we had discussed removing all
the constraints with the exception of
the new constraint five on F schools and
then revising constraint one to just
address disproportionality of discipline
and um and keeping up to date with um
evaluations for number one. So
>> Okay. Okay. I appreciate that. Yeah, I
didn't I didn't catch all of I did not
hear that part and I apologize.
>> Yeah, but I 100% agree that the dual
language implementation is a more
important
>> piece. I it goes back again to my
concern about the limitations of
constraints because the goal pro the the
constraint progress monitoring for that
basically says we will take one element
of dual language implementation a very
important one the language of
instruction but we'll take one element
of dual language implementation and in
five years we'll improve it a little bit
right that's not going to get our kids
where they need to go either so I don't
feel like it has enough teeth
>> to really be kind of
>> doing the work it needs to do. Um, but I
do agree with the seal of literacy being
a very important outcome, but again,
it's kind of turned into something
that's not quite going to move the work
in itself the way that we want it to.
So, I agree.
>> That's right. I I would
>> Yeah. I mean, so do you think so
Kaufman, you're kind of the resident
expert on some of this. Would you
so is are we getting rid of tracking the
dual language implementation as a
constraint?
I that was the recommendation is that we
not not I mean in the context of
reducing constraints it would be one
that
>> yeah okay so my
>> and I think the idea we haven't gone
through all the constraints yet so I
think we can talk through them one by
one
>> okay so so I would say
>> to be
>> okay that's helpful okay so I think what
I would say is
I don't want to get rid of any of the
constraints I actually feel like those
are really important
Um, but but if we had to take get rid of
some to make the numbers work and and
include the new one, I'm I'd be okay
with that. But I I really worry because
those are that's where we do get to talk
about our values and those
are really so important. Um
and so I would be really
I would need to really think about um
getting rid of too many of the
constraints. I would rather lose the
seal of biiteracy goal because it would
guarantee that we because it would allow
if if I had to choose between the two
that deal with dual language, I would
definitely pick the one that talks about
dual language implementation that just
affects so many more students and is
just more foundational to early
literacy. Um, and so that's that would
be my two cents, but I'll just um wait
till we go through all the constraints.
Um,
>> thank you. And I don't know if you
caught the beginning of the conversation
where um, Superintendent Ziggura
explained that that
>> the process of creating reports and and
preparing the data.
>> And then Yeah. Okay.
>> Okay. I mean, I didn't check in the
meeting, but I've talked to him about
that. So, yeah.
>> Okay. Perfect. And then Trusty suggested
pairing it down to just one because
that's all that we have to have. So
that's how we Yeah, that was our gateway
into this conversation.
>> Yeah. I mean the way my understanding of
a scorecard is and you know this is like
the fifth version of scorecard I've gone
through and we keep changing it based on
external factors and so that just makes
it so hard you know I that's that's why
I'm reticent to to change the
constraints again because like those we
we did so much work in in identifying
those values and we have set up the
infrastructure to track them and I think
it would personally
I I don't want to lose the opportunity
to talk about those things in depth on
the dis. I think those are things that
our community cares a lot about and I
believe those are um so so I don't know
but I I do think that the new constraint
is really critical. So I I don't know if
I would do a complete overhaul and just
reduce it to like one constraint if So
um but that's where I am now and I might
I might change my mind but I just I
don't want us to get in the habit of of
just changing the scorecard based on
external factors. Um because then we'll
be just changing them changing it all
the time. Um
and this seems like it's a a pretty
decent overhaul. It's not just a tweak.
So, thank you.
>> Thank you. Um, so let's come back to and
we'll come back to the constraints, I
think. So, let's come back to our the
scorecard. We have to have one, two, and
three. We've heard the administration
speak about what they think the
constraint progress measures should be
for our CCMR goals to leave them as they
are. And then we've had um a proposal
that if we're going to lose a goal that
we lose the seal of biiteracy goal, the
biiteracy goal rather than the algebra
goal. What do we think?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> What's that? Oh, down the road. Yeah. Do
we want to
>> How do we feel about that? Anyone? I can
>> I like the idea if if that's trusty
Kaufman if you think the constraint is
more meaningful,
but I would love to hear from you. I
think hearing your thoughts is
important.
>> So I think they're they're both
important. Um but I would I agree with
Trusty Singh. If we're looking at trying
to reduce total numbers but still have
maximum impact, I would say taking out
the goal and keeping and turning the
constraint into a single constraint
would be better.
>> Okay.
>> Trusty went too.
>> Um, yes. So, I'm I'm supportive of
eliminating both goals. I think the the
middle school algebra constraint
especially because of the new law that
requires the administration to do it and
they're doing a good job of it and um at
the superintendent um and the the
administrative recommendation I
supporting um goals four and five.
Okay. Anyone else?
>> I I mean I think for my part the the
rationale between for for both of those
seem like they make sense. Um you know I
don't know I I'm straining to speak on
the the value of how much reporting
we're getting from those two. I I mean
the constraint part makes a lot s a lot
of sense. I think the math um
I yeah I'm probably on the fence on
>> okay
the math goal seems clearcut to me
because of the issues with the reporting
um the repetitive nature of the goal
progress measure
um
I guess I'm still going back and forth
on the goal and the constraint I think I
would need to see what it would be what
the revised constraint would look like.
But I think right now given the points
that Trusty Hunter made, I would be in
favor of retaining just one through
three, the HB3 goals.
>> Okay.
Trusty Kintana, thoughts.
But
if we have to monitor the HB3 goals
anyway, then do should we make
I just don't understand how that makes
sense to
bring to our space if they're already
doing the work.
Shouldn't we
do something that's not mandated
already?
You're saying speaking in favor of doing
something that isn't already mandated.
>> Okay. So, I'm not sure we have
consensus. I'd love to hear would this
look like a motion. Bring the full
scorecard and make a motion.
We'll make some drafts.
Maybe keep
both of them for the moment. Or are we
do we have consensus that if we keep one
it would be algebra not by literacy and
then we can
>> so that so you're not voting tonight. So
the question I guess is and if there's
like a deadline to do this and it's next
week then
>> figure out a quick way to get where you
want to go.
>> Yes.
>> Um without meeting again between now and
next Thursday. Um, so
I guess it looks like a motion. Yeah. I
mean, you don't have to have a unanimous
vote,
>> right?
>> Um, that might be one thing to keep in
mind. Uh, but yeah, I mean, if there's
additional work that's going to have to
be done between now and then, you at
least should decide who's going to do
that.
>> We'll make I I can work with Ashley to
do the additional work based on our
conversation today. And then if there's
not clear consensus on biiteracy and or
algebra, we can come with one or both of
those and then make a motion about
approving it with or without. It's it's
complicated, but we do have a deadline.
>> I ask trusty conf
with the report repeated reporting like
I'm kind of the school of thought that
when you don't have anything new to say,
you just don't say much, right? So, will
we not be able to do have it on the
agenda and simply say no new updates
since last time or would they have to be
performative with kind of going through
the dance and pretending like we have
questions and then could we just say
we're going to ask some really good
questions the first time we hear that
data
>> and we're going to really dig in deep
and make sure that we're attending to
student results and making sure that
we're passionately getting the work
done. And then the next quarter there's,
you know, this was updated, that was
updated, we ask a couple questions, we
move on, and then is that not an option?
>> Um, I think that Dr. Koffman brings up a
good point, and this is one of the
challenges with only having um a single
GPM for a goal.
>> Um,
>> that's the biggest problem.
>> Yeah. I mean it really is because you
you are you do end up in this cycle of
just repetition and so that means that
every single time
um that you monitor it there there
should be an update um and that's one of
the actual requirements of the GPM is
that um that they are able to be updated
multiple times throughout the year. And
so if that's not possible, then um then
it might be necessary to look at if if
the board does decide to keep the goal,
then it might be necessary uh for the
administration to look at um an
additional GPM. And I don't know if
that's ne um it doesn't sound like
that's necessarily something that you're
wanting to wanting to do or that you
feel is necessary. And so um the
question is always going to be what what
is the best thing for kids? what is
going to uh move the system in the way
in the direction closer in the direction
of the vision. Um I'm not hearing a
compelling any compelling answers that
um that at least the goal that only has
the one GPM is um making a lot that you
that it's really necessary to monitor um
in terms of just monitoring you do need
to so if you have a goal it needs to be
monitored four times uh throughout
throughout the year. Um and that that is
one of the requirements of LSG. Um but
again
that usually also uh
has three three different things to
monitor. So
I sorry to cut you off there. Now thank
you Ashley because I mean that that
again kind of triggers my sped brain.
you know, if I have an IEP goal that
doesn't really require constant
tracking, I'm going to ask, is that a
goal that I need to keep or should that
be
a subset of of some other goal? And so,
I think we had that conversation about
whether that would fit into the CCMR.
And if it doesn't fit under that, if if
that's not a natural fit, I don't think
we should be trying to force it in
there. Um, so I think along those lines,
the fact that it doesn't have
robust progress monitoring or it's not
requiring it, that makes me question
whether the the goal is valuable to
keep.
And then I have a question,
Superintendent Sakura, if it if this
goal is not on the scorecard, is there
anything stopping the administration
from communicating the progress to the
public um in a transparent manner? No, I
think um as a team we've we've committed
to I mean this work is still going to
continue. Uh and so we've talked about
can we do a supplemental board update
and just say like we're going to present
on this do an actual call out in the
board update, post it online. um that
that in itself is just a different level
of effort and and it's an order of
magnitude level like it you know a
report to the community and to you all
is very different than a report that has
to be in a certain structure has to have
certain data sets has to has a certain
level of you know kind of quality
control detail analysis I mean we like
one of the things we just talked about
over the last two hours ago maybe three
hours ago was the inconsistencies in the
data associated with algebra
and the advanced academic or the um the
uh the yeah the academic the um uh
academic pathways for sixth grader sixth
graders and that was a function of us
trying to parse together different data
sets to say the same thing three times a
year because we reported on a data and
we were at a time of the year we didn't
have the complete data set then we
reported a little bit later had a little
bit different data set and then we
provided an update on the summitive data
at the end of the year which is what we
did now so that's that's what we're
running into uh So to your point, your
question, Trustee uh Willy Chu, no, we
will we're still doing the work. We have
no problem
communicating to our board and to our
our community, we will submit this
board, this report, you know, at this
time in the year and do it twice. All
right. Whatever we think makes sense
given the work, we're happy to do that.
Um it's it's really just the the lift
associated with this and the redundancy.
And and to Trusty Kaufman, your
question, I don't think we could come
back here and say we didn't do anything
just because I think our board and just
the nature of this atmosphere expects,
you know, that dialogue and that
conversation that puts us in a difficult
position if we just said, you know, and
I don't mean do nothing. I mean, it's
like, for example, like,
>> but I mean, I can see easy things that
if if students are enrolled in math and
we're wanting to see them succeed, why
can't we report on
um nineweek grades to say that the kids
are on track to passing this class? I
mean, are there things that are smaller
scale, easier to report that would allow
us to Yeah. Or Yeah, that's I just I
just I just don't I
I can see both aspects of if you if it's
not worth reporting, then it probably
shouldn't be on the list. I can also see
it's really important to do, but we
don't need to force it into a framework
that requires four times a year
reporting. So, if our current system
requires us to have it in four times per
year reporting and the element itself
doesn't lend itself to that, then I
would say we should take it off.
Okay. So, what is our thought about
um leaving it on, taking it off? Is
there enough
uh
difference of opinion that we leave it
on and make a motion to take it off or
vote with or without
to bring it next week? And how do we
feel also about the biiteracy goal? Is
there consensus on this or not?
>> We're trying to figure out how to move
forward efficiently.
>> Yeah.
>> Say, is is there any disagreement with
um
with the voting meeting having goals one
through three exclusively as the goals
up for vote?
>> I there was some disagreement. Um,
Trusty Singh had thoughts about algebra
>> um and had some thoughts about it and
and I think um I would love to hear some
input from our community if people have
thoughts um just because I think when we
were first creating the scorecard, our
community had very strong feelings about
reducing what we were talking about
simply to standardized tests and you
know the the CCMR goals and our
community felt like we were being pushed
honestly to be really candid.
into a system that focused very heavily
on test scores um and didn't leave a lot
of room for other other things. And I
think that was um you know part of what
we tried to get to with these goals and
and the process we went through and part
of what we were working to get through
with constraints you know with those
other values. And so I think um I guess
the possibility is we can bring it with
three and make a motion to add or we can
bring it with four or five and make a
motion to remove
um you know kind of approach it either
way
>> could because we're just sort of
belaboring it at this point. I don't
feel like there's movement. Would it not
be possible just to have the meeting
have what's on there have the discussion
part of the meeting and then vote then
we know
>> Yeah, that's that's kind of what I was
going to suggest. And I also would maybe
suggest that you consider the fact that
because nobody's change to the
recommendation is carrying the day for
the consensus that perhaps
you know that you ought to consider that
as well.
>> Yeah. Okay. So maybe we bring it with
all five and someone makes a motion.
>> Yeah.
>> And that seems cleaner and that way
they're there and removed and we don't
have to add on the fly.
>> We'll have some good Robert's practice.
>> Okay, that works. And that seems
simplest. Okay. Um, let's run through
the constraints. I think there was
consensus on constraint one that we
change the language, the title, change
the language, get rid of chronic
absenteeism, and focus on the the two
special education items. Um, special
education evaluations and exclusionary
discipline, which is not just um
students receiving special education
services, but but looking at discipline,
exclusionary discipline across student
groups. We good with that? Okay. Next
one is um caregiver engagement and
families and meaningful partnerships.
Um do we have thoughts about removing
that?
And I know trustee Singh had said um
keeping the constraints maybe our
possibility is that we do the same thing
and keep them unless we want to really I
would say three is easy because academic
disparities we talk about every time we
talk about any academic goal to me that
one is a pretty easy one to lose.
Do we have thoughts about that?
And I have thoughts about constraint two
again which I think I'm repeating myself
but constraint two turned into goal six
because it is now saying we you know one
of our goals is to effectively implement
a dual capacity building framework on
more campuses. So to me that's that's a
goal and if we're if we are believing
that which I do believe narrowing the
focus to smaller number of things that
we attend to
not reducing the number of things that
the district is doing, but reducing the
number of things that we're attending to
at the board meeting, then then I I'm
uncomfortable continuing to keep 10
goals.
I also do want to I guess go back to um
constraint one
and the constraint progress measures and
the points that uh trustee Theodorost
made. Um I think those are vital pieces
of information that historically the
community have not had access to or were
misled on. And I think that
there could there be I'm wondering could
there be perhaps another way another
avenue for the community to have that
information that isn't through a
constraint progress measure.
thoughts.
I really like three.
If we were going to keep one, I would
say three.
>> You like three?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
And Trusty deoste, do you have thoughts
about um Trusty Gonzalez's question,
Secretary Gonzalez's question about
number one and the special education
items and whether there would be another
way to share that?
>> You know, I I guess for
for 1.2,
I feel like that that's already
something that we have been reporting on
and that we're doing. And so I I feel
like the uh efficiency on reporting like
you know I'm open to being wrong but I I
don't see how it's particularly more
laborious to continue to report on it
than it already has been because it's
it's just a strain report number and I I
feel like it's you know it does tie
directly to something that the
community's been asking for. and the
disciplinary one um kind of that one I
think in particular specifically beyond
just special education the way that
we've framed it so that it's you know
specific demographics um I mean that
it's just one that I hear so often from
the community I I don't know about
I to me it symbolizes something to have
that as as a constraint that we're
reporting on and and because it's a very
clear one that
the numbers just you know reflect so so
>> yeah no trusty I appreciate that and I
don't think I mentioned I don't think I
said that this it was laborious like as
far as reporting like like it is not
difficult to report this one specific
sub uh constraint um and so yeah and it
it's going to I mean really go go
through 2025 26 so at some point we're
going to have to restructure it anyway I
mean the way that it's written um so
just for whatever it's worth um no so
that that's not difficult to
Yeah. And I I apologize. I didn't mean
it to
some of them are really really hard.
This this um but uh I think chronic
absenteeism like that like you know
there are so many ways that we are
tackling that for a variety of reasons.
You know to me that would be one it
drops if if the trustees would consider
it.
>> I think we're there on that one that
there we have clear consensus on that.
>> Yeah it's okay. So then but you said one
two and one three you were the ones you
were talking so I just was kind of
>> yeah and
>> just to speak on the difference because
you know one two is something that we're
already reporting on as part of the
agreed upon order you know this this
tends to tie into it and all of that um
so I feel like that's already there and
one three between the different
populations I I just people talk about
it so much I feel like it's it's
worthwhile to keep on there um so you
know those are really the main two that
I'm focused within within that piece.
Um, I just think the community would
find a lot of value in continuing to see
them.
>> I think given what we've been through
with special education, I do support
having that um making sure that the
progress is steady. We've I think we've
seen so many times a district get turned
a school get turned around and fall back
into problems or, you know, we we
pay attention to it while we're paying
attention to it and then we lose sight.
Um and so I do think there's some value
at least for a little while maybe
especially if it's an easy thing to
report
um
having that there the last just just
because I do sit right next to trustee
coffin. Um I to me I do see this as a
constraint because it's it's very much a
barometer you know like I I don't think
we're saying there's a goal to have this
be zeros across the board or anything
like that. It's it's something that
clearly reflects disparity in in
discipline as you know a good way to
track you know what's happening in
practice and it's involves so many other
things that we're doing. Um you know it
really is kind of a litmus for all those
other pieces that contribute to these
scores that we're seeing.
>> Okay.
Um, so do we want to bring one
with 1.2 and 1.3 and then we can take a
vote to make a motion? Okay, let's look
at number two. We have thoughts about
number two.
I mean, I I will just point out that
5.2% 2% had something that kind of fit
with our
our family engagement policy and their
campus improvement plan. We hear from
families a lot that um they aren't
engaged in meaningful ways. That's not
new in the district. Um and that number
is really really low. Um and I'm not
sure that this constraint is going to
fix what we hear from families. So, just
want to kind of put that out there, but
really show that, you know, a campus
improvement plan,
family engagement we believe is
meaningful. Our community told us that
was a value and that was meaningful and
and um
and I'm not sure as as Trusty Coffman
said that this necess you know these
constraints necessarily get us where we
want to be. So, I think it's um worth
considering.
>> Yeah. Can I say something? Um, so I'm
right there with you as far as, you
know, how valuable it is to to recognize
and engage with their communities and
and, you know, take their lived
experience to inform our work and to do
it in a true partnership. I think what
makes this hard is that much of this
will fall on the campus. Um, and at a
time when we're navigating lots of
things on our campuses because the way
that it makes its way into is in the
campus improvement plan, right? Campus
improvement plans are by campus. Our
principles work with our executive
directors. They build them out. We
provide professional development. But at
the end of the day, you know, we are
asking our principles to to to lead this
work because we have over 100 campuses.
I mean that's just it, you know, that's
just part of how we would have to
operationalize this. And so with
everything going on, I worry about um
kind of having it be there in this way
because it it does create a little bit
of time conflict um as we think about
reporting because of of what we're
asking to be done. Uh so I think there's
other ways. I think overall we we
support it surely, but um it is
something that I at least want to be
considered from that perspective. And
maybe there's different ways we can
build upon it and expand upon it um in a
different way, but the way that it's
written in and have it be in the cabin
improvement plan, it just it's just a
different kind of feel locally.
And I think um
the flip side is that when things get
really busy, I think our community, you
know, feels like this is something
that's is sometimes seen as fluff and
unnecessary. Um and I think working
together, we chose the campus
improvement plan because it's something
the principles are doing anyway and that
it and that one of the levers that are
to be considered is kind of that family
engagement. Um and I hear what you're
saying. So, um, you know, this is not
mine to decide, it's ours to decide, and
I want it to be meaningful, and I want
it to be doable. Um,
yeah. And I think it's it's here because
we heard from our community, and I know
we can't keep, you know, you're we're
hearing you say we can't keep
everything. So, um, I think the question
is what we move forward with. Do we move
forward?
Is it easier to move forward with
everything we don't have consensus on
um and make a motion to only keep what
we want? I this is obviously it's
important but it's important to for you
to do the work you need to do, right?
>> Yeah. And and just to be uh what I was
wanting to after we did completed one
full year with the monitoring report,
sorry, the scorecard with our monitoring
reports, I just wanted to communicate to
our trustees um just what it felt like
>> and what it feels like tackling all the
things, right? Special education agreed
order, consolidations, accountability,
budget, and it's the same individuals
leading much of this work. So I I think
really I I all of these are great like
they all have a purpose. We work through
them. So it's really a function of if
there's an opportunity to reduce it
would be meaningful because of what
we're currently tackling. That that is
really the I don't want anybody to walk
away from this conversation that I feel
a certain way about these. I think
they're all valuable.
>> We understand that. We understand that.
>> Um and I know we're tackling big things
with fewer people because there's a
scarcity of resources. I understand
that. of time, of money, of a lot of
things. Um,
okay. So, caregiver engagement, where
are people keep it on or take it off?
Off.
>> Yeah. I'm I don't I don't see how we're
going to do any of the work that we have
coming up if if we were aren't already
doing,
four, and five.
>> Okay. Candace.
Okay. I think if we don't we need to
move through. I think if we don't have
con if we don't have consensus we can
keep it on take it off with a motion
when we come to our voting meeting
because I don't we could talk about this
all night. Are we good if we don't have
clear consensus leaving it on and
waiting for a motion? Okay. Number
three.
Trusty Kintana has said keep.
Yeah, I agree. If we're losing the dual
language on the goals that we would keep
something for dual language on the
constraint
>> because this is the quality of our dual
language instruction. Could we take only
that and get rid of the gifted and
talented Ashley? How many times do we
have to monitor
each constraint is just once a year?
>> Uh the constraints need to be they just
need to be monitored once per year. And
um but I do want to remind the board
that it is a superintendent um that the
constraint progress measures are the
superintendent's to identify.
One of the things that I am that I have
heard on several of these is that
they're not actually um
they're kind of you're you're kind of
maintaining the status quo almost. It
sound it sounds like and maybe that's
not their best wording, but um it
doesn't sound to me I'm I'm not hearing
a compelling um argument that um some of
these constraints or constraint progress
measures are actually changing adult
behaviors u which is what it's what it
this is about. And so, um, you know, if
they're if adult behaviors aren't
changing, then either,
um, the constraint progress measure is
maybe isn't actually reflective of the
constraint or maybe it's, um, it's just
not the right thing for this school
system now that you've been been through
a full year of implementing. So,
take with that what you will.
>> Thank you.
>> Can I can I ask a clarifying question? I
just for for a constraint, you know, I
guess part of the way I'm interpreting
some of this is to make sure that adult
behavior stays changed, that it's not
changing in the in the wrong direction.
>> Would that be fair?
>> In some in some instances that is that
is accurate, but that is very rare. Um
generally generally you want to
um
you want to so if you if something is
happening and you don't want that thing
that's happening to stop then put a
constraint around it. Um if there is
something that is happening that you
don't want the district to do anymore
then put a constraint around it. Um, but
generally if if things are working the
way that they should be working and it's
not something that is um that's really
at risk of not happening, if there isn't
a constraint, then there isn't a
compelling reason to have a constraint
there. Um, but ultimately it is the
board's decision on on what constraints
you decide to keep and which which ones
you decide to get rid of. Um, I also I
just want to let the board know. I just
shared a guidance document about uh
constraints and guardrails with um Josh
and President Boswell to make sure that
everyone gets that before the next um
before the voting meeting so you can
have a little more information about
them.
>> Thank you.
Um so looking at constraint three I'm
going back to our conversation about um
goal five about the seal of biiteracy
and having this CPM be more meaningful
to us and is there thought about keeping
constraint three and that constraint
progress measure and getting rid of goal
five and superintendent Sigura how would
you feel if we kept only if we turned
this into a dual language goal and got
rid of the gifted and talented. I
understand the grant we had that was
supporting that work may be gone.
>> Um, and that's going to maybe I I hope
some of the work is baked in, but I
don't know how would you feel how what
is the thought about making this taking
away one of the constraint progress
measures and making this a dual language
goal.
>> So 3.1 I I very much appreciate I I I
think that's a great uh constraint
progress measure. I I think over the
last year we really learned how to
balance the observations occurring by
our principles versus um the
multi-ingual education department and so
you know I I feel I personally feel
strongly that should be kept um you know
>> yes I'll just say that I don't want to
>> and how do you feel about um CPM 3.2
>> if we turned this into a a dual language
goal and got rid of 3.2 That would
reduce some work.
>> Yes.
>> How do we feel everybody?
>> It's not a goal.
>> Uh if we kept the dual lang turn it into
a dual language constraint. Thank you.
>> And I could work with Ashley on language
about the headline uh the caption the
and the name of the constraint and the
language.
President Boswell, I have a quick
comment or maybe a question on this. Um,
so for this one and this is and I
apologize I missed the first part of
this really important discussion.
>> Um, is is the reason we're doing this is
because it's um taking away the
administration's
uh attention from other compelling
things that are happening right now in
our district. Is that correct? There are
lots of heavy lifts and this is taking
up a lot of time.
>> Yes. And the question is how meaningful
all of it is.
>> Okay. And then I want some clarity on
from the superintendent. Like if we took
away the GT the GT constraint progress
measure, does that mean that the GT work
stops
or does it mean it um it continues but
maybe in a reduced fashion or does it
mean it's it's still going full force?
You're just not writing the report and
we're not talking about it in a board
meeting.
So I would say it's it's the latter but
modified maybe slightly because as
president Boswell mentioned and I don't
have my notes um we did provide it kind
of internally when we were developing
these documents a lot of the things that
were contributing to some of the
pressures uh in this instance there were
some grants that um we had secured for
quite a while that were helping us
>> um provide the supports uh to ensure
that we could meet these goals. So even
the targets when they were set or I say
targets the constraint targets were set
at a different time and we had different
resources. Uh another example of that I
mean not to change from 3.2 but 3.1 you
know when we first envisioned 3.1 we had
actually more staff within the multi
multilingual education department than
we have now. And you know the second
part the first in the first year the
second observation was completed totally
by the multilingual education department
and now we just simply don't have those
individuals in the same way we had
before because of the loss in title two
three and four dollars and those are
going away in the next fiscal year. So
so it it it is in order to create some a
little bit of space to focus on the
things that are at hand. But there are
other things contributing to making this
harder now that we've gone through one
year of it. And I just gave you two
examples of them. But so I just want to
make it clear, it's not just because I
don't want to report more. There are
lots of other things contributing to
this. Uh but as far as the work, it will
continue. The work will absolutely
continue.
>> Um the targets, if if we have a target,
we're going to hit that target, which
means I have to deploy resources and
kind of offset grants that have since
dried up, right? So that's what we're
struggling through. really helpful.
Okay. So, I think that's that's a really
great connecting piece for me that I was
kind of maybe missing. Um, so I think
like whatever we propose to cut, um, I
think it would be really helpful to
identify
kind of the options like is it are we
cutting this because this work is being
diminished because, you know, federal
funds or state funds are being cut. Um,
and so we just don't have the resources
now that we did before to really do this
well. Um, or are we still going to do
this work full force? We just want to
save a little time here and the
reporting piece of this and maybe we'll
get this information out another way. I
think it's really important to create
that distinction because that's going to
impact like how I feel about some of
these things. And I really appreciated
what Secretary Gonzalez said earlier
about like, okay, if there's something
on here that maybe doesn't no longer
merits being a constraint progress
measure, but we maybe have a community
engagement session around it or like
something like that. Like we've got to
tell folks like I I would when we kind
of finalize this, I would like to know
what's going to happen with the things
that we cut out and why. I think that
transparency is going to be really
important because otherwise people are
going to say, "Oh, look, the district
cut out caregiver engagement. They don't
care about, you know, see like we told
you they didn't care about family
engagement." You know, like I I want us
to be really thoughtful about the
rationale for these. And I would say in
addition,
I I don't know if we can even do this,
Ashley. Maybe you can. I would love your
guidance, but like could the
administration come up with like an
easier progress measure um or a more
effective one now that we've had a year
to sort of beta test some of these? So
for like for you know if people aren't
really feeling like our our constraint
progress measure for caregiver
engagement is really like changing the
adult behaviors that we want. um maybe
the idea of like doing a dual capacity
framework and a campus improvement plan
is just too much um talk and not enough
action. Could we just simplify it to
just say like we're going to have an
active PTA at every campus, which
actually was one of our scorecard goals
when I first came on the board or
something like that because that is
something that's super tangible. It's
it's a much easier to measure and it
would allow us to direct things. I mean,
our PTA is just absolutely critical
right now in all these changes that
we're creating and and
like you know, so I'm just wondering if
we maybe could if this is also an
opportunity to simplify
um a CPM rather than getting rid of one
alto together.
>> Yeah. So trusty sink three things um
the comment around creating time and
then not doing the work. I are not
having the ability to do the work in the
same way because the funds have been
reduced in some way. There's I think
there's also a third component which is
we have the funds to do the work. I
don't necessarily have the funds to
track it in a way that actually is
responsive to the target in the
scorecard. Um because you know if you're
tracking something typically it's an
observation tool or there is a level of
effort deployed across all your schools
to ensure that you're actually scoring
it a certain way and have it be
calibrated so the work can continue
because we have the resources to do that
but how we track it and the ensuring
kind of validity in how we do it is also
resource consuming. So every time we do
something, you know, the tool to track
it and the resources to track it are
also a significant expense. So that's a
third thing that I think it really is
part of this conversation. I don't want
to get lost or maybe missed or maybe
kind of not considered. Um and the other
thing is uh for the dual capacity or for
caregiver engagement, some of these were
baseline years, right? So so it was just
the first year and so we learned a lot
in that year. you know, we we that's the
purpose of a baseline here. Um, so you
you you weren't going to see ma maybe
the the complete shift because we were
just tracking where we are. Um, so I
just wanted to kind of share that as
well because there are lots of things
that we learned. We learned about how to
collect data. We learned about what it
really means when you put it in one
place or another. Uh so so that also
contributed to this because some of the
things we're actually modifying are
baseline years that once we get through
it you're like hey that wasn't actually
what we intended and maybe the way that
we thought we were going to pull it
isn't actually how we should pull it. So
a lot of that is contributing to this as
well and absolutely if there's a
modification we've already spent the
time to think through kind of why we're
leaning or maybe why our recommendation
is a certain way. So we will provide
that data and can call out maybe the
things that are putting pressure on why
we're making a recommendation to move
away or not.
So yes, I hope that was helpful.
>> Appreciate that.
>> Thank you. Um
so do we have a thought given what we've
just heard about um the administration
saying they think the dual language goal
is valuable? Um, and the conversation we
had earlier feeling like that um was a
more meaningful measure
of of real progress toward that. Um,
not a perfect measure. Obviously, a
narrow measure. Um, but also revealed
that a lot of our classrooms weren't
being faithful even to language of
instruction. And then gifted and
talented may not be something that makes
a lot of sense right now. How do we feel
about changing constraint three to a
dual language constraint, keeping the
first constraint progress measure, and
getting rid of the gifted and talented
progress measure given reality right
now? I have a thumbs up. I have a thumbs
up. I have a nod. Yes,
Candace.
Arthy,
>> sure.
>> Okay. I have we have another point of
consensus for uh reducing some of the
workload and a change. Okay. Early
learning constraint. Um Vice President
Willie Chu is not here and I know this
is one that um had been important to her
throughout. Do we want to discuss that?
Come back to that.
>> Okay. And she's back there. She may
>> Yeah.
Um
>> I'm curious the superintendent's
thoughts on that.
>> Yeah, on the early learning
>> seems like a lot of work has been gone
into developing a measure.
>> Yeah, I mean
uh there's there's lots of work in all
of these. Um you know, I think when we
built the constraint, we were trying to
find this balance between something that
was already familiar, but something that
hadn't been operationalized in the way
that would allow us to track it the way
that we are. Um, and so it was a
baseline year, so we learned a lot. Um,
you know, it's kind of one of those ones
where it'd be helpful, but again, the
work is going to continue. It's a focus
of ours. We've actually restructured
ourselves um to to really, I think,
invest uh in early learning. Um, I mean,
it is a big focus of ours. So, for us, I
mean, I maybe ask Dr. Maxwell if she had
anything to share but I mean generally
speaking it's it's one that you know
there's there's significant there's
value in it but it's also a lived so I
mean I don't know Dr. Maxwell, if you
want to
>> I I think this is really I mean we've
worked really heavily in this as a
district initiative. Uh so that work had
had already started. Um it presents
itself in a lot of the things that we're
doing really uh specifically for the
early childhood classroom in prek prek3
and prek4.
um and uh in including the the team in a
lot of work and actually some of our
campuses in um improving practices in
the early childhood classroom. Uh part
of that is a a grant from the Moody
Foundation that allows us to work with
the school empowerment network that's
come in and started workingly with with
some campuses. Um and then it's uh
inherently integrated. But I think part
of that early learning initiative too is
really focusing on K2 practices uh in
through content. So that's part of it's
part of the work that's integrated into
literacy and numeracy that and the way
that we focused on K2 that of course as
as we've talked many many times uh a big
a big part of that so that we're really
looking at the prek through second grade
classroom and and all that. So, I think
most of that is really involved in our
our district initiative. That's on top
of some of the other work that we did
just to kind of stabilize some
foundational work in um prek3 and prek4
with some of the guidance, the
curriculum, the training that we've
provided uh to those teachers and how
we've really amped that up. So, there's
part of the initiative I would say is a
lot of that work.
Okay, we have thoughts about this,
consensus on this. Do we think it's
getting us toward what we want? Trust
that it'll happen. Want to put it away
for a moment?
I think Katherine was clear to go down
to just one, so we probably have her
answer. Um, trusty will, but do we have
thoughts?
>> Oh, yeah. Trusty.
>> Okay. Sorry. Um, and I seem to be the
one that like I'm like I want to keep it
like you know. Yeah, because this is our
chance to talk. I mean that I I'm really
just having a hard time getting my um
just wrapping my arms around the idea of
it took us like six months to develop
this scorecard and now we're just like
you know I I worry about just like cd
dropping things that are just so
important
to our work and and I know that that
we're being put in this position largely
you know for for so many so many reasons
I could list but I just
I don't want us to take our eye off the
ball um for this one. So,
you know, and and that's why I get back
to if we're not able to do the work
anymore or do it to a lesser degree,
that's one thing. Um but sorry, I just
realized my video is off. Um, but if we
are still going forward and we're doing
the work and it's really just the
reporting is is a burden
like I don't feel I I still I'm like
well you got to do the report like you
know like that like if you're doing the
work the report maybe then maybe we just
say our report needs to be something
simpler but I you know if we are doing
the work full force
then I I would like us to continue
keeping keeping tabs on me on it and
maybe reducing the effort and and the
report that comes to the board. But my
understanding is like our our
constraints are neutral time and that is
really important time for us to talk
about behavior changes and and I know
that there's I don't want to like throw
the baby out with the bathwater is my
concern and I might be in the minority
here and that's fine but I can't I can't
not share what my worries are about
taking taking this one off. So
>> I think that's fair. Thank you. Um,
>> thank you.
>> And I do know that when we stop paying
attention, some things sometimes start
stop happening. So, Dr. Maxwell, were
you gonna say something? Sorry.
>> I think we were trying to
>> Yeah. I I just think this is one of
those ones where I think we're very much
aligned. It's focus Dr. Maxwell's
hyperfocus on early learning. You know,
it I I think again, overall, I think any
relief is helpful. There's there's not
any one that I think is less valuable
necessarily. I just want to be really
clear. So trusty seeing and everybody
like that's that's not it. It's just
when you have 10 things that you have to
report on multiple times a year that
that's really what I'm trying to address
overall. So you know this this stays
we're fine with it. It's not I mean
>> yeah I I think this is work we're very
excited about and um want want to
continue in depth. there there is a
little bit of difficulty in trying to
connect um additional walkthroughs for
teachers that's also connected to PP
PPFT and um the validity of measuring
walkthroughs is always very tough. Um,
so while I can easily say like I enjoy
the opportunity to really talk about
that work that we're doing in early
childhood, the the measure itself is is
difficult and I'm not sure that it's the
best measure of how that work is
happening or whether it's happening
well. But it gives us the opportunity to
talk about and I will I'll share just
one perspective which is I know
walkthroughs are stressful and they're
timeconuming for the walkers and they're
stressful for the walkies, right? the
people whose classrooms are visited. And
to some degree, um, removing this could
be a sign that we trust our teachers to
do what they're good at and what they
know how to do. Um, and in that spirit,
I would be open to getting rid of it
because our teachers um, often want to
be trusted to teach and we are offering
really strong training. We're offering
really strong expectations. I know we're
doing more of that in more thoughtful
ways. Um, and I would be supportive of
removing this for that reason. If if the
lift is big and the stress is high,
thoughts
I mean I I prefer to keep it and I am
okay with reducing to a minimum number.
So I'm okay either way. I think I think
it's important. I think there's a big
difference between just focusing on
grades pre-K through second and
addressing developmentally appropriate
practices. And we have somebody who
believes in developmentally appropriate
practices, but the purpose of board
policy is to kind of enshrine things
that represent the vision and values of
the community over time so that it
doesn't change with the next iteration.
So I think I do know we've heard loudly
and clearly from our community that that
they value developing appropriate
practices and early early learning.
>> So I'm okay either way. I think it's an
important goal. I think I like that they
attended to how they can fit that
measure into existing structures instead
of creating something brand new.
>> Teachers are going to get walkthroughs
all the time. Um they were meant to be
supportive. They're meant to be
professional growth, not gotchas. So, as
long as we're doing them in a way that's
supportive and not oppressive, then it's
not a bad thing to do walk through.
>> And we're doing them anyway. Absolutely
fair. Okay. So, I I think we have
consensus. Why don't we leave that on?
We can make a motion. Um number five for
accountability. I think we're clear that
there's value in that. That is um we are
in that moment. Thank you, Dr. Maxwell.
Um how do we feel keeping a dual
language constraint? Do we want to go
back and revisit um goal number five by
literacy
and think about taking that goal off and
focusing on the constraint in the spirit
of saying we are absolutely reducing a
burden somewhere like bits and pieces
and a goal. How do we feel?
>> Yes. Thumbs up.
>> Yes.
>> Can you say that again? So we have we
had talked about the the dual language
education and biiteracy and bilingualism
and we had two places we were looking at
that. one was in the goal goal number
five for biiteracy
um which is looking at the the seal of
biiteracy or the um global seal of
biiteracy or the Texas um measure um and
then we had looked at measuring the
fidelity one measure of the f fidelity
of language of instruction as a
constraint and and there was discussion
that that constraint was actually
probably
um made a bigger impact in in the
classroom than just measuring what
happens at the end basically. And the
idea is that if we keep we change our
constraint to dual language, we've
reduced the gifted and talented. We can
accomplish what we're hoping by having,
you know, strong
um biiteracy and leaving leaning into
dual language without the goal but with
the constraint. Does that make sense?
And then we can lose goal number five
and reduce the burden for the
administration with that.
>> Yes.
>> Do we feel good about that? Okay. Okay.
Okay. So, I think we have a plan. That
was a lot of conversation. Thank you
all. Um I think we're hearing you and
we'll come back and there may be we
we'll start
um with these changes and um then we can
vote on
>> Can you summarize the net changes?
>> Yes, I am I have a document that I have
made and I will summarize. So, the
changes that we will be considering are
um third grade literacy stays the same.
It's one that we have to have CCMR.
Third grade numeracy goal two stays the
same. It's one that we have to have um
sorry HB3 goal. It is also an HB3 goal.
Goal three stays the same. Um at the
administration's recommendation, we
discuss changes. We are not making
changes. Um and that is another one that
we have to have a college career
military readiness goal. Um we are going
to leave goal four on to bring it to um
the meeting next week and we can take a
vote with it on or with it off. We'll
we'll entertain a motion to approve it
as presented or to make a change to it.
Goal five we are removing.
Um okay. So that's what we're doing. The
entire goal
>> the entire goal of gore goal five
because we are going to focus our
attention our biiteracy attention on a
constraint
um that measures the fidelity of
language of instruction. So we're going
to go through the constraints now. Does
that make sense?
>> So you said
>> we're going to get to the constraints
now and we'll go through
>> Got it.
>> Um yes. And hold on. I'm cleaning up my
notes so I know that we are really
really clear on what we're going to be
doing. Um, and I will work with Ashley
and I will work with Josh uh to make
sure this is all and share it with the
officers to make sure what we're putting
forward is what we're talking about.
Okay. Uh, first superintendent
constraint. Um, we are changing the
title. It's going to be focused on
special education. Um, we are going to
change the the actual constraint itself.
I will work with Ashley to make that
happen. Um, GPM number one is going away
chronic absenteeism. So, that's the
second thing we're removing. Um,
we are changing the constraint progress
measures. We will we are going to bring
two for for a potential vote. Um, and
they both focus one focuses specifically
on special education evaluations. The
other is exclusionary discipline. Um,
constraint two, caregiver engagement.
Um, there is no consensus. We'll leave
it and we can make a motion. Constraint
three, um, instead of academic
disparities, we're calling it
specifically dual language. Um, we will
have to change the title and the
language. I will work with Ashley on
that. And we're keeping constraint
progress measure 3.1.
Um, the language of instruction. Uh,
we're keeping that. And we are getting
rid of CPM 3.2 for gifted and talented
for many reasons. um one of which that
funding has been lost. Um the work will
continue um but it will continue um
differently and we don't have to have
special reporting um as a result. So
that's a third thing we're removing. Um
constraint four early learning we will
leave on for our meeting um and decide
uh through our motion what we do with
that. Uh constraint five accountability
is the new one and there seems to be
clear consensus that that is a something
we want to have. we good on that? Am I
accurate on that? Okay, that was a
really long conversation. Thank you,
Ashley. Thank you um for supporting us
through it. That was very helpful. Um
so, appreciate that. We are going to
move on since we are still in agenda
update. Um we're changing updates to the
board monitoring calendar. This calendar
that we have in front of us will now
have to be changed. Um and uh Ashley, I
have a question.
Okay,
>> we need to approve the board monitoring
calendar this month,
but we won't know how to make the
monitoring calendar until we approve our
scorecard. I've talked with Josh about
an order of operations
um for voting separately on a lot of
these. Um, can we change the Josh, do
you think we can change the calendar,
have a couple of versions of the
calendar ready to go and we can approve
the one that matches what we come up
with?
>> Do you want me to have like the six
permutations before the board meeting?
>> Uhuh. I'll work with you.
>> Gotcha.
>> Okay. Thank you, Ashley. Does that work?
And then we'll pick the one that matches
the scorecard we come up with. It's a
little choose your own adventure.
>> I'm happy to work with Josh as well.
>> Okay. Thank you. little choose your own
adventure, but I think it will get it
done by the deadline we have. Thank you.
>> You need to So, if if you get in a pinch
with that um at the voting meeting, you
can always table it and and it'll be
fine.
>> It'll be fine even though
>> Yes, it'll it'll be fine. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Um it's it's um we're going to call it
extenduating circumstances.
>> Okay. Thank you.
Okay, we'll we'll try the choose your
own and adventure route if we can't make
that work. Thank you for that, Grace. Um
I appreciate that. Okay, so next item
that we're going to talk about um that
is one of our deliverables for
September. Um
is in our our cleanup process is
approving amendments to our board guard
rails. Um we have three. We have to have
at least one. Uh, guardrail 2 um was
faulty according to Lonear governance
rules because it had a double negative
and it only has needs one negative at
the beginning and not one in the middle
and because it listed three things and
we can only list one. Um, so we need to
have at least one guard rail.
We don't have to have three, but if we
include two, it has to be rewarded. And
Ashley and I worked to come up with
language that captured some of what we
wanted. So, we could keep just number
one, we could have just number two, just
number three, or we can keep all three.
Do we have thoughts?
You want all three
thoughts?
>> All three.
>> Okay. Any any objection to this? Okay,
Ashley. Um, this language, we're good.
>> You're good.
>> Okay, perfect. We are moving quickly
now. Um, all right. Approval of
amendments to the board handbook. Um,
Josh, can you help me remember the
changes we made because I
>> Okay, there. Here we go.
>> Yeah, I did red line it and
>> Yes.
>> edit blue text for new. Yes. So, we're
Yeah. Updating the calendar in there.
Um, it's not many.
Yeah, it's not many. Some of it's
cleaning up um language to match
reality, new positions after
reorganization.
>> I did change a little bit of the timing
because of the 72 hours versus three
business day rule.
>> New laws. So, it's really clean up um
really as much as anything. And then
this is an important one to talk about
the general public comment. Um there has
been um Superintendent Sigora, can you
explain a little bit about what you're
hoping we will um consider? Yeah. So,
um,
one of the challenges that we have
observed, uh, over the last 18 months is
that we will get, um, call calls, um,
community comment or public comment, uh,
into the four:00 hour. And what has
happened is the time that it takes for
us when we get those late calls
sometimes to um redact something that
maybe needs to be redacted or to make
sure there's an interpretation to really
uh kind of go through the process that
we need to make it uh public uh has
pushed us up against the board meeting.
And so now with the law changing and
when we post uh agenda items and make
our um items public, instead of posting
them on Friday and close the business at
6, it's actually going to Monday.
Sorry, we're brain is melting here.
Typically, it's Monday at 6 p.m. Now
it's actually Friday. So we're picking
up the entire weekend. So, one of the
things that Josh and I were talking
about is now that those documents will
be public several days earlier than
before, can we actually create more time
for community to call in uh but now make
it for um uh the two days before and
then the day. Yeah. So, essentially, how
did we write it down?
>> It's a 9 to5 the day before and then 9
to one the day of.
>> Yeah. So, that's more hours total. Um,
but it gives you more of a window to
actually do the work, especially as we
we have more and more callers.
>> Yeah, I would say the one um thing I
know we've heard from some of our staff
is having that really early time, that
7:45
is valuable to allow staff to come in
before they go to work. Um, so I would I
I support those changes. You know, I
support
changing it so you have more time to do
what you need to do, but I would like to
keep that 7:45 a.m. on that second day
to honor what our staff have really
specifically requested. And then um I do
think we need to be really conscious of
communicating really thoroughly with our
community because um it's a moment when
I think we have a lot going on and
people are going to want to be making a
whole lot of public comment and I don't
want anyone to feel like we have um kept
them from commenting about some really
really you know some of the most
important decisions we have ever made as
a district. Um, and I think it's really
important that our community voice be
heard and that we do have time to redact
if anyone's named, if anyone, and I know
we've had some comment when like a
couple of them today were flipped and
didn't match the time or we had one a
few months ago where we were worried
that one had gotten dropped. Um,
>> so 7:45 to 11:45 the second day.
>> She's saying 745 to one to one. Okay.
And and how do we feel about that change
to one on the second day when people are
accustomed to being able to call later?
In this moment, where are we?
>> And do you need all the way back to one
o'clock to have the time you really
need? Like is there a balance?
I mean, if I I think for what I've we
realized 4:30 is very tight. 430 is very
tight.
>> There's been there's been several
instances this year where we just didn't
have the time to get through the volume.
Um
>> yeah, 4:30 is very tight.
>> You know, one there there's not like a
whole team just to be clear. There's
there's literally one person, you know,
that's kind of managing this uh on our
behalf. Uh and then as support is
required, we we back him. Mhm.
>> Um but you know it's it's it's not a a
large group. So so really um more time
is helpful. If one doesn't work then
maybe get to 2 o'clock but I I would
really get worried about kind of getting
closer. We are adding more hours total.
>> No one's arguing with one. I think we're
good with one,
>> right?
>> One.
>> Yeah. We were saying not to move it back
to 11:45, but keep it started earlier.
>> Make it 7:45 to 1.
>> Yeah. 7. That would you'd be fine with
that?
>> Because teachers can't do it during
their working day. They can do it during
lunch and they can do it before school.
>> Yes.
>> That covers lunch and before school for
most
>> staff. Yeah.
>> Okay. How how do we feel?
>> Okay. Okay. And then I think the
question is just uh if you could let us
know really clearly how you'll be
sharing it with the community and in
this moment just making sure we share it
kind of widely and in a bunch of
different ways and understanding that
our community is
um not just people who get email from
schools and are connected by text, but
our community, we've heard from neighbor
neighborhood associations today. We're
hearing from grandparents. We're hearing
from people um who aren't necessarily
going to be on a list and and I don't
know if KUT would make an announcement
if you know the Statesman would print a
small notice you know we could put it on
our marquees I don't know what but I
think just making sure our community is
aware in a moment when we don't want to
give anyone a reason to believe that
we're trying to keep from hearing from
our community that we're trying to
actually make it more effective um and
more supportive of our staff. So, okay.
Thank you.
>> I guess one question I have is the is it
possible to say put an I'm looking at
Kenneth an effective date. Um, or would
that not be appropriate? I certainly
recognize that, you know, this handbook
goes effective the minute y'all vote on
it. So, is there, you know, should we
wait till like, you know, I mean, it'll
be the next couple board meetings. We'll
we'll make it work if we have to, but
could we say starting
December 1st, 2025,
that gives community certainty over the
next several meetings before we get
through some bigger votes and then we
start kind of at the end of the semester
into the new year with a those bigger
votes behind us, but then you know, so I
don't want to create any confusion in
our community. Certainly, I don't want
to disrupt things, but long term this
would be the preferred solution. But I
certainly recognize
>> well who I guess I'm cur whose authority
is this because it's also in beed
regulation as an administrative decision
and it's in our handbook as a board. So
really who's
who's I mean which comes first changing
the board handbook or changing the beed
regulation?
>> A handbook I would say if you're going
to vote on the handbook the regulations
not something you'd vote on.
>> Okay. Um, so if you vote on the handbook
to say this is how we want to do it
going forward and administratively they
say they pick a date of when that's
going to be
>> effective. Yeah, I think it that's an
administrative decision in my opinion.
>> Okay. So I could do that. So we could
the board could approve it and then I
could have an effective date to be delay
effective later than when the handbook
is approved just to address that concern
because it is a concern about
>> Yeah. I mean, if you need time to
transition, the process is pretty big
and affects a huge amount of people. So,
>> yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And can you get the support you need to
make get this done? Like an extra person
to help.
>> Yeah.
>> When we know the volume's going to be
big for a bit.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, we were.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. Uh we good with that?
>> Okay. And then we will um part of the
order of operations is that once we
approve the scorecard, we will amend we
the handbook also to have our updated
scorecard, updated calendar, all of
that. Okay, thank you. Um next one and
we are almost finished. Um
that's it for that. So anything else in
this section to talk about board
administration? Those are all the
deliverables we have. Um Ashley,
correct?
That's correct.
>> Okay. Thank you very much for um helping
us through that and um I know you've had
a lot of very clear lists and and
information. So, thank you. Um
and we'll be glad to have that ticked
and tied. Okay. Um next is agenda
preview for business and finance. Any
questions?
I know Trusty Singh has requested that
the budget development calendar be
pulled at our meeting for a separate
vote. Trusty Singh, do you have anything
you want to share about that right now?
>> Yeah. Um, there were a few things I
guess I wanted to ask the administration
if they could um
talk, you know, I'm happy to mention the
things that I had had raised um but if
you wanted to
>> Yeah. kind of share what you'd be
willing, you know, your your thoughts on
the the issues that that I had raised.
>> Yeah. Um so there were certainly some uh
milestones we wanted to um incorporate
into the calendar and the administration
is happy to to accommodate um the ones
that were were pretty straightforward.
The one that I I want to make sure our
trustees um are aware of and and
certainly one that the administration is
supportive of is creating milestones um
around the work associated with the
progression of the academic vision
framework. Um because really what we're
talking about is consolidations and and
we've talked about you know the need to
progress the academic vision academic
framework academic philosophy and we've
gone with we've talked about that for
quite some time and because of all the
pressures and because of the time
required uh it's kind of gotten to a
point now where we want to make some
meaningful progress um but we know that
we can't complete you know a year and a
half effort or a year effort in you know
in in weeks time and so Um it's a
commitment for the administration to
have certainty in that work and identify
certain milestones that um create
consensus around why we're doing what
we're going to do uh as far as freeing
up resources to to ensure that we have
um well resourced schools to provide a a
learning experience that meet the
expectations of the board and the
administration. Um but having that as a
milestone so our trustees know hey when
we v vote on this budget it's going to
include for 2627
um reductions tied to some difficult
decisions we're going to make and we're
doing that because this is what we
believe in. So so that's what trustee
Singh and I talked about. Um there was
Dr. Maxwell and I have had m a couple
conversations about kind of what the
work looks like. like I know we've
socialized it uh with some trustees um
and and so we're prepared to take that
work forward but that's what trustee
Singh um and I have been talking about
so we wanted to bring that to the board
just so that there's awareness and we'll
make those adjustments and then um work
uh to to get the work done or progress
>> and I would say just to um so just to
clarify my specific I'll just go down my
specific proposed amendments one was on
row 4 to add something like FA phase one
of the baseline academic um plan and
associated budget would be part of the
package um that comes to us as part of
the consolidation plan. So so that was
the the very specific request there. Uh
that is something that we've been
talking about for months. It's like, you
know, folks need to know that there's
going to be an exchange. You know, if we
close some schools, what's going to
happen? And I know that the idea here is
like, okay, we're going to be
financially more stable and we can
strengthen our neighborhood schools, but
this is putting some specificity around
that and it is derived directly from our
long range plan. And so I think that's
um so that that was the one request is
to include the baseline academic uh
program as part of road 24 as part of
that consolidation plan that we vote on
in November. Um and then the other thing
I wanted to see in here was um whatever
the next phase like at the phase two of
that baseline academic plan because I
know that is a large lift and so you
know if there is something that we can
vote on um with the associated budget so
people can see okay we say we're saving
this much money by closing schools and
this is what it's freeing up to do to
strengthen our schools or to strengthen
our district that needs to That
connection I think is going to be really
helpful for us to ensure that we are
meeting our scorecard goals that we are
drawing a direct line between school
consolidations and student outcomes and
that's the way to do it. Um and then I
would the other requests were for um
adding somewhere maybe in December 2025
um board approval of a three-year plan
to restore the fund balance to 20%. I
don't know what the actual date would be
for that, but I don't want to lose that.
When we voted for this um budget in
June, we said, you know, basically, and
when we changed our policy to the 15%
fund balance, we were pretty clear that
the administration would bring to us a
three-year plan to restore the fund
balance. And so, I did not see that in
the the budget calendar for this year.
So, I wanted to make sure that was in
there. Um, I also wanted to I noticed
that there were several references to
the budget ad hoc committee and I but
there weren't any deliverables
associated with it and I think that's
really important for whatever they're
going to be charged to do. Um, that we
include those milestones in there so
that the board can know what to expect
coming out of the budget ad hoc
committee. Um, also there was a request
to add a vote on the consultation
agreement a month prior to the budget
vote. Um, that would give us enough time
um to make an attention for that because
that is such a huge part of the budget
and um it is a practice that we've had
in the past in the district and one I
wanted to have us all consider. Um, so
again, these are proposed amendments,
you know, and and so I think that it
would warrant some um I I would hope
that it would warrant some discussion.
>> Yeah. Uh, Trusty Seeing um so the um
three-year um budget um
unassigned fund balance recovery plan.
So Katrina McGomery and I have been
talking about that. I I I have a plan.
and I have not lost, trust me, that is
the last thing I've lost track of. Um,
so, uh, we we've already been planning
through I I think the challenge we had
is we kind of started from a traditional
budget and there are things that
typically wouldn't fall on the budget
that we're now going to be kind of
aligning and we understand why that
makes sense. Um, so so we will be sure
to to make sure that we hit those
milestones. I also would want to be
really really clear. I don't want the
message to be that because we're
consolidating all of a sudden we will
get all of these things. Um we're
operating at a budget deficit now. So we
can't afford what we have now. I just to
be really clear. So it will be a step it
step towards um multiple steps you know
as we get to a stable budget as we get
aligned and and continue to provide
quality education and actually even
improve it. So, I I just want to be
really really clear because I don't want
the community or trustees to to to think
that oh, if if we could do all of these
things and all of a sudden this will
happen in the next year. We if that if
we were baseline then that would be the
case because we'd free up funds and be
able to allocate those funds. In this
case, we're operating from a deficit.
So, we have to make up that deficit and
then um take the next step. So, um I
hear you. Um, but that is why I think
the academic work is important because
it tells you that there's multiple steps
to get there. Everything we're doing is
in is kind of in that vein to move
further. Um, but I'm just going to
continue to reinforce that just because
I I I I think it can get lost sometimes.
But yes, no. Um, we will make
adjustments. Um, I I hear you. Um,
Katrina have already talked about many
of these. Uh um I'll have to some maybe
proposals back for the amendments to the
because of how I think they maybe could
align a little bit um if that's helpful.
>> Okay, good. Thank you. Anything else on
the budget calendar? Anything else in
section 9? All right. Anything in uh
section 10 facilities?
Getting a bunch of new buses. Um
anything in agenda uh section 11 talent
strategy?
Okay. CH uh 12 policy
I want to flag um under AE local that is
another thing that we owed um this month
for Lonear governance um kind of
cleanup. uh we had to change ae local
educational philosophy to remove a lot
of things that were um considered advice
and make lots of other changes. You have
a red line redlined version um and again
that one will be an order of operations
issue um or we are no our
um scorecard and calendar will go into
it as um exhibits. So that will be
included after we vote on that to amend
that. Okay. Anything uh any conversation
for agenda preview other?
All right. Um
and I do notice in other there's 13.6
which looks like talent strategy a
termination
13.6 six, but it's under other
>> for a separate conversation. Okay, thank
you. Um Okay, good. Uh okay, that is it.
This will end our regular agenda
preview. Um and now we will now recess
the open meeting at 11:30 p.m. Move to
executive session pursuant to Texas
Government Code sections 551.074,
551.072,
551.073,
551.087,
551.076, 076 551.0821
and 551.071.
When we finish with the executive
session, we will briefly return to the
open session to formally adjourn the
meeting. The adjournment will be
recorded and will be included in all
replays of tonight's meeting. Thank you
for joining us and have a good evening.
Uh and thank you all for being here with
us.
We will now reconvene into the open
meeting at 1:51 a.m.
Secretary uh Secretary Gonzalez, do I
have a motion to adjourn the meeting? So
moved.
Uh the meeting is adjourned at 1:51